MY COLLEAGUES HOPEFULLY -- WITH
ME GOBBLING DOWN OUT WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL COLLEAGUES JOIN BUT
SINCE IT'S AN INFORMATION
HEARING.
I'M GOING TO GET STARTED BECAUSE
WE HAVE A FULL AGENDA I KNOW WE
HAVE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
TODAY -- AND I INTEND. TO KEEP
THE TRAINS MOVING IN THIS
MORNING.
MY SON SAYS WHEN I NANCY LIKE
THAT HE KNOWS I'M VERY SERIOUS.
SO I HOPE EVERYONE ELSE.
UNDERSTANDS THAT AS WELL AND
TEARS TO KEEP THE TRAINS MOVING --
GOOD MORNING AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US LET ME START BY
SAYING HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO JAMES.
THE BIRTHDAY CHANGE.
THIS HEARING COLLEAGUES WILL
COVER AN IMPORTANT SUBJECT.
A CRITICAL ONE TO ALL OF US
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IF YOU'RE LIKE ME IT'S THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE YOU RECEIVE
CALLS ABOUT IN YOUR DISTRICT
OFFICE AND THAT'S THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
THE DMV IS ONE OF THE PRIMARY
CONNECTION POINT BETWEEN
RESIDENTS OF THIS STATE.
AND THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT.
OVER THE LAST YEAR A SERIES OF
ROLLING CRISES HAVE IMPACTED THE
DEPARTMENT AND DAMAGE THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST.
WAIT TIMES IN DMV FIELD OFFICES
ROLES TO UNACCEPTABLE LEVELS
VOTER REGISTRATION DATA WAS
MISHANDLED AND QUESTIONS REMAIN
ABOUT WHETHER THE STATE WILL BE
ABLE TO DELIVER ON THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FEDERAL REAL
ID ACT.
WHICH WILL HEAR ABOUT MORE IN A
MINUTE.
THESE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ARE
SMEAR SYMPTOMS OF A LARGER
SYSTEMIC.
ISSUE.
A NUMBER OF AUDITS IN PROGRAM
REVIEW
[inaudible]
START.
NEXT REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
DMB STRIKE TEAM LED BY SECRETARY
BADGER WILL DISCUSS THE FINDINGS
OF THEIR RESPECTIVE REVIEWS OF
THE DEPARTMENT.
AND LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT WILL
PRESENT DIFFERENT POLLS THE
PROPOSED RESPONSE TO THESE
ISSUES IN THEIR BUDGET PROPOSALS
THAT ARE INDEED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE.
AFTER WE CONCLUDE OUR PANEL
DISCUSSES WILL OPEN THE FOR FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
LET ME CLEAR.
FIVE AND ASK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO FAMILIARIZE
YOURSELF WITH THE AGENDA AND THE
PANELS AND HOW THEY'VE BEEN
SEPARATED.
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU POSE YOUR QUESTIONS TO THE
APPROPRIATE PANEL SOMETIMES WHEN
WE START WITH THE LA L. AND THEY
START WITH A HIGH LEVEL WE FOCUS
ALL OF OUR QUESTIONS -- ON THE
FIRST PRESENTER AND I THINK
THAT'S NOT THE BEST USE OF OUR
TIME TODAY.
AGAIN -- LET'S BE CLEAR THAT --
CHAIR EXCEPT TO SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HE HAS THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE DMV AND
THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS TO DELVE MORE DEEPLY
INTO THE PARTICULARS OF THE
SPECIFICS OF WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED -- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
AND AGAIN COLLEAGUES THIS ISN'T
OUR ONLY OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
IN THIS CONVERSATION -- HELP OR
GET CLEARLY FROM ANY STATE
DEPARTMENT DON'T JUST HAVE TO
GET IT ALL IN A BUDGET HEARING
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH OUT TO LEADERSHIP.
IN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
DEPARTMENTS IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
I WILL INVITE -- MISLI PRINCIPLE
FISCAL POLICY ANALYST AT THE
LEGEND ONCE OFFICE TO COME
FORWARD.
BEFORE YOU GET STARTED MOSTLY SO
THAT IT WILL MEMBERS JOIN US.
HOME I WANT TO JUST REITERATE
THE COLLEAGUES I ASK THAT YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE GENDA -- AND
SO YOU'RE CLEAR ABOUT WHO WILL
BE PRESENTING A WHT PANELS AND
SO YOUR QUESTIONS CAN BE
DIRECTED TO THE APPROPRIATE
PANEL.
I'M ALSO GOING TO USE -- THE
DISCRETION OF THE CHAIR --
BECAUSE WE HAVE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TODAY AND I'M GOING TO
SUGGEST THAT WE HAVE A HARD STOP
AT NOON AND SO I'VE SAID EARLIER
BEFORE YOU ALL JOIN THIS THAT I
INTEND TO KEEP THE TRAINS ON
TIME.
TODAY EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING ANY DAILY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
US TO PRESENT BEFORE YOU --
STAFF FASTEST TO PRESENT ON THIS
FIRST PANEL SOME BACKGROUND TO
SET THE FOUNDATION FOR YOUR
DISCUSSION TODAY.
THE SERGEANTS WILL HAVE
DISTRIBUTED A HANDOUT THAT OUR
OFFICES PREPARED IN THIS FIRST
PANEL WILL BE COVERING PAGES ONE
THROUGH FIVE OF THE HAND OUT.
AND THEN THE REMAINDER OF THE
HANDLE WILL BE COVERING WHEN WE
COME BACK TO YOU AS PART OF
PANEL THREE THANK YOU.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE OF
YOUR HAND OUT WE FIRST WANT TO
START WITH A REALLY HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF REALIZE THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE IMPACT ON
DIEM THE OPERATIONS.
THE FEDERAL REAL ID ACT -- FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIVE REQUIRED THAT
STATE ISSUED DRIVER'S LICENSES
AND IDENTIFICATION CARDS.
MEETS THE MINIMUM IDENTITY
VERIFICATION AND SECURITY
STANDARDS IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
BE USED FOR OFFICIAL PURPOSES
THE KEY DATE THAT WE WANT TO
KEEP IN MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IS OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
BECAUSE THIS IS THE DATE BY
WHICH IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
COMPLIANT LICENSE.
A CARD YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO
PROVIDE AN ALTERNATIVE FORM OF
ID TO BOARD A DOMESTIC AIRPLANE.
SO -- CALIFORNIA BE AN ISSUE A
REAL ID'S AT THE BEGINNING OF
LAST YEAR JANUARY OF LAST YEAR
AND THROUGH THE END OF THIS
FEBRUARY HAD ISSUED ABOUT THREE
POINT ONE MILLION REAL ID'S.
AND GETTING A REAL ID REQUIRES
THAT INDIVIDUALS COME INTO THE
FIELD OFFICE AND PROVIDE --
CERTAIN DOCUMENTS TO BE VERIFIED
AND KIND OF DOCUMENTED SO THIS
REALLY LEAD TO AN INCREASE IN
DIEM THE WORKLOAD IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
PROCESS DRIVERS LICENSES AND ID
CARDS CROW.
TAKES A LITTLE BIT LONGER AND ON
TOP OF THAT YOU ALSO HAD PEOPLE
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD STATE OUT OF
THE FIELD OFFICE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD RENEW BY MAIL OR WHO HAVE
CARDS LICENSES THAT EXPIRE AFTER
THE OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY DATE.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OF YOUR
HAND OUT.
THE STATE DID PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO HELP WITH THIS
WORKLOAD BUT DESPITE THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
ON THE WAIT TIMES BEGAN TO
INCREASE AND THEY REALLY HAD IF
HE CAN KIND OF THE SUMMER WHEN
SOME INDIVIDUALS WERE WAITING A
FEW HOURS.
AND THE LAW THE DMV RESPONDED BY
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WHICH WILL GET TO SHORTLY --
HIRING TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES
SHIFTING RECORD ON THE FIELD
OFFICES SUCH AS LIKE USING SELF
SERVICE TERMINALS ETCETERA.
AND TO DATE THE WAIT TIMES HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT DOWN TO UNDER AN
HOUR.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE OF
YOUR HAND OUT THIS PROVIDES A
SUMMARY OF THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO DATE.
SO THE BECAUSE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY IN THE WORKLOAD THE
STATE PROVIDED.
MONEY IN BOTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SPECIFICALLY TWENTY
THREE MILLION FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. TO SUPPORT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN POSITIONS
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND FORTY SIX POINT SIX MILLION
TO SUPPORT FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY POSITIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ADDITIONALLY THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
INCLUDED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING PROVIDED TO DMV.
UPON THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE RECEIVED THREE
LETTERS TO DATE -- UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF THAT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE.
THE FIRST WAS REQUESTED AN
APPROVED IN AUGUST IT WAS FOR
SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. TO REDUCE WAIT TIMES
AND SUPPORT -- ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY POSITION.
IN TOTAL THAT BROADER EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FUNDING LEVELS TO SIXTY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION AND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
POSITIONS.
AND WHEN THE ADMINISTRATION
PRESENTED ITS JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WAS THAT PLACE
HOLDER NUMBER THAT YOU SAW.
THERE ARE TWO OTHER REQUESTS AS
YOU AS YOU SEE LISTED BEFORE YOU.
ON THE LEGISLATURE HAS BASICALLY
THROUGH THE END OF APRIL TO
EVALUATE THEM -- ONE IS FOUR
FORTY POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY POSITIONS AND
TO MAINTAIN ALL ACTIVITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED SO FAR.
IN ORDER TO KEEP WAIT TIMES DOWN.
THE SECOND REQUEST TO THE VERY
BOTTOM OF THIS PAGE IS FOR SIX
MILLION DOLLARS AND THESE REALLY
PERTAIN TO ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
ALSO KIND OF PRESENTED IN YOUR
APRIL FINANCE LETTER. TO THE BIG
EXAMPLE IS THAT FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THE SIX MILLION IS TO
HIRE AND TRAIN THREE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES
pREQUESTED AS PART OF THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET PROPOSAL.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR OF YOUR
HAND OUT.
WE'VE JUST PROVIDE A VERY HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
PROPOSAL YOU'LL BE HEARING ABOUT
THEM IN MORE DETAIL.
AS PART OF YOUR SITE I BELIEVE
YOUR THIRD PANEL BUT AT A HIGH
LEVEL.
THE EVIL FINANCE LETTER REQUESTS
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT TO SUPPORT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE PERMANENT POSITIONS.
ABOUT NINETEEN HUNDRED TEMPORARY
POSITIONS AND A WIDE RANGE OF
OTHER ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
CONSULTANTS -- FOR ASSESSMENTS
AS WELL AS IMPLEMENTING KIND OF
LIVE CHAT CUSTOMER SERVICE --
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT IS A MULTI YEAR REQUEST IT'S
NOT JUST FOR FOR FOR ONE YEAR IT
X. IT DOES RATCHET DOWN BUT IT
EXTENDS INTO THE FUTURE.
AND FINALLY THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES A SIMILAR PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO AUGMENT
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET UPON
THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION TO JAIL
BC.
TURNING TO PAGE FIVE OF YOUR
HAND OUT WE DIDN'T WANT TO KIND
OF HIGHLIGHT FOR THE COMMITTEE.
A NUMBER OF THE VALUATIONS THAT
ARE ONGOING IMPENDING AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
WILL GENERALLY BE HEARING ABOUT
RECOMMENDATIONS -- THAT ARE KIND
OF ROLLING OUT ESSENTIALLY OVER
THE SUMMER INTO THE FALL.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE DMV
PERFORMANCE AUDIT THAT WAS JUST
RECENTLY COMPLETED -- YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM THEM IN YOUR NEXT
PANEL BUT THEY DID RAISE SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
SOME OF THE UNDERLYING
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE SECOND IS THE DMV
REINVENTION TEAM STRIKE FORCE
TEAM THAT STARTED ITS WORK IN
JANUARY AND CONTINUES ITS WORK
TODAY YOU'LL AGAIN HERE FROM NOW
ON YOUR SECOND PANEL.
THE THIRD -- ONE WAS RECENTLY
STARTED IN MARCH IT WAS A
CONTRACT BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES AND MCKINSEY
AND COMPANY -- IN THIS
ENGAGEMENT IS FOR ABOUT FIVE TO
EIGHT MONTHS AND CAN BE WILL BE
TASKED WITH KIND OF EVALUATING --
STAFF TRAINING ON REAL ID HOW
REAL ID PROCESS SEES -- OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD OFFICES
AS WELL AS HOW STAFF ARE TRAINED
AND THESE ARE EXPECTED TO CAST
KIND OF PROTOTYPE -- SUGGESTIONS
OF RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH WILL
THEN BE USED TO INFORM FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL BE
PRESENTED FOR KIND OF
CONSIDERATION.
THE FINAL ASPECT IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES TO
CREATE A NEW OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY.
TASK OF THIS NEW OFFICE IS
REALLY TO DEVELOP --
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO REASSESS HOW THEY
PROVIDE SERVICE DELIVERY MODELS
TO RE ENGINEER BUSINESS PROCESS
SEES -- TO ADDRESS CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND TO LEVERAGE DIGITAL
INNOVATION AND TOOLS WHERE
APPROPRIATE.
AND SO -- THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THAT DMB WOULD LIKELY
BE ONE OF THE OFFICES FIRST
CLIENTS ESSENTIALLY.
THE WITHOUT WORK AND OUR
COMMENTS ON BACKGROUND AS A
MENTION PREVIOUSLY WHEN I START
THE COMMENTS THE REMAINDER OF
THE HANDOUT WILL COVER -- AS
PART OF YOUR THIRD PANEL.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU MEMBERS DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
MISLEAD BASED ON THE
PRESENTATION SHE HAS JUST GIVEN
US.
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A
QUICK QUESTION ON PAGE THREE OF
THE FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION TO
HIRE AND TRAIN THREE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL TEMPORARY POSITIONS.
WHEN YOU SAY TEMPORARY WHAT IS
THAT TIME FRAME?
WOULD THEY BE THERE FOR SIX
MONTHS A YEAR A MONTH.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BETTER
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES WE HAVE
RESTRICTIONS ON A CIVIL SERVICE
RESTRICTIONS IN TERMS OF THAT
TIME FRAME FOR WHICH EMPLOYEES
CAN BE HIRED.
ON AND SO THEY'LL BE A BETTER
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY PLAN TO
LEVERAGE THEIR RESOURCES.
OKAY.
I WILL ASK THAT WILL OUTSIDE OF
THE ACTING DIRECTOR WILL BE THE
FIRST QUESTION UP IN THE FOR THE
THIRD PANEL THINKING MAN THAT'S
MINE THANK YOU.
QUESTION SENATOR STONE OF THE LA
L. BASED ON WHAT SHE'S JUST
PRESENT IT THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU -- I GOT HER A LITTLE
BIT LATE.
THE WHOLE PRESENTATION OF IT ARE
YOU.
IT IS A DMV FINDING A LOT OF
CONFUSION -- WITH REGARD TO THE
DOCUMENTATION THAT IS REQUIRED
FOR THE SAFE ID ARE YOU AWARE OF
THAT AT ALL.
THE DMV WILL PROBABLY BE ABLE TO
SPEAK MORE.
ACCURATELY AND KIND OF A MORE UP
TO DATE ON THAT I WILL SAY IN
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE IN
TALKING TO THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS HEARING FROM THE VARIOUS
EVALUATIONS SO THAT HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED -- KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
WHAT INFORMATION A WHAT
DOCUMENTS TO PROVIDE WHAT IS
NEEDED IS SOMETHING THAT IS HAS
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A CHALLENGE.
OKAY BECAUSE IT -- I'M HEARING
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION
ABOUT WHAT YOU SHOULD BRING A
PASSPORT OR A SOCIAL SECURITY
CARD OR WHAT SUFFICES AND SO
WITH THE DMV MIGHT BE BETTER
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION ASK
MISS WEB TO ADDRESS THAT -- SHE
JOINS THE PANEL WHICH IS THE
THIRD PANEL THANK YOU RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
CENTER NIELSEN.
AND READ OVER THE THE DOCUMENT
I'VE GOT HERE LATE AS WELL.
BUT LET ME JUST ASK YOU A
GENERAL QUESTION [inaudible]
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE DMV
ARE NOT NEW.
I'M FAMILIAR WITH THEM FOR
DECADES.
NOW WOULD IT BE YOUR OPINION
THAT A CERTAIN NUMBER OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED THERE WILL BE
PRESENTED HERE.
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO DEAL
WITH.
OUR OUR THE ENDEMIC IN AND
INSTITUTIONALIZED.
WILL IT TAKE A LOT OF DOING.
THAT ON WIND THAT SORT OF
CORPORATE MENTALITY AND
STRUCTURE WITHIN THAT DEPARTMENT
THAT HAS BEEN SO PERVASIVE AND
PERSISTENT.
AND SO FRUSTRATING FOR THE
CITIZEN FOR SO LONG.
THERE IS CERTAINLY UNDERLYING
STRUCTURAL ISSUES AND IT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
EXPECTATIONS THEY HAVE FOR THE
DMV THAT CAN INCLUDE -- HOW THE
EXPECTS THE DMV TO PROVIDE
SERVICES WHAT GOALS AND KIND OF
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT THEY
HAVE IN MIND? ONE OF THE THINGS
A LITTLE WITH THAT WE'LL GET TO
WHEN WE PRESENT ON YOUR THIRD
PANEL IS THAT WE DO THINK
SOMETHING TE LEGISLATURE WILL
WANT TO CONSIDER.
IS THE ISSUE OF ACTIVITIES THAT
HAVE SHORT TERM IMPACTS VERSUS
THOSE THAT HAVE LONG TERM
IMPACTS.
IN BY THAT.
THE STATE IS SEEKING TO MEET
THIS OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
DEADLINE AND THEIR CERTAIN
ACTIONS THAT WILLREALLY HELP.
WILL REALLY HELP MEET THAT
DEADLINE. FOR SOME OF THE LONGER
TERM ACTIONS -- RATHER THAN KIND
OF APPROACHING IT SORT OF IN A
PIECEMEAL MANNER IT MAY MAKE
MORE SENSE TO HAVE THE ENVY AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS COME TOGETHER
AND REALLY THINK THROUGH.
KIND OF A LONG TERM KIND OF
STRATEGIC OR OPERATIONAL PLAN TO
REALLY LAY OUT WHAT THE STEPS
ARE. TO ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
SYSTEMIC CHANGES -- THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT ARE FACED SOME OF
THEM WE CAN POTENTIALLY BE VERY
EXPENSIVE SO FOR EXAMPLE I THINK
THAT THERE BEEN CONCERNS ABOUT
IT CAPABILITIES UNDERLYING ID
CAPABILITIES ETCETERA.
WE KNOW FROM OTHER BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS THAT IT -- PROJECTS
ARE FAIRLY EXPENSIVE BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES DEPARTMENTAL RESOURCES
AND SO THAT SOMETHING OFF TO
KIND OF KEEP IN MIND AS THE
DEPARTMENT IS.
KIND OF THINKING THROUGH CHANGES
YOU HAVE KIND OF A LIMITED FOR
EXAMPLE EXECUTIVE STAFF OF THE
DMV.
AND SO THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT
HOW MANY PROJECTS DO YOU WANT
MOVING AT THE SAME TIME CITY
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT THE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
CONSIDER AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE BE VERY
DIRECTORY AT THIS TIME.
IN WHATEVER WE SUGGEST TO THIS
YEAR TO DMV TELLING THEM WHAT WE
EXPECT NOT TELLING.
HIM THAT HAVING THEM TELL US
WHAT THEY INTEND TO DO. TO GET
TO THE CORE.
PROBLEMS I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO BE REQUIRED AS WELL AS
VERY -- IN DEPTH AND SUSTAINED
MONITORING.
OF THE AGENCY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF THINK IS UNTIL FOR THE
AND I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU I
THINK THAT ALSO REQUIRES THAT WE
AS LEGISLATORS ARE INFORMED
ABOUT.
WHAT'S FEASIBLE AND WHAT TO DO
WILL PULL THAT WE DO A BETTER
JOB AS LEGISLATORS TO REALLY
FIND THE MILLION TO STAND WHAT
IT TAKES TO GO TO TO CREATE
CULTURE SHIFT.
AND TO AND TO FINANCE AND DESIGN
COMPUTER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CURRENT AND RELEVANT GOING FOR
IT WE WE HAVE HOMEWORK IN THE
MORNING TO DO OURSELVES.
SENATOR PAN.
CARE TO SURVIVE SHE FOLLOWS UP
ON THE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS IN
THE QUESTION AS WELL SO CAN YOU
JUST MAKE YOU SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY
AS TO WHAT YOU SEE.
THE ELLIE OWES ROLE IN HELPING
US -- ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES IN THE SENSE THAT.
WE ARE FACING SO MANY Q. CRISIS
BUT THIS IS PRIDE BUILT ON
CHRONIC ISSUES THAT CUMULATED
OVER TIME INCLUDING YOU KNOW AT
OLD VERY OLD ANTIQUATED --
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS.
AND THE RECOGNIZING EVEN THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE LIMITED TERMS
AND SO FORTH -- WHAT AND WHAT
YOU WHAT YOU SEE IS -- LA OWES
ROLE IN HELPING US THAT AYE
GUIDING US IN TERMS OF BE ON THE
MONITOR.
OVER THE LONG TERM -- VERY
SPANISH MARKS THAT -- WE THAT
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATORS HAVE
EXPECTED THE DMV TO TRY TO HIT
OUR WEATHER WE MADE INVESTMENTS
AND HOW THEY TURNED OUT --
BECAUSE MAYBE IS NOW THREE OR
FIVE YEARS LATER AND PEOPLE
DON'T REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
THREE OR FIVE YEARS AGO.
SURE -- I THINK KIND OF HOW WE
ENVISION OUR FIRST ROLE ACTUALLY --
BE PRESENTED TO YOU LATER ON AS
PART OF TOWN FOR A WE THINK ARE
KIND OF FIRST ROLE IS THIS IS
THERE IS TRANSIT PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHOICES THAT
NEED TO BE MADE HERE.
SO OUR ROLE AS WE SEE IT AS PART
OF YOUR THIRD PANEL IS TO
PROVIDE SOME THOUGHTS IN TERMS
OF HOW TO THINK THROUGH. TO HOLD
THE LEGISLATURE THINK THROUGH AN
WAY THE KEY FACTOR.
I THINK IT WAS FUNNY I
APPRECIATE THE OPTIONS AND SO
FORTH BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF
YOUR HEALTH AND RATE RECOGNIZING
THEIR SOME LIMITATIONS TO HOW
MANY RESOURCES LA -- HAS IN
TERMS OF HELPING MONITOR --
BEYOND JUST THE AGENCY ITSELF
REPORTING TO US.
OUR THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE MADE
THE POLICY THAT THE POLICIES
THAT WE HAVE PASSED TODAY
ACHIEVE THEIR AIMS.
SEVERAL YEARS LATER SIGNED AND
THAT THE SO IT'S GOING TO POLICY
OPTIONS BUT IT'S ACTUALLY THE
FOLLOW THROUGH.
WELL ALSO IN LINE WITH THAT FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HIGHLIGHT AS AN ISSUE FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION IS
THAT WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT
CLEAR OUT COMING PERFORMANCE
GOALS.
ARE NEEDED IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
YOU AIMING FOR WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH AND WE'RE NOT
REALLY SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
ACTUALLY CLEARLY LAYS OUT.
HIS SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING WHERE WE CAN CERTAINLY
WORK WITH STAFF AND MEMBERS TO
KIND OF DEFINE WHAT THOSE GOALS
ARE AND ONCE THOSE GOALS ARE
DEFINED.
THAT PROVIDES US WITH THE
BENCHMARKS OF FOR EXAMPLE IF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY TO THEN ADVISE YOU ON
AND YOU KNOW DO THAT ANALYSIS ON
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S BEING
ACCOMPLISHED I MEAN THAT THAT'S
AN EXAMPLE.
I THINK IN OTHER AREAS -- YOU
KNOW THINKING ABOUT WHAT LEVEL
OF OVERSIGHT.
THE LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE LEGISLATURE
CURRENTLY RECEIVES THESE ANNUAL
REPORTS ON WAIT TIMES.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
BOTH KIND OF SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM OPTIONS HE COULD INVOLVE
DIFFERENT REPORTING LANGUAGE
REGULAR REPORTING COMMITTEE
MONTHLY QUARTERLY THERE'S NO
KIND OF MAGICAL NUMBER.
BUT IT INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
LAYING OUT WHAT ACTIVITIES OR
PROJECTS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING IMPLEMENTED WHAT'S NEXT UP
IN THE QUEUE WHAT -- CHALLENGES
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AND THAT
REALLY HELPS US -- YOU KNOW KEEP
IT HELPS US INTO THE LEGISLATURE
KEEP UP TO DATE ON WHAT'S
OCCURRING AND WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT JUMPS OUT
AS BEING.
A FLAT.
I THINK SEPARATELY FROM THAT AND
YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT --
THE LITTLE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE INTERESTED IN A
VALUE AND HAVING US ABOUT A
PARTICULAR IDEAS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT I MEAN THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE WITH.
THANK YOU -- WE'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THE WAIT TIMES I HAVE ONE
GENERAL QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO THE SECOND.
AND I'LL COME BACK YOU CENTER
STONE.
CAN YOU GIVE US A GENERAL IDEA
OF WHAT STATES HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB OF COMPLYING WITH THE REAL
ID.
KIND OF ROLL OUT AND PLANNING
TODAY.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I HAVE NOT
SPEND VERY MUCH TIME ON BUT I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THE SECRETARY
OF THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY AS PART OF THEIR DMB
REINVENTION TRACK TEAM ACTUALLY
SPENT TIME.
REACHING OUT TO COUNTERPARTS IN
DOING THAT AND ALSO SO I THINK
THEY'LL BE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
SPEAK PERFECT ALL RIGHT TO THIS
TOWN.
THAT WAS PART OF MY QUESTION
MADAM CHAIR BUT AS A LOOK
THROUGH THE REPORT.
IT LOOKS AS THOUGH -- SINCE WE
STARTED THE PHYSICIANS AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE'VE.
INCREASED THE POSITION BY ALMOST
A THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED BY MY
CALCULATIONS -- I WANTED TO FIND
OUT IN OTHER STATES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN USING -- TECHNOLOGY TO TO
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
NECESSARY FOR THE REAL ID BUT
THE REAL IDEAS REALLY -- STIFLED
OTHER OPERATIONS WITH THE DMV
BECAUSE OF THE WORKLOAD SO --
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS A DIGITAL WHILE
PROGRAM THAT HE WANTS -- TO TO
EMBRACE AND AND AND MOVE FORWARD.
DOES THE LA -- DO ANY KIND OF
ANALYSIS.
TO SEE IF THERE IS TECHNOLOGICAL
MEANS THAT WE CAN USE THAT CAN
IT WILL ALWAYS SEEM TO THROW
MONEY IN POSITIONS AT A PROBLEM.
BUT IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE THE
MANPOWER IT'S NECESSARY IT'S THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS REALLY GOING
TO STREAMLINED SERVICE AT THE
DMV.
SO HAVE YOU EVALUATED THE THE
NEEDS OF THE DMV TECHNOLOGICALLY
TO MAKE THEM ON MORE EFFICIENT.
MAKE THEM RUN FASTER AND LESS
EXPENSIVE.
WE HAVE THERE'S AND THERE'S A
WIDE RANGE OF KIND OF
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS ARE
OPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
IN THESE -- BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
ARE BEING DISCUSSED TO AS PART
OF THE VALUATIONS I THINK THE
INTERESTING THING IS THAT YOU'LL
HAVE KIND OF CONSULTING
COMPANIES THAT ARE REALLY DIVING
IN FOR IN DEPTH TO DO THIS AND
THIS IS LAST MINUTE -- I THINK
FROM OUR VIEWPOINT WE HAVE
ASSESSED TECHNOLOGY TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY WERE PART OF A
BUDGET PROPOSAL SO FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES FIRST.
WITH CONSIDERING THE SELF
SERVICE TERMINALS WE DID
EVALUATE THAT PROPOSAL AND AND
KIND OF OFFER RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THAT.
THERE ARE A WIDE RANGE OF THAT --
IDEAS BEING.
OFFERED NOW I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS A
REINVENTION TRACK TEAM ARE
CONSIDERING YOU'VE GOT
CONSULTANTS ETCETERA.
AND SO I THINK PART OF THOSE
EVALUATION WILL REALLY HELP
INFORM THIS DISCUSSION AND KIND
OF DETERMINE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO FOCUS ITS
ATTENTION.
AND I WOULD I WOULD ALSO KIND OF
KICK IT BACK TO THIS LARGER
ISSUE OF IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO KIND OF
SPECIFIED HOW IT ENVISIONS DMV
OPERATING AND OFFERING SERVICES
WHAT DO YOU ENVISION.
DMV LOOKING LIKE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
YOUR QUESTION I SEE IT AS A HIGH
TECH AGENCY OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT WHERE PEOPLE CAN DO
AS MUCH OF THEIR BUSINESS ONLINE.
AND BY MAIL AND NOT NECESSARILY
HAVE TO GO IN AND WITH
EFFICIENCY AND AND REDUCE COSTS
WHEREVER POSSIBLE BY UTILIZING
TECHNOLOGY TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS SO I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWERS AND
REPORT TO THE PRESS ACCOUNTS.
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LOT.
MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING THE
MORNING -- MISLI JUST THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL I COME FROM
A COUNTY THAT FILED FOR CHAPTER
NINE BANKRUPTCY SO -- WE WE PUT
IN A LOT OF REFORM SOMEONE OF
THOSE REFORMS WAS PROVIDING AN
ANNUAL BUSINESS STAY FOR
BUSINESS -- REPORT FOR YOUR PLAN
FOR EACH DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT REPORT WOULD INCLUDE
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO.
HOW WE MEASURE IT?
AND HOW WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE
DOING IN THE NEXT YEAR AND AND
THEN HOW DID WE MEET THE PRIOR
YOUR SCHOOLS IMAGES JUST A IT'S
A NICE.
ROAD MAP FOR ANY SUPERVISOR
LEGISLATOR TO PICK UP.
AND SO I'M JUST CURIOUS BEING
APPEAR I HAVEN'T SEEN A BUSINESS
PLAN I BASS FORM BUT I CAN I GET.
CUTE SMILES BUT WITH THE DMV OF
HAD A BUSINESS PLAN IS SAID WE
ANTICIPATE.
THE S. THIS AMOUNT OF INCREASE
IN VOLUME.
THEREFORE WE NEED THIS AMOUNT OF
NEW EMPLOYEES WE NEED TO TRAIN
AND BY THIS AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND AND WE NEED TO INTEGRATE
THAT WITH THE STATE'S BUDGET THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND AND
AND AND DO WE HAVE THAT. FOR
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE.
I FIFTY EIGHT I THINK
DEPARTMENTS REACTS DIFFERENTLY
DEPENDING ON WHAT INITIATIVES
ARE COMING THEIR WAY WE'VE
CERTAINLY AS PART OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS BEEN PRESENTED WITH
DIFFERING LEVELS OF INFORMATION --
RELATED SPECIFICALLY TO THE DMB
I THINK THAT -- WHEN YOUR SECOND
PANEL PRESENTS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AUDIT IDENTIFIED WAS THAT THERE
WERE SOME CHALLENGES IN
PREPARING FOR REAL ID
IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'LL TALK ABOUT?
IT SO --MOVING FORWARD AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
PROCEED NEXT WITH THE MV WHAT
LEVEL OF RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
WHAT LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT TO
INCLUDE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND --
VERY SIMILARLY AND ADDRESSING
SENATOR CAN'T QUESTION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT KIND OF CLEAR
OUTCOME OF PERFORMANCE MEASURES
THAT'S ONE OF THE THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE MENTIONED
THAT AS BEING POTENTIALLY
IMPORTANT.
THINKING ABOUT APPROPRIATE
REPORTING EXCITER A SO.
IF I WERE TO ASK THE DMV I I'D
LIKE TO KNOW YOUR METRICS FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS HOW MANY CARS
DID YOU REGISTER EVERY YEAR.
HOW MANY NEW CARS HOW MANY USED
CARS?
IS THAT ALL THAT DATA AVAILABLE
TO SEE WHAT KIND OF TRENDS WE
HAVE.
DMV DOES COLLECT DATA AND IT AND
THEY HAVE PROVIDED DATA --
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS AS
WELL AS REPORTS THAT ARE
REQUESTED THEM FROM SO FOR
EXAMPLE I REFERENCED IN THE
PRESENTS REPORTS ON MONTHLY WAIT
TIMES -- SOMETIMES THE DATA
THAT'S COLLECTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE SAME AS WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
OR POLICY MAKING STAFF ARE
INTERESTED IN.
AND SO PART OF THESE DISCUSSIONS
IS REALLY KIND OF RE.
ALIGNING THE TO SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CLEARLY
SPECIFIES THEIR EXPECTATIONS
THAT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT THEN
TO THINK AHEAD AND BEGIN
COLLECTING THAT INFORMATION OR
COLLECTING IN IN A WAY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DEFIANCE OF FOR
EXAMPLE IN OTHER AREAS WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT.
DEFINITIONS ABOUT BACKLOG
DEFINITIONS ABOUT WAIT TIME
THERE SOMETIMES DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS OF HOW HE WOULD
GO OUT MEASURING THAT AND IF YOU
DON'T CLEARLY SPECIFY IT YOU
OFTENTIMES CAN HAVE DISCUSSIONS
THAT -- EITHER ARE CONFUSING OR
CONFLICT WITH ONE ANOTHER AND SO
THERE'S IMPORTANCE AND KIND OF
LAYING THAT EXPECTATION OUT VERY
CLEARLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VENTURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ELAINE THOSE
EXPECTATIONS ON THE FRONT END
AND SO.
THEY CAN WE CAN COLLECTIVELY
RAMP UP TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH APPLES APPLES
CONVERSATION GREAT THANK YOU.
BOB THANK YOU MISLI WILL SEE YOU
AGAIN SHORTLY WILL ASK THE
SECOND PANEL TO JOIN US.
COLLEAGUES THIS PANEL THE FOCUS
WILL BE EVALUATION OF DMB
ORGANIZATION OPERATIONAL ISSUES
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
JENNIFER WOULD OCCUR IN MARYLAND
STANDING HORSE IN THE OFFICE O
STATE AUDITS AND EVALUATIONS
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND WILL ALSO BE JOINED BY THE
SECRETARY OF GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY MAYOR BILL
BADGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
CALLING FOR AN ASSET FOR THIS
PANEL WE FOCUS.
ON BUT MADAM SECRETARY FOR IT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT CAME
UP IN THE FIRST POSTED THE LA
ALSO IF YOU COULD INCORPORATE
THOSE AT THE END OF YOUR
PRESENTATION -- THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THIS WOULD OCCUR IN THE
STANDING HORSE FIRST.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR INVITING
US TO THIS HEARING AND PROVIDING
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF OUR AUDIT
RESORT WHICH MY MOVING THE MIKE
A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOU I'D
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
WE PLAN TO BRIEFLY DESCRIBE THE
OBJECTIVES METHODOLOGY FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF OUR AUDIT.
OUR AUDIT FOUND SIGNIFICANT
WEAKNESSES IN BEES UNDERLYING
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IN
ADDITION DIEM BE OPERATED IN A
REACTIVE CULTURE AND NEEDS TO
REFOCUS ITS EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
WE PRESENT THESE INDEPENDENT AND
OBJECTIVE RESULTS TO ASSIST
DECISION MAKERS IN MOVING THE
DMB FORWARD.
IN SEPTEMBER INTO IN SEPTEMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AT THE
DIRECTION OF GOVERNOR BROWN
FINANCE CONDUCTED AN AUDIT.
AT THE DMV WITH TWO PRIMARY
AUDIT OBJECTIVES THE FIRST ONE
SS THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF DMV'S
OPERATIONS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS. TO IMPROVE
THEIR PRACTICES AND ENHANCE THE
CUSTER SKIS ME ENHANCE THE FIELD
OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
OUR OBJECTIVE NUMBER TO EVALUATE
DMV'S IT SYSTEMS AND ITS IMPACT
ON THE FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE.
WE INTERVIEWED OVER A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EMPLOYEES RANGING
FROM THE FORMER DIRECTOR TO THE
MOTOR VEHICLE REPRESENTATIVES IN
THE FIELD OFFICES WE CONDUCTED
THIRTY UNANNOUNCED VISITS TO
FIELD OFFICES IN NOVEMBER AND
DECEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHERE
AUDITOR'S OBSERVED OPERATIONS AS
WELL AS PROCESS TRANSACTIONS AS
A CUSTOMER.
WE ALSO CONDUCTED FIFTEEN
PLANNED VISITS WERE AUDITOR'S
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO OBSERVE
OPERATIONS AND AS WELL AS A TEN
WEDNESDAY MORNING TRAINING
MEETINGS.
WE REVIEWED AND EVALUATED OVER
THREE HUNDRED RESPONSES WE ARE
ONLINE CONTACT FORM WHERE WE
RECEIVED RESPONSES FROM BOTH
EMPLOYEES AND CITIZENS -- AND
NOW I WILL TURN OVER THE ODD --
OVER TO THE AUDIT MANAGER AT
MARYLAND STANDING HORSE WHO WILL
GIVE YOU A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF
THE FINDINGS AND SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
AS JENNIFER DESCRIBED AND AS
DESCRIBED IN OUR AUDIT REPORT
DMV OPERATIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE IN
DELIVERING SERVICES TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
MANY OPPORTUNITIES EXIST FOR
THEM TO IMPROVE THEIR PRACTICES
AND ENHANCE THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
OUR AUDIT RESULTS ARE ORGANIZED
INTO TWO SECTIONS TWO CHAPTERS
ONE FOR EACH OF OUR AUDIT
OBJECTIVES.
FEATURE OUR FINDINGS IS
ACCOMPANIED BY DETAILED
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH ARE
FOCUSED ON OPPORTUNITIES FOR DMV
TO IMPROVE THEIR PRACTICES.
AND ENHANCE OUR OPERATIONS AND
THEIR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY.
AB I WILL NOW GO OVER IT SUMMARY
OF OUR FINDINGS AND OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
OUR FIRST AUDIT OBJECTIVE ON TV
OPERATIONS AND THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE RESULTED IN
SEVEN FINDINGS AS FOLLOWS.
THE FIRST FINDING IS THAT THERE
WERE SIGNIFICANT DEFICIENCIES IN
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE REAL ID PROGRAM.
THESE INCLUDED IT IN CONSISTENT
APPROACH FOR PLANNING FOR REAL
ID AND THE DECADE LEADING UP UP
TO IMPLEMENTATION.
DELAYED PRIORITIZATION OF THE
RELATED I. T. PROJECT.
UNTIL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES TO REDESIGN UP
POLICIES FOR THE FREQUENCY THAT
CUSTOMERS REQUIRED DMV SERVICES.
TO ADDRESS THIS FINDING FOR BOTH
REAL ID AND FUTURE SIGNIFICANT
PROJECTS WE RECOMMEND WE
RECOMMEND DMV ASSIGNED A
DEDICATED TEAM TO MONITOR
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION.
THE TEAM SHOULD ALSO HAVE
CLEARLY DEFINED ROLES IN
LEADERSHIP WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES TO MONITOR KEY
MILESTONES. FOR SECOND FINDING.
THE DMV OPERATES UNDER AN
OUTDATED ORGANIZATIONAL AND
REPORTING STRUCTURE. FOR EXAMPLE
FIELD OFFICE GRADING WHICH
DETERMINES THE SIZE AND
RESOURCES NEEDED FOR FIELD
OFFICES.
WITH LAST ASSESSED STATEWIDE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FURTHERMORE
REGIONAL OFFICE OVERSIGHT OR
FIELD OFFICES IS INCONSISTENT.
AND DMV'S INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS STRUCTURE TO
THEIR FIELD OFFICES IS
INEFFICIENT.
IN PART BECAUSE FIELD OFFICE
EMPLOYEES DO NOT HAVE A DMV
EMAIL ADDRESS. FOR THIS FINDING
WE RECOMMEND DMB CONDUCT A
SYSTEM WIDE ASSESSMENT OF THEIR
FIELD OFFICE CREATING.
EVALUATE THE RATIO AND LEVEL OF
SUPPORT PROVIDED BY THE REGIONAL
OFFICES.
TV SHOULD ALSO EVALUATE THE
FEASIBILITY OF PROVIDING EMAIL
ADDRESSES FOR THEIR FIELD OFFICE
EMPLOYEES.
OUR THIRD FINDING IS THAT THE INTHE STAFFING AND BUDGETING
APPROACH IS NOT FOCUSED ON
MAXIMIZING THE FIELD OFFICE
CAPACITY.
ON AVERAGE WE OBSERVE 30% OF
FIELD OFFICES AND WINDOWS CLOSED
WHEN WE CONDUCTED OUR
OBSERVATIONS.
IN ADDITION LONG TERM RELIABLE
DATA ON FIELD OFFICE ABSENTEEISM
WAS NOT READILY AVAILABLE FOR US.
ALSO DMV DOES NOT HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE PROCESS TO ALLOCATE
POSITIONS TO FEEL OFFICES AFTER
THEIR PRUDENT.
AFTER THEIR APPROVED THOSE
POSITIONS THROUGH THE BUDGET ACT
TO EFFECTIVELY HANDLE THEIR
CUSTOMER DEMAND. TO ADDRESS THIS
FINDING WE RECOMMEND THE DMV
DESIGNED THEIR WEEKLY FIELD
OFFICE EMPLOYEES SCHEDULES TO
ENSURE.
ALL OFFICE WINDOWS ARE OPEN
THEREFORE SERVING CUSTOMERS
DURING BUSINESS HOURS.
TV SHOULD ALSO TRACK AND ANALYZE
THEIR ABSENTEEISM DATA.
AND ENHANCE THEIR PROGRESS FOR
ALLOCATING POSITIONS TO FELD
OFFICES.
OUR FOURTH FINDING IS THAT TV
IMPORT DMV'S APPOINTMENT
PRACTICES NEED IMPROVEMENT.
SPECIFICALLY THERE POINT SYSTEM
ALLOWS FOR DIFFERENCES AND
APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THE RESERVATION OF DUPLICATE
APPOINTMENTS.
WE RECOMMEND DV STRENGTH IN THE
SYSTEM TO ENHANCE OUR CUSTOMERS
ABILITY TO BOOK APPOINTMENTS
TIMELY -- BUT WAYS TO ENHANCE
THAT SYSTEM INCLUDE REQUIRING
UNIQUE IDENTIFIERS WHEN
CUSTOMERS RESERVE THEIR
APPOINTMENTS ANDFIELD OFFICE
EMPLOYES VERIFYING THE
AUTHENTICITY OF APPOINTMENTS
WHEN CUSTOMERS ARRIVE.
OUR FIFTH FINDING IS THAT STATE
WIDE MONITORING OF THE FIELD
OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE THESE
IMPROVEMENTS.
DMV IS INITIATIVE SUCH AS THE
COMMAND CENTER AND LEAN SIX
SIGMA TEAM OR UNTIMELY
IMPLEMENTED WITH REGARD TO THE
SUMMER TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAIT
TIMES.
AND THESE GROUPS HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
ALSO DMV'S INTERNAL AUDIT UNIT
DOES NOT AUDIT CUSTOMER SERVICE
RELATED TOPICS. FOR THIS FINDING
WE RECOMMEND DMV REEVALUATE AND
RE DIRECT THESE HEADQUARTERS
RESOURCES TO BETTER MONITR AND
RECOMMEND IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE
FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
OUR SIX FINDING.
IN RESPONSE TO THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAIT TIMES DMV
IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER SERVICE ENHANCEMENTS.
HOWEVER WE FOUND THAT FIELD
OFFICE CUSTOMER SERVICE TOOL
SUCH AS TABLETS.
TEXT NOTIFICATIONS WINE TRIAGE
ING AND ACCURATELY TRACKING AN
ADVERTISING WAIT TIMES WERE
INCONSISTENTLY IMPLEMENTED. TO
ADDRESS IS FINDING DMV FIELD
OFFICES SHOULD CONSISTENTLY
TRIAGE THEIR LINES USE TABLET
DEVICES AN OFFER TEXT
NOTIFICATIONS TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
THE V. ALSO SHOULD ACCURATELY
ADVERTISE WAIT TIMES ON THEIR
WEBSITE SO THAT CUSTOMERS CAN
BETTER PLAN FOR THEIR VISITS.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND DMV EXPAND AND
ADVERTISE ALTERNATIVES FOR
OBTAINING SERVICES IN FIELD
OFFICES.
SUCH AS EXPANDING FUNCTIONS AND
CAPABILITIES OF THEIR KIOSKS AND
CALL CENTERS.
OUR SEVENTH -- AND LAST FINDING
FOR THE FIRST OBJECTIVE.
IS THAT FIELD OFFICE MPLOYEE
TRAINING AND RESOURCES ARE
INADEQUATE. FOR EXAMPLE OVER 20%
OF EMPLOYEES.
FROM THE OFFICES THAT WE VISITED
HAD.
WE VISITED HAD ATTENDED NEITHER
A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR VEHICLE
REGISTRATION TRADING.
ANY OF THESE EMPLOYEES WERE NEW
HIRES.
TV SHOULD TIMELY PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING TO THEIR
NEW HIRES.
AND EXPLAIN EXPAND THEIR
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXISTING EMPLOYEES BEYONDTHEIR
WEEKLY ONE HOUR MEETINGS.
OUR SECOND OBJECTIVE WAS ON IT
IS IMPACT ON THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE AND WE HAD
THREE FINDINGS FOR THAT
OBJECTIVE.
THE FIRST FINDING WAS THAT HAVE
INSUFFICIENT NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LACK OF
NETWORK MONITORING CONTRIBUTED
TO FIELD OFFICE OUTAGES.
ALSO DMV'S PRIORITIZATION AND
RESOLUTION OF I. T. ISSUES NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT -- TV SHOULD ADDRESS
ITS NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
MONITORING DEFICIENCIES AND
ENHANCE ITS.
RESPONSE PROCESS.
OUR SECOND IT RELATED FINDING --
IS THAT THE REAL LIFE D. I. T.
PROJECT DID NOT FOLLOW INDUSTRY
STANDARDS WITH REGARD TO
PRIORITIZATION.
RESOLVING PROJECT DEFECTS
TESTING AND DOCUMENTATION.
WE RECOMMEND TV COMPLETE ALL
REQUIRED TESTING AND RESOLVE ALL
PROJECT DEFECTS BEFORE LAUNCHING
A NEW I. T. PROJECTS.
THEY SHOULD ADEQUATELY DOCUMENT
KEY DECISIONS AND COMPONENTS OF
THEIR I. T. PROJECTS.
AND GOING FORWARD D. V. SHOULD
ALSO REVISIT ITS PROJECT
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT HIGH IMPACT AND
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS ARE GIVEN
ADEQUATE TIME AND RESOURCES FOR
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION.
OUR THIRD AND FINAL FINDING IS
THAT TV'S USE OF LEGACY COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING LANGUAGES CONTRIBUTE
TO THEIR SUCCESSION PLANNING
RISKS.
TV NEEDS TO TRANSITION FROM THE
LEGACY COMPUTER PROGRAMMING
LANGUAGES AND WORK ON ADDRESSING
THEIR SUCCESSION PLANNING RISKS
THAT THESE CREATE.
WITHOUT ADDRESSING OUR AUDIT
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
DMV WILL CONTINUE FACING
CHALLENGES AND EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY DELIVERING SERVICES
TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
DMV STATED THAT THEY AGREED WITH
OUR FINDINGS AND THE RESPONSE TO
OUR AUDIT REPORT.
WE REQUESTED A DETAILED
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN FROM TV.
DUE IN MAY.
DESCRIBING THEIR PLANNED ACTIONS
TO ADDRESS THESE FINDINGS AND
CORRESPONDING RECOMMENDATIONS.
A CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN SHOULD
DESCRIBE MILESTONES AND TIME
LINES TO ADDRESS EACH FINDING.
OUR PLAN IS TO MONITOR THEIR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN PROGRESS.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US TO DISCUSS THE
RESULTS TODAY WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AND COLLEAGUES I THINK
BEFORE SECRETARY BAGS BEFORE WE
HAVE YOU START --BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA TRANSITION A BIT TO
STRIKE TEAM WORK IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS MEMBERS HAVE.
COME ON THE AUDIT.
OF THE FIRST TWO WITNESSES.
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THIRTY STONE
FAQ -- MADAM CHAIR I I KIND OF
FEEL LIKE THIS IS A CONFESSION --
EPISODE HERE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
HONESTY AND DESCRIPTION OF OF OF
THE ISSUES -- I FIND IT.
RATHER ALARMING WHEN YOU MENTION
THAT ONE THIRD OF THE SLOTS --
WERE WERE OPE WHEN CUSTOMERS
WERE COMING AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES I THINK -- HAS AS
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES SOMETIMES
WE FORGET WHO ARE BOSSES ARE --
ELECTED OFFICIALS CONSTANTLY
REMINDED WHO ARE BOSSES ARE NOT
THE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE
WE SERVE.
AND SO -- WHAT OF WHAT WILL
THOSE PEOPLE DOING A ONE THIRD
OF THE SLOT SIR ARE DOWN I MEAN-IT WE?
WE'VE ADDED -- BUDGET REQUESTS.
TO ADD UPWARDS OF A THOUSAND
PEOPLE INTO -- VARIOUS DMV
OFFICES AND WHAT IS PEOPLE DOING.
SO FROM THE OFFICE AS WE VISITED
WE LEARNED THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL FACTORS CONTRIBUTING TO
THAT ONE THIRD 30% OF WINDOW
CLOSURES -- ONE OF THEM WAS DUTY
BREAKS AND LUNCH PERIOD SO WHEN
A PERSON GOES ON BREAK OR GOES
ON LUNCH THERE ISN'T ANOTHER
PERSON.
OF FOR THE ONES THAT WE VISITED
TO FILL THAT WINDOW AND CONTINUE
HELPING CUSTOMERS.
ANOTHER REASON IS FOLKS --
CALLING IN SICK OR ABSENT FROM
THE OFFICE THAT DAY -- AND THEN
THE THIRD REASON WOULD BE THAT
NOT.
EVERY POSITION IN THAT FIELD
OFFICE HAS BEEN TRAINED TO WORK
THAT WINDOW TO HELP DRIVERS
LICENSE OR REGISTRATION.
BUT YOU MENTIONED TRAINING --
YOU MENTIONED THAT A LOT OF THE
EMPLOYEES OR WHATEVER YOU AND
TRYING TO PROCESS A DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR REGISTRATION.
I FIND THAT.
PASTORS ARE WITH THEIR DMV
EMPLOYEES AS ONE OF THE PRIMARY
FUNCTIONS OF EMPLOYEES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES HOW
CAN WE HOW CAN WE ACCOUNT FOR
THAT.
WE PUT PEOPLE AT A WINDOW IN
THAT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
PROCESS THESE.
BASIC -- SERVICES -- SAYS YOUR
QUESTION HOW I'M SORRY WHAT WAS
YOUR QUESTION.
I GATHER THIS IS AUDITS AND IF.
THEY CAN ANSWER.
IN HALF AND THEN THE THE MAYBE
IT'S MORE RHETORICAL QUESTION
BUT THE AND THEN THE REAL ID AT%
THE THE REAL ID PROCESS STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE AND WE
HAD LIKE FIFTEEN YEARS TO
PREPARE FOR IT.
WHAT SOUNDS LIKE IN THAT FIFTEEN
YEAR PERIOD WE DIDN'T DO A WHOLE
LOT TO PREPARE FOR IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE GOT?
HIT WITH THE STORM OF REQUESTS
AND NOT EVEN UNDER.
STANDING THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROCESSES TO TO ACCOMMODATE ALL
THESE PEOPLE AND IN AS A PART OF
THE AUDIT DID YOU FIND THAT IN
SOME CASES THAT WE WERE.
PROCESSING REAL ID'S WITHOUT THE
CORRECT INFORMATION IS A MAN IS
A TRUE THAT.
A PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE THAT WERE.
THAT THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING
REAL ID IS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
RETURN TO THE DMV BECAUSE OF OUR
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
WAS REQUIRED. FOR THAT ANSWER --
DEFERRED TO THE DMV PANEL EITHER
PANEL THREE OR SECRETARY
BACHELOR.
OF OUR AUDIT DID NOT INCLUDE AN
EVALUATION OF THE STATE'S
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
RADIO REALLY T. OCT.
OKAY -- THANK YOU MANAGER I'M
I'M JUST.
I WILL OFFER ADVICE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS -- DMV AND THE
SECRETARY THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR I'M JUST CURIOUS.
MISS SAYS STANDING ORDERS A IN A
IN A ALL THOSE THAT YOU
INTERVIEWED DID YOU ALSO
INTERVIEW REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE AUTO CLUB -- NO I DON'T
BELIEVE SO.
OKAY BECAUSE I ARE WAS THINK I'M
GONNA GO TO TRIPLE A NOT THE DMV.
WHY WERE THEY EXCLUDED -- OUR
EFFORTS FOCUSED ON THE FIELD
OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE WITH
REGARD TO BUSINESS PARTNERS SUCH
AS TRIPLE A AUTO CLUBS.
WE DID LOOK AT WHAT TYPES OF
TRANSACTIONS THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE CAPABLE OF HANDLING AND I
BELIEVE IN OUR REPRT WE
RECOMMEND DV EXPLORING.
EXPANDING THOSE OPTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER.
OKAY THIRTY NIELSEN.
YEAH THIS IS A THE I. T. IS A
VERY BIG ISSUE.
WE'VE SPENT BILLIONS IN.
SQUANDERED BILLIONS.
YOU NAME THE AGENCY I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S A ONE THAT'S EVER WORKED.
HE MENTIONED THAT.
THEY DID NOT FOLLOW QUOTE
INDUSTRY STANDARDS.
AND DOES A EMBARKED ON NEW I. T.
[inaudible]
THEN.
WHAT DID THEY DO WHAT WAS THEIR
GUIDES?
IN LIEU OF INDUSTRY STANDARDS
DID THEY JUST INVENT THEIR OWN
OR DID THEY JUST NOT.
EMPLOYEE STANDARDS.
SO DO WE HAVE A SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT LIFE CYCLE WHICH
WOULD BUT WHAT THEY'RE CALLED AS
THEIR STANDARD.
FOR IT PROJECTS AND THE DESIGN
OF THAT PROCESS DOES FOLLOW
INDUSTRY STANDARDS HOWEVER WITH
THE REAL ID PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY
HAD A SHORTENED TIME FRAMES.
THEY HAD -- TO FIVE PASSED
CERTAIN PARTS OF THAT PLAN OF
THAT CYCLE.
SO AS I MENTIONED SOME OF THE
TESTING OF THE SYSTEM --
RESOLVING DEFECTS OF THE SYSTEM
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT THEY CUT
OUT OF THEIR CYCLE.
THE DAY NOT HAVE ANTICIPATED
THIS EVENTUALITY THOUGH AND
BUILT IN SOME PROCEDURES TO
ACCOMMODATE IT. TO RESPOND MORE
QUICKLY WHEN THEY SAW THAT
THINGS WERE NOT GOING.
ACCORDING [inaudible]
TO EDGELL -- ISN'T THAT A NORMAL
WAY OF BUSINESS.
MANAGES IT'S TIME LINES AND AND
BENCHMARKS.
YES I WOULD AGREE AND AS WE SAY
IN OUR REPORT BECAUSE THE REAL
I. T. I. T. PROJECT WAS NOT MADE
A PRIORITY UNTIL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THEY HAD A
LIMITED TIME FRAME AND NOT --
THESE ARE THE DECISIONS THAT
THEY MADE IN ORDER TO MEET THEIR
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN ROLL OUT
DATE YOU DID MENTION THAT --
THEY DIDN'T NOT NOT NOT MAKE
THAT A PRIORITY SO.
THAT THAT IS IMPORTANT AND I
WOULD JUST LASTLY SUGGEST AT
THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT.
THE CRY OF AGENCIES WHEN THEY
HAVE TROUBLES.
BACK LOG SERVICE.
ALL KINDS THEY COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY WE NEED MORE
MONEY.
WELL I AM FINDING THAT.
NOT COMPELLING.
IN FACT ALMOST OFFENSIVE.
COME AND TELL US WHAT YOU WANT
TO DO WITH MONEY.
AND HOW IT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
WITH THE PLAN.
BUT DON'T JUST COME AND SAY MORE
MONEY AND I SAW A MESSAGE TO ALL
AGES.
IN THE SAME YEAR WITH DMV IF
THERE ANSWER IS MORE MONEY --
I'M GOING TO BE DEAF TO THEIR
PLEASE [inaudible]
MISTER JONES.
I'M SURE IN YOUR ANALYSIS -- DID
YOU COMPARE ORG HONESTLY COMPARE --
AND DID YOU LOOK AT WHAT OTHER
STATES ARE DOING -- IN THERE DMV
DEPARTMENTS -- EITHER.
YOU KNOW OVERALL OR INTO
SPECIFIC ISSUES.
THE SPECIFIC -- FINDING AN ISSUE
WHERE WE LOOKED AT OTHER STATES
WAS WITH ALTERNATIVE SERVICE
OPTIONS -- SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
KIOSK THAT TV HAS WE LOOKED AT
WHAT OTHER STATES TRANSACTION
CAPABILITIES AND VOLUME OF THEIR
KIOSKS ARE -- WE ALSO LOOKED AT
HOW OTHER STATES.
GET FOLKS OUT OF THE FIELD
OFFICE -- OTHER STATES WILL
ACCEPT.
A VISION CERTIFICATION FROM
THEIR OPTOMETRIST SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE A VISION TEST IN
THE IN THE OFFICE SO WE LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE THAT.
IS THERE A WERE YOU ABLE TO RANK
THE STATE'S ON YOU KNOW WHO'S
DOING THE BEST JOB IN WHO'S
DOING THE WORST JOB IN.
IS THERE A GOLD STANDARD OUT
THERE THE FIFTY STATES IS THERE
A GOLD STANDARD OF OF A STATE
THAT WE CAN ASPIRE TO MATCH OR
BEAT.
WE DID NOT -- PERFORM THAT
ANALYSIS.
PERHAPS THE DMV HAS THAT
INFORMATION AND COULD ANSWER
THAT QUESTION ON THE REAL ID
ISSUE SPECIFICALLY ALL FIFTY
STATES HAVE TO DO THIS.
SO -- AGAIN AS OUR STATE OUT
THERE THAT'S WAY AHEAD OF
EVERYBODY ELSE.
FOR THAT'S ANOTHER QUESTION I
WOULD DEFER TO THE STRIKE TEAM.
NINETY THANK YOU [inaudible]
PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
APPRECIATE -- YOU LOOKING AT
THIS I THINK IT'S JUST AN
OBSERVATION MAYBE IN WRONG.
A THERE SEEMS TO BE PARTICULAR
FOCUS AND CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE AT THAT ARE FACE TO
FACE INTERACTION AND I KNOW YOU
DID LOOK A LITTLE BIT ONLINE BUT
I GUESS IN TERMS OF AND AND YOU
MADE MENTION JUST MADE MENTION
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACTUALLY.
HANDLE THINGS OUTSIDE THE OFFICE
BUT THIS IS THERE ARE GONNA BE
MORE APPROACH OF LOOKING AT MY
SAY THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT JUST.
INTERFACING WITH AN OFFICE OR
EVEN A KIOSK BUT JUST OVERALL
BECAUSE OF THE DISEASE MENTIONED
WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING.
TO DECREASE IN FACT THAT'S KIND
OF THE EXPECTATION NOW RIGHT AND
EVEN A KIOSK SEEMS A LITTLE OLD
FASHIONED BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE.
IN MOST OF THE SITE.
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING A BILL
LATER ON TODAY ABOUT PEOPLE
GETTING FOOD DELIVERED USING TO
CAO FRESH BENEFITS AND WHAT KIND
OF GUIDELINES YOU HAVE THAT IN
OTHER WORDS.
WE ORDERED THINGS -- AND WE
HAVEN'T DELIVER TO OUR DOOR.
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE NEW
EXPECTATION IS THAT YOU CAN TAKE
EVERYTHING WITH YOUR COMPUTER OR
YOUR I. PHONE AND THEN WHATEVER
YOU NEED GETS MAILED TO YOU.
IT'S A LOCATION THAT YOU
DESIGNATE I REALIZE WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE ADDRESSES
AND FIGURE THAT OUT BUT I I
THINK IN TERMS OF TRYING TO LOOK
MORE BROADLY -- BUT WE LOOKING
AT THAT KIND OF DEVICE THAT THE
TOTAL CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE FROM
THE TIME THEY NEED TO ENCOUNTER
DMV TO AND HOPEFULLY THEY NEVER
EXCEED EVER NEED TO TOUCH IN
OFFICE IS THAT SOMETHING THE
THAT WAS LOOKED AT BY -- THIS
AUDIT.
I THINK THAT BEYOND THE FIELD
OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE THAT
MAYBE SOMETHING THE STRIKE TEAM
OR DMV COULD SPEAK TOWARDS -- I
WILL SAY THAT THE ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE FOCUSED OUR
EFFORTS ON THE FIELD OFFICE WAS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT TO
GET A REAL ID YOU HAVE TO GO TO
A FIELD OFFICE YOU CAN'T DO
THROUGH ANOTHER SERVICE CHANNEL
BUT THE LAST TIME FOCUSED ON
REAL IDEA AND SO THAT WAS. ONE
OF THE MAIN DRIVERS OF US
FOCUSING ON FIELD OFFICES AND
THEN I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
IS IN TERMS OF I. T. RECOGNIZING
WE HAVE A LEGACY SYSTEM I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE TO STILL
USING KOBOL.
AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE EVEN RECOGNIZE WAT KOBOL
IS ANYMORE -- THE OF WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ALSO TAKES TIME TO
DEVELOP IT SYSTEMS ARE WE
LOOKING AT I'D SAY IT'S SOME OFF
THE SHELF TYPE OF APPROACHES AS
WELL BECAUSE WE MAY NOT HAVE
TIME GIVE THE DEADLINES OF THE
REAL ID TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP A
BRAND NEW.
COMPUTER INFRASTRUCTURE -- AND
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE INVESTED SOME
BEFORE I'M NOT SURE OF WHERE WE
ARE N THAT TIME LINE TO BE SURE
IT'S ACTUALLY UP AND RUNNING
FAST ENOUGH.
WE CAN BE UP AND RUNNING BY THE
DEADLINE THAT'S TOO LATE IT HAS
TO BE UP AND RUNNING RIGHT NOW.
SO WHERE ARE WE WITH THE I. T. --
INFRASTRUCTURE WE OOKING AT IF
WE'RE NOT THERE READY WHAT ARE
WE LOOKING AT OFF THE SHELF
SOLUTIONS.
I WOULD JUST -- I WOULD DEFER TO
DMB FOR THAT ANSWER OF HELL DAVE
PLAN TO TRANSITION FROM THOSE
LEGACY LANGUAGES.
HOWEVER WE DID HIGHLIGHT THAT
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT RISK
FACING THEIR I. T. OPERATION
THEIR I. T. PORTFOLIO AND THEIR
I. T. WARN YOU ASK YOU THAT FROM
OUT ITS PERSPECTIVE -- IS THE I.
T. SYSTEM RIGHT NOW SUFFICIENT
TO HANDLE THE PROBLEM -- AS WE
POINT OUT OUR AUDIT THEY HAVE A
DMV HAS EXPERIENCED.
MULTIPLE OUTAGES INCIDENTS AND
THAT SOUNDS LIKE NO.
THEY HAVE A HIGH A HIGH RISK IT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ALL I CAN
TELL OKAY.
IF YOU COULD CLARIFY FOR ME
BECAUSE I I'M HERE IN A NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES I THINK ASKING
YOU QUESTIONS REALLY KIND OF
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF AN AUDIT
THAT IN AN AUDIT YOU DON'T DO
THESE KINDS OF COMPARISONS TO
OTHER STATES IT'S IT'S NOT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT AN ODDITY ITSELF
FROM AN AUDIT AND EVALUATION
PERSPECTIVE -- WHAT COMES NEXT
YOU'VE DONE THE AUDIT -- IS
THERE ANY EXPECTATION -- THAT
THE AGENCY OR THE DEPARTMENT --
COME BACK TO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
FOLLOW UP IN TERMS OF KIND OF
TICKING OFF THEY'VE HANDLED THIS
RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S IN THE NONPROFIT WORLD FROM
WHICH I COME WHEN WE GOT TO GET
NOT IT THERE IS A FOLLOW UP
MEETING WITH YOUR AUDITOR SO.
THEY CAN COME BACK EXT YEAR AND
SAY THESE COURSE CORRECTIONS
WERE MADE IS THAT THE NATURE OF
AS A STE.
FROM FINANCE AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WHEN YOU DO AUDITS
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS IS THERE
THAT KIND OF FOLLOW UP.
YES -- SO FOR WITH DMV AND WITH
MANY OF OUR AUDITS ARE STANDARD
PROCESSES SIXTY DAYS AFTER OUR
FINAL REPORT WE REQUEST THAT
DETAILED CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN.
AND THEN -- SIX MONTHS AFTER
THAT PLAN WE ASK FOR UPDATES ON
HOW EACH OF THEIR PLANNED ITEMS.
ARE MATERIALIZING HAVE THEY MET
THEIR MILESTONES WHAT ACTIVITIES
AND ACTIONS HAVE THEY TAKEN AND
THAT CONTINUES EVERY SIX MONTHS --
UNTIL ALL THE FINDINGS ARE
RESOLVED OR UNTIL THREE YEARS
HAS ELAPSED OCCASIONALLY WE WILL
DO SUBSEQUENT MORE IN DEPTH --
REVIEW OF THEIR REPORTED ACTIONS.
IS THERE A PROCESS OR AN
OPPORTUNITY IN THAT PROCESS WERE
DEPARTMENT CAN PUSH BACK IN
EITHER CHALLENGE YOUR FINDINGS
ARE CHALLENGE YOUR
RECOMMENDATION -- DURING OUR
REPORTING PROCESS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
TO OUR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS EVEN BEFORE THE
REPORT DURING OUR EXIT
CONFERENCES AND UPDATE MEETINGS
THEY HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY -- IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT'S TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
DISCRETION TO IMPLEMENT HOW WE
HAVE WARDED OUR RECOMMENDATIONS --
BUT WE WILL FOLLOW UP AND ASK
THEM BUT IT'S FIFTY THAT EXIT
CONFERENCE PROCESS AT THAT CAN
KIND OF BE DISCUSSED YES THANKS
FOR THE CLARIFICATION ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS AROUND AUDITS
AND EVALUATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECRETARY Q.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US SECRETARY BADGER.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AS YOU KNOW IN EARLY JANUARY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME APPOINTED ME TO
LEAD A THE STRIKE TEAM.
THE GOAL OF WHICH WAS TO
REINVENT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
THE STRIKE TEAM WAS GIVEN SIX
MONTHS BUT WE KNOW THAT THESE
ISSUES.
ARE THE ISSUES THAT THE DMB RUN
DEEP.
AND IT WILL TAKE MUCH LONGER
THAN SIX MONTHS.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT THE STRIKE TEAM
IS DOING THAT I BELIEVE WILL
pHAVE LONG TERM IMPACT FOR THE
DMV AND ITS CUSTOMERS.
FIRST HOWEVER LET ME BE CLEAR
ABOUT THE MISSION OF THE STRIKE
TEAM.
OUR OBJECTIVE IS TO BEGIN WORK
OF REINVENTING THIS PUBLIC
FACING STATE AGENCY WE ARE NOT
SIMPLY TALKING TO PEOPLE AND
THEN WRITING A REPORT.
WE'RE RE ENGINEERING PROCESSES
WE A RE PRIORITIZING SERVICES TO
GET TRANSACTIONS THAT CAN BE
DONE ONLINE OR AT A KIOSK OUT
SIDE OF THE FIELD OFFICES.
SO THAT THE DMV TECHNICIANS AT
PUBLIC COUNTERS CAN SPEND TIME
ON THE MOST COMPLEX SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS LIKE THE REAL
ID'S WHICH REQUIRE AN IN PERSON
VISIT.
AND WHICH INDEED ARE CREATING AN
UNPRECEDENTED VOLUME OF VISITS
TO THE FIELD OFFICES.
BUT FIRST LET ME ASSURE US SOME
OF THE BASICS ONE OF THE
PERENNIAL -- FRUSTRATIONS WITH
DMB IS THAT YOU CAN'T USE A
CREDIT CARD IN A FIELD OFFICE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS NOTED THIS
AND THAT MAKE THEM HAS SAID THAT
IT MAKES NO SENSE IN THE MODERN
ERA.
THE STRIKE TEAM LOOKED AT
PERCEIVED BARRIERS TO CREDIT
CARD USE AT THE DMV INCLUDING
SECURITY AND PRIVACY ISSUES.
WE RELEASED AN INVITATION TO
NEGOTIATE FOR BIDDERS AND BY THE
END OF APRIL JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
WE EXPECT TO AWARD A CONTRACT TO
A CREDIT CARD VENDOR.
IN MAY AND JUNE WILL WORK TO
COMBINED THE DEBIT AND THE
CREDIT CARD SERVICES AND BEGIN
TO PILOT IN A FIELD OFFICE BY
JULY.
WITH A FULL IMPLEMENTATION
EXPECTED BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
WITH THE PRIORITY TO HAVE AS
MANY TRANSACTIONS AS POSSIBLE
DONE OUTSIDE OF THE FIELD OFFICE
WE ARE EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
SELF SERVICE TERMINALS AND
KIOSKS AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND ADDING OTHER TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT THOSE KIOSKS CAN
DO.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO KEELE BOSQUES IN
FIELD OFFICES AND RETAIL AND
OTHER NON FIELD OFFICE LOCATIONS.
WE RECOMMEND ADDING ANOTHER ONE
HUNDRED SELF SERVICE TERMINALS
IN KEY LOCATIONS BY THIS SUMMER
AND ANOTHER BY THEEND OF THE
YEAR.
THE USAGE OF THESE KIOSKS HAS
RISEN AND MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
TRANSACTIONS WERE PROCESSED ON
THE KIOSKS AND EVER WORRY.
COMPARED TO A HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND LAST SEPTEMBER.
THE STRIKE TEAM HAS A PILOT
PROJECT UNDER WAY TO BRING THE
DMV TO MAJOR CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES IN ORDER TO HELP THEIR
EMPLOYEES GET A REAL ID.
AT THEIR WORK PLACE RATHER THAN
VISITING A DMV FIELD OFFICE.
THIS POP UP DMV IS AIMED AT OUR
STATES BUSINESS TRAVELERS WITH
ADVANCE NOTICE AND COORDINATION
WITH DMV.
MAJOR EMPLOYERS WILL PREPARE
MEMBERS OF THEIR WORK FORCE TO
PULL TOGETHER REQUIRED DOCUMENTS
FOR REELED ID AND BRING THEM ON
A DESIGNATED DAY AND COMPLETE
THE ENTIRE APPLICATION PROCESS.
AT THEIR WORK LOCATION WITHIN
MINUTES WE HAVE THE FIRST PILOT
SCHEDULED AT HEALTH NET HERE IN
SACRAMENTO REGION THIS WEEK.
IT IS IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL WE HOPE
TO HAVE MANY MORE AT LARGE
CORPORATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THE DMV WEBSITE IS NOT INTUITIVE
AND DOES NOT CLEARLY GUIDE THE
USER TO NEEDED INFORMATION.
THE STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDS AN
IMMEDIATE OVERHAUL OF THIS
WEBSITE USING THE BEST PRACTICES
OF HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN.
THIS WILL DELIVER A MODERN
WEBSITE THAT PUTS CUSTOMERS
FIRST.
MAKES IT EASIER TO COMPLETE
TRANSACTIONS AND REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF FIELD OFFICE VISITS.
WELL IF YOU CAN'T FIND WHAT YOU
NEED -- ON THE WEBSITE THE NEXT
STEP OFTEN IS FOR YOU TO PICK UP
THE PHONE WELL THAT EXPERIENCE
HAS ALSO BEEN FRUSTRATING FOR
DMV CUSTOMERS THE STRIKE --
OPERATES ONE OF THE BEST AND
MOST EFFICIENT CALL CENTERS IN
THE STATE TO DO A THOROUGH
REVIEW OF THE DMV'S CALL CENTER
PRACTICES.
AND SHARE BEST PRACTICES.
AMONG ITS FINDINGS WERE THAT DMB
SHOULD DEVELOP AN ANNUAL
COMPREHENSIVE HIT HIRING AND
TRAINING PLAN.
GET MORE AGENTS ON TO THE PHONES
OUT OF FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE OBSERVED PHONE AGENTS.
AN AVERAGE OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE AGENTS WERE NOT ON THE
PHONES BECAUSE THEY WERE DOING
WHAT PERFORMING BASIC OFFICE
DUTIES.
RAY TO PERSONAL COMPUTERS SO
THAT TECHNICIANS WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO EMAIL AND ONLINE
MANUALS CURRENTLY TECHNICIANS
MUST RELY ON PAPER MANUALS WELL
THEY'RE TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE ON
THE TELEPHONE.
HE CAN EVEN DO A WORD SEARCH
OBVIOUSLY.
ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO EXPAND
THE WEBSITE BY ADDING CHAT BOT
IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER ON BY
THE LA -- TO ANSWER BASIC
QUESTIONS FOR USERS AND THEN
MOVE TOWARDS LIVE CHAT WITH DMB
SERVICE AGENTS AT THE CALL
CENTERS.
WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
CUSTOMERS KNOW WHAT DOCUMENTS TO
BRING WITH THEM TO THE FIELD
OFFICES.
OUR GOAL IS TO COMPLETE EVERY%
REAL ID PROCESS IN ONE SINGLE
VISIT.
THAT MEANS WE NEED TO
COMMUNICATE CLEARLY ABOUT WHAT
EVERY PERSON NEEDS TO BRING WITH
THEM SUCH AS WHEN THERE HAS BEEN
A NAME CHANGE WHICH MAKES IT.
A VERY COMPLICATED TRANSACTION.
RIGHT NOW THE DMV.
PROCESS IS AN AVERAGE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND REAL
ID'S PER MONTH THE DMV NEEDS TO
DOUBLE THAT CAPACITY TO SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER MONTH.
IF THEY ARE TO PROCESS EVERYONE
WHO IS EXPECTED TO COME IN THE
DOOR BEFORE OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE.
FRANKLY THAT'S HUGE THESE
NUMBERS ARE HISTORIC AND TRULY
UNPRECEDENTED FOR THE DMV. TO
MAKE MATTERS WORSE THE MONTHLY
FIGURE COULD BE EVEN LARGER
BECAUSE WE ONLY GET 80% OF THE
REAL ID TRANSACTIONS RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME. 20% THERE FOR THE
REAL ID CUSTOMERS HAVE TO COME
BACK FOR A SECOND VISIT.
SO THAT MEANS. TWENTY THREE
MILLION MORE VISITS TO THE DMV
AGAIN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBERS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH WE ESTIMATE
BY THE THE B. C. B. ESTIMATES
ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION.
FRANKLY THE STRIKE TEAMS AUBURN
OBSERVATION IS ABOUT FIFTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION.
PEOPLEWILL NEED TO HAVE A REAL
ID BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER.
ONE AND WITH A 20% RETURN RATE
THAT'S ANOTHER THREE TO FOUR
MILLION.
DMV HAS CREATED ALL OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS.
AND INFORMATION ABOUT REAL ID IN
HOUSE WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF
KNOWING WHETHER THE MESSAGING
RESONATES WITH TARGET AUDIENCES.
A MAJOR COMMUNICATIONS AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN IS VITALLY
NEEDED IF WE WANT BETTER
PREPARED CUSTOMERS.
WE MUST CUT DOWN ON THE NEED FOR
RETURN VISITS TO MITIGATE THIS
ON THE UNPRECEDENTED VISIT SO WE
HAVE.
I STOP HERE TO REITERATE.
THAT IF WE DO NOT COMMUNICATE
WELL AND EFFECTIVELY TO THE
DRIVING PUBLIC OF CALIFORNIA WE
WILL SEE.
EVEN MORE VISITS NEEDLESS VISITS
TO THE TO THE DMV SERVICES.
I MEAN SKEWS ME -- FIELD OFFICES.
WE ALSO WANT TO INCREASE.
OUR COMMUNICATIONS AROUND THE ID
BY ESTABLISHING COMMUNICATION
BOOTHS AT THE MAJOR CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS. TO TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT REAL ID AND OTHER DMV
SERVICES THE STRIKE TEAM IN THE
DMV ARE WORKING WITH THE TSA ON
PLACEMENT OF THESE BOOTS.
THE FIRST BOTH WENT UP LAST WEEK
AT LA ACTS AND FRESNO AIRPORTS
AND WILL CONTINUE OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS AT SACRAMENTO SFO AND
ONTARIO WERE WORKING WITH OTHER
AIRPORTS TO EXPAND THE FOOT
PRINTS OF THIS OUTRAGE.
IN ANOTHER EFFORT TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS VISITING A
FIELD OFFICE TO COMPLETE TASKS
THAT COULD BE DONE ONLINE WE
NEED TO MODERNIZE THE DMV'S
APPROACH TO AUTHENTICATING
CUSTOMERS I DANITY.
ON ONLINE SERVICES CURRENTLY DMV
CUSTOMERS CAN CONFIRM THEIR ID
ONLINE FOR DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
IDENTIFICATION CARD APPLICATIONS.
THIS SERVICE SHOULD BE EXTENDED
TO STREAMLINE THE REAL ID
APPLICATION PROCESS BY ALLOWING
DMB CUSTOMERS TO UPLOAD AND
STORE REQUIRED DOCUMENTS.
BEFORE GOING TO A FIELD OFFICE
THE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
CUSTOMER HAS COMPLETE
APPLICATION AND REQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION.
WHEN VISITING A FIELD OFFICE AND
THAT THE PROCESS CAN BE
COMPLETED QUICKLY AVOIDING A
RETURN VISIT?
THE FIELD OFFICE TECHNICIAN
WOULD ONLY NEED TO VERIFY THE
CUSTOMER'S DOCUMENTS THIS WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
TRANSACTIONS TIME.
AS WE LOOK TOWARD THE DMB OF THE
FUTURE.
THE STRIKE TEAM HAS PUBLISHED A
REQUEST FOR QUOTE TO DEVELOP
WORKPLACE STRATEGIES ANALYTICS
THE NEWS RETAIL DESIGN TO
PROVIDE THE BASICS OF A NEW
DESIGN FOR ITS FIELD OFFICES
THAT WOULD OPTIMIZE AND THE
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE. TO A MORE
FUNDAMENTAL ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN
INDEED IN DIEM BE OF THE FUTURE.
WE WANT.
PROTOTYPE DESIGNS THAT ELEVATE
DMB WORK FLOW AND ENHANCE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE WE WANT A
WORKSTATION DESIGNED FOR PEAK
PERFORMANCE OPTIMUM STATE STAFF
PERFORMANCES AND STREAMLINED
BUILDING SYSTEMS THAT REDUCE
LONG TERM OPERATING COSTS.
THERE MUST BE A COMP THERE MUST
BE COMPREHENSIVE CHANGE IN HOW
THE DMB OPERATES AND PROCESSES
TRANSACTIONS.
WE ARE NOT ONLY LOOKING AT NEW
SPACES FOR THE DMV BUT WE A RE
ENGINEERING PROCESSES.
THE STRIKE TEAM AND THE DMV HAVE
ENGAGE MCKINSEY AND COMPANY I
THINK WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY
THE LA JOH. TO HELP DMV FOCUS.
THAT START OF ITS CULTURAL
CHANGE ON IMPROVING THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE AROUND THE REAL ID.
THEY HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
UNDERTAKE A SERIES OF THREE
RELATED DESIGN SPRINTS FOCUSING
ON COMMUNICATIONS EMPLOYEE
TRAINING AND THE FIELD OFFICE
ACTIVITIES FOR USING RELY DIS
ISSUING SKEWS ME REAL ID'S.
THEY ARE YOU USING FIELD OFFICE
VISITS AND HAVE LAUNCHED A
SURVEY TO LEARN.
ABOUT T. RELY DEEMED MARKET
SEGMENTS AND WHAT MOTIVATES
PEOPLE TO GET IN OR NOT.
ADD TO GET A REAL ID
OBSERVATIONS FROM THESE VISITS.
AN ANALYSIS OF FIELD OFFICE DATA
WILL BE USED TO BUILD A FACT
BASED TO UNDERSTAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MANAGING
CAPACITY.
DEMAND AND THROUGHOUT. FOR
THROUGH PUT SKEWS ME FOR REAL ID
WHICH WILL BE CONVERTED TO
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS PROTOTYPES
FOR OTHER AREAS WELL THE WORK IS
FOCUSED ON PROCESSES SURROUNDING
RELY DE.
THESE LESSONS ON USER RESEARCH
DESIGN BASED APPROACHES FOR
PROTOTYPING AND FALL FOCUSING ON
CUSTER MEANT BACKED SOLUTIONS
WILL CASCADE AND TRANSLATE TO
OTHER CENTRAL DMB FUNCTIONS.
ANOTHER KEY AREA THAT BOTH THE
STRIKE TEAM AND S. O. S. A HIGH --
SAY.
IT TO THE AUDIT FOUND LACKING IS
TRAINING TRAINING MATERIALS ARE
OUT OF DATE AND WHILE THE DMB
SETS ASIDE AN HOUR FOR TRAINING
EACH WEEK IT IS UNCLEAR HOW WELL
THIS TIME ISSUES AND HOW
EFFECTIVE IT IS USED.
THE LACK OF ROBUST TRAINING IS
WHY WE ARE ORGANIZING A TRAINING
STAND DOWN DAY THIS SUMMER. FOR
ONE DAY WE WILL CLOSE DMV
OFFICES TO PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
UNIFORM TRAINING IN ALL FIELD
OFFICES FOR ALL EMPLOYEES.
WHEN GAVIN NEWSOM GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM RECENTLY CELEBRATED HIS
ONE HUNDREDTH DAY IN OFFICE HE
REITERATED HIS COMMITMENT? TO
RENEW AND REINVENT DMB TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
BEEN MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO
TAKE ON THAT CRITICAL CHALLENGE
ON HIS BEHALF AND YOURS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS AND MADAM CHAIR YOU
ASKED ME TO ADDRESS.
A COUPLE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED EARLIER TONIGHT I'LL
DO THAT NOW THANK YOU LET HER ON
YOU WILL IT WAS PASSED BY BOTH.
SENATOR STONE AND SENATOR JONES
I BELIEVE WHAT STATES ARE DOING
WELL WHAT STATES ARE DOING
BETTER AND DID WE LOOK AT IT.
THE STRIKE TEAM HAS -- LOOKED AT
SEVERAL STATES AND WE'VE ALSO
SPOKEN TO SEVERAL VENDORS THAT
WE USE HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ALSO OUR VENDORS TO OTHER STATES.
I WILL SAY THAT ALL OF THE
STATES ARE STRUGGLING WITH.
WITH REAL ID IMPLEMENTATION I
DON'T THINK ANYONE IS DOING IT
SWIMMINGLY.
SOME WITH WITH THAT HAVE LESS
VOLUME THAT WE THAN WE DO ARE
DOING BETTER WE LOOK
SPECIFICALLY AT THE STATE OF NEW
YORK WE LOOKED AT INDIANA.
WE LOOK AT WASHINGTON HAWAIIAN
COLORADO.
INDIANA HAS SOME VERY
INTERESTING -- FIELD OFFICES
THEY YEARS AGO UNDER GOVERNOR
MITCH DANIELS MOVED REJECT
VEHICLE REGISTRATION OUT OF THE
FIELD OFFICE ENTIRELY SO THAT'S
PROCESS BY A THIRD PARTY.
PEOPLE AS MY UNDERSTANDING --
THEY ALSO CREATED A OFFICE OF
THE FUTURE LOOKS KIND OF LIKE AN
APPLE OFFICE IT IS ALL SELF
SERVICE IT HAS IN THE WALL
SERVICES.
AND ON KIOSKS SO IT'S TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN BUT THEY TO HAVE ARE
ARE ALL WORKING HARD -- TO TO
IMPLEMENT THE REAL ID UNDER YOU
KNOW THESE DIFFICULT TIME FRAMES
AND SOME STARTED EARLIER THAN
OTHERS A ONE STATE I BELIEVE IT
WAS OREGON EVEN TRIED.
TO WITHDRAW THEMSELVES FROM
IMPLEMENTATION FROM THE THROUGH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- I
THINK IT WAS ALSO -- ASKED IF.
THE THE WHETHER THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INFORMATION WHICH IS --
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH
WILL BE PLACED IN MY AGENCY --
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
WHETHER IT WILL BE LOOKING AT
OPPORTUNITIES AT DMV.
THAT -- WE ARE FORMING THAT NOW
OF COURSE IT'S IN THE BUDGET NO
BUDGET MUST BE APPROVED FIRST --
AS THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INFORMATION SERVICES IS IS PUT
INTO PLACE AND OPERATIONALIZED --
POST JULY SHOULD THE BUDGET BE
APPROVED -- WE MOST DEFINITELY
WILL BE LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR IMPROVEMENTS AT DMV.
ON I THINK SAID SENATOR PAN HAS
LEFT BUT HE DID GO AHEAD RESPOND
MEMBERS OF HAD TO GO TO A
PROJECTIONS COMMITTEES OF THEIR
STAFF CAN.
FEEL THE MAN OKAY HE HE
MENTIONED IN ASKS THE AUDITOR'S
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS A WAY
TO BRING THE DMV TO INDEED THE
PERSON.
I MET LAST WEEK WITH IT WITH THE
VENDOR WHO -- HAS HAS DONE
SEVERAL NOT A CURRENT VENDOR
DANDY HAS DONE SEVERAL START UPS
IN FACT HE WAS VERY INVOLVED IN
YELP.
AND AND THEY HAVE A AN
INTERESTING CONCEPT TO DO JUST
THAT SOME SIMILAR.
TO HOW WE NOW FUNCTION WITH ON
LEFT AND WEBER WHERE INDEED YOU
WOULD TAKE IT.
AT DMV EMPLOYEE INTO THE HOME TO
DO A DMV VISIT THAT IS IN THE
NAY SEEIN -- RELEASED THE STAGES
BUT I DID WANT SENATOR PAN TO
KNOW THAT T'S SOMETHING THE
STRIKE TEAM I HAVE MET
PERSONALLY ON AND AND WE WILL
FURTHER -- REVIEW I DIDN'T
MENTION IN MY PREPARED REMARKS
BUT PART OF THE EARLY ON EFFORT
THAT I UNDERTOOK THE TEAM
UNDERTOOK IN FEBRUARY WAS TO DO
A PORT.
FOLIO REVIEW IT REVIEW -- AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
WE LEARNED -- AS IT'S BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED AND STATED THAT THE
I. T. STRUCTURE AT THE DMV IS
FRAGILE -- THE D. M. V. EIGHT
WHICH IS THE DATABASE NOT ONLY
COLD BALL BUT ASSEMBLY -- WHICH
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW EXISTED IS
USE THE LANGUAGE SO.
WE HAVE HAVE -- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA TECH
TOP THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND THE DMV OF
UNDERTAKEN SOME -- WE SUGGESTED
THEY HAVE UNDERTAKEN SOME
ACTIVITIES -- THAT WILL AND
SECURE AND STABILIZE THE MIDDLE
TIER OF THE STACK IF YOU WILL
THAT AREA THAT HAS IBM
PROPRIETARY FUNCTIONS AND SOME
OF THE PROPRIETARY LANGUAGES
THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT OVER THE
YEARS.
SO THOSE THOSE ARE F. PEAS ARE
OFF OF THOSE ARE OUT ON THE
STREET NOW AND WILL BE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS -- SO WE CAN
STABILIZE THE STACK AND SO WE
CAN INDEED ADD ON OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE FEZ IN A
SUCCESSFUL MANNER -- THAT WILL
NOT. TO USE A COMMON TERM BREAK
THE BACK OF THE I. T. SYSTEMS A
DMV I THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR --
THAT WERE RAISED I APPRECIATE
YOU -- MADAM SECRETARY LET ME
LET ME BEAGAIN BY ASKING --
KIND OF AN OVER ARCHING QUESTION --
WE HEARD THAT THE CHARGE OF THE
STRIKE TEAM BY THE GOVERNOR WAS
TO QUOTE. TO TO QUOTE YOU
REINVENT THE DMV.
AND MY QUESTION IS FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT ROLE DO YOU
PERCEIVE THE LEGISLATURE AS
PLAIN AS YOU.
WORK TO REINVENT THE DMB AND I
ASKED THAT QUESTION FROM THIS
PERSPECTIVE.
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT IS IN CRISIS?
PARTICULARLY A DEPARTMENT.
THAT IS FUNDAMENTAL.
IT'S PIVOTAL. TO THE EXPERIENCE
OF EVERY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT. TO
THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT BEHOOVES US.
TO HAVE EITHER IN AN
ANTAGONISTIC OR NON INCLUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
YOU'VE HEARD QUESTIONS AND
YOU'VE HEARD THE LA L. SUGGESTS
TO US IN RESPONDING TO QUESTIONS
THAT THAT WE SHOULD BE IN A
POSITION OF ESTABLISHING
EXPECTATIONS A FRAMEWORK.
YOU'VE HEARD MY COLLEAGUE TALK
ABOUT.
DEPARTMENTS COME IN ASKING FOR
MONEY BUT WE DON'T HAVE A SENSE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY WE HAVE A
OVERSIGHT ROLE TO PLAY AS
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO IF YOU ARE UNDERTAKING A
JOB AS SIGNIFICANT AND BIG AS
REINVENTING A STATE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT ROLE IS THE LEGISLATURE
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE SUPPOSED
TO PLAN THAT?
A VERY AIM CENTRAL AND IMPORTANT
ONE AS YOU SAID MADAM CHAIR
EARLIER AND WE'VE HEARD
INDIVIDUALLY FROM MANY MEMBERS
BOTH FROM THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY.
THIS IS EITHER THE NUMBER ONE OR
THE NUMBER TO CONSTITUENTS ISSUE
THAT YOU ARE FACED WITH.
THAT MEANS IT'S A POLITICAL
IMPERATIVE AND FOR FOR US IT IS
A CUSTOMER SERVICE IMPERATIVE
AND AS YOU SO WELL SAID NOW I'M
CHAIR -- THE DMV IS S. SERVICES
EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH YOUR COMMENT THAT -- IT
SHOULD NOT BE A A
CONFRONTATIONAL RELATIONSHIP IT
SHOULD BE A PARTNERSHIP.
AND THE THE LEGISLATURE I'VE I'M
OF COURSE SECRETARY GOV OPS AND
I WAS NOT INVOLVED IN THE DMV
UNTIL THIS.
RECENTLY SO I WASN'T INVOLVED IN
ALL THE ACTIVITY LAST SUMMER AND
FALL.
BUT YOU PARTNER AND WITH THE DMV
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL IN
PROVIDING RESOURCES AND MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES AT THE TIME AND
I SEE GOING FORWARD THAT WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION THE STATE EVERY
EVERY AGENCY EVERY DEPARTMENT IN
THE STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
REPORT.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE AND WHAT
THEY ARE DOING WITH THE
IMPORTANT APPROPRIATIONS THAT
YOU HAVE GIVEN US INTERESTED IN
US?
SO -- THE THE THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME FOR CASH FOR
DMV IT REALLY REALLY IS THE
NUMBERS ARE HORRIFIC TO THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO TRANSACT.
TWICE AS MANY TRANSACTIONS AS
THEY CURRENTLY ARE DOING IN
ORDER TO GIVE THOSE PEOPLE A
REAL ID WHO NEED NEEDS ONE BE
FOUR OR NEED ONE BEFORE OCTOBER
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY I MEAN I I
MENTIONED THAT WE'RE DOING THIS
POP BUT DMV WITH HEALTH NET AND
AS A PILOT.
AND THAT YES INDEED DOES FOCUS
ON BUSINESS TRAVELERS BUT OUR
COMMERCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT MUST
TRAVEL TO CONTINUE THE COMMERCE
OF OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY MUST HAVE A REAL IDE.
UNLESS THEY ARE WILLING TO USE
AND HAVE A PASSPORT BUT
CERTAINLY NOT EVERYONE DOES.
THOSE ARE SCARY NUMBERS TO ME
FRANKLY.
AND AND WEHAVE.
TO BETWEEN NOW AND THEN IT WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN. TO ON TO INCREASE
THE SUCCESSFUL ASH ONCE OF A
REAL ID AND THAT IS AS I'VE
OUTLINED THAT'S GETTING PEOPLE
OUT OF THE FIELD OFFICES THAT
DON'T NEED TO BE THERE.
THAT CAN TRANSACT ELSEWHERE
ONLINE.
AT A KIOSK WE HAVE TO EVENTUALLY
AFTER THE CRISIS PASSES AND AYE
CONSIDERATE THAT.
WE DO HAVE TO REINVENT THE DMB
WE DO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
PROCESS IS AS WE ARE DOING WITH
OUR PILOT WITH MACKENZIE THAT IS
LOOKING AT HOW THE PROCESSES --
FUNCTION HOW THE DMV FIELD
OFFICE FUNCTIONS AND REMOVING
THOSE NON ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS OR
PROCESSES FRANKLY SOME OF THAT
FLOW HAS BEEN THE SAME WAY SINCE
PROBABLY WELL BEFORE YOU MANY OF
YOU WERE BORN -- WE HAVE TO
BRING IT INTO THE FUTURE.
AND AS I SAID WE HAVE SIX MONTHS --
JULY IS WHEN I'M SUPPOSED TO RUN
SORT OF HAND OFF TO THE NEXT
FOLKS.
OR THE DMV AND HOPEFULLY MANY OF
OUR IDEAS ARE SHORT TERM AND
MANY OF THEM ARE LONG TERM AND
ALL WILL BE IMPLEMENTED.
THE POINT OF MY QUESTION IS
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THESE
NUMBERS AND THE EXPECTED
WORKLOAD ARE UNPRECEDENTED.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT OUR
STRATEGY IN TERMS OF THE
PARTNERSHIP LOOK DIFFERENT TO
THE STATUS QUO IS SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH. TO SIMPLY COME TO US
AROUND AN EXPECTATION FOR
PROCREATION IS ON THE BACK IN
AND OFTEN TOO LATE.
AND SO THE POINT OF MY QUESTION
IS BECAUSE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE PROBLEM I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
WOULD FIGURE OUT A DIFFERENT WAY
IN WHICH WE CAN PARTNER.
NOT SIMPLY COMING TO BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
UP THROUGH APRIL FINANCE LETTERS
TO JAIL BC REQUEST BUT EVEN --
MEMBERSHIP ON THE STRIKE TEAM
SOME WAY IN WHICH WE ARE ENGAGED.
AND SO WHEN IT'S TIME THAT WE
HEAR THE PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE QUITE FRANKLY YOU HAVE
ADVOCATES ON THIS SIDE OF THE
TABLE AS WELL PEOPLE WILL
PARTNER WITH YOU HAVE BEEN A
PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
AND AND FEEL AND HAVE A SENSE OF
CONNECTION TO THE PROPOSED
RESOLUTIONS I FULLY APPRECIATE
THAT THAT MAY BE A DIFFERENT WAY
IN WHICH A STRIKE TEAM THE
ADMINISTRATION FINANCE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
WORKS TOGETHER BUT AS YOU SAID
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT IMPACTS EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
THAT WAS THE POINT OF MICHAEL
QUESTION BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
THINK CREATIVELY AS WELL IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU ENGAGE US.
ON THE FRONT IN TO PARTNER WITH
YOU IN IDENTIFYING SOLUTIONS AND
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THEM
APPRECIATE THAT I APPRECIATE THE
INNOVATIVE THINKING INTO AND DO.
OUR FIRST SENATOR MINING
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DERIVE SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR ORGANIZING THIS OPPORTUNITY.
WANT TO THANK THE PRESENTERS SIN --
IN MY QUESTION.
TIM IS BAD TEACHER FOR YEAR
LEADERSHIP ON THE STRIKE TEAM
IT'S APPRECIATED.
LET ME JUST PREFACE MY QUESTIONS --
WE DO HEAR FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
OF FRUSTRATIONS AND COMPLAINTS
WE TRY IT.
HELP TO THE EXTENT WE CAN.
WE ALSO DO HEAR FROM SOME PEOPLE
THAT -- APPRECIATE THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE THEY HAVE RECEIVED SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK
AT THE BIG PICTURE IN THE BIG
CHALLENGES -- THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF DEDICATED STAFF THAT ARE
TRYING TO MAKE.
A TOUGH SITUATION BETTER INDEED --
THERE ARE -- SO I DO WANT TO
JUST TAKE KNOWLEDGE THAT.
A LOT OF FOCUS ON THE REAL ID --
WE HAVE BEEN CONTACTED BY
CONSTITUENTS WHO WENT TO THE DMV.
PROVIDED THE DOCUMENTATION AND
NOW READ IN THE NEWSPAPER THAT
THAT DOCUMENTATION.
PERHAPS WASN'T SUFFICIENT
BECAUSE OF A CHANGE IN WHAT'S
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- HAD A SOMEBODY WHO
SECURED THEIR REAL ID.
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT IT'S GONNA
WORK FOR THEM WHEN THEY GO TO AN
AIRPORT IN TWO YEARS.
DOES THE END DMV REACH OUT
AFFIRMATIVELY TO THOSE WHO WERE
ISSUED A REAL ID BUT NOW REQUIRE
FURTHER DOCUMENTATION DINO.
SENATOR -- I'M AWARE OF THE
WHOLE CIRCUMSTANCE AND AND COULD --
ANSWER THAT I THINK HOWEVER IT'S
MUCH BETTER THAT -- ACTING
DIRECTOR WEB ANSWER IT BECAUSE
SHE IS A PERSON.
WITH IN HOME AND WITH HOME AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
COMMUNICATING.
SO I'D I'D I WILL DEFER TO HER
OKAY IN THEM I AM GLAD TO FOLLOW
UP.
ON THE BIGGER RELY TEAM PICTURES
SOUNDS LIKE FROM YOUR COMMENTS
AND TRYING.
TO MANAGE INCREASED DEMAND.
LARGELY THROUGH REAL ID I
BELIEVE WAS IN YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT RELY DE APPLICATION.
DOES REQUIRE A PERSONAL
INTERFACE BETWEEN THE APPLICANT
YES WHETHER THEY HAVE A PRE
EXISTING.
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
NOT THERE HAS TO BE AN INTERFACE
THAT'S A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ASSIGNMENT YES IT IS SIR.
SO AS WE TALK ABOUT KIOSKS AND
REMOTE ACCESS AND IDEAS FOR THE
FUTURE.
IN THE PRESIDENT TO SECURE REAL
ID REQUIRES.
PRESENCE OF THE APPLICANT YES
SIR IT DOES AND HOWEVER THERE
ARE MANY MORE TRANSACTIONS
MILLIONS OF TRANSACTIONS THAT
ARE DONE DAILY BY DIEM THE FIELD
OFFICES.
THAT INDEED COULD BE DONE ONLINE
OR AT A KIOSK OR AT A TRIPLE A
OFFICE AND SO ONE WAY TO RELIEVE
THE PRESSURE IN THE OFFICES.
EXACT OR THAT CAN BE DONE FROM A
HOME COMPUTER OR EVEN SUGGESTED --
A BUSINESS -- ENVIRONMENT AND
SUPPORT YES YES LIKE THE POP
PUNK YES SIR THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
WE WANT TO GET AS MANY A 100%
WOULD BE PERFECT.
OF THOSE TRANSACTIONS THAT DO
NOT NEED TO BE DONE WITHIN THE
DMV OFFICE WE WANT THAT MOVED IN
TO THE AREA WHERE THEY CAN BE
TRANSACTED OUTSIDE OF THAT.
THE FIELD OFFICE AND AGAIN
PERHAPS THIS IS ALSO QUESTION
FOR THE DMV BUT DO YOU NOW.
DID THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CHANGE.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR DOCUMENT
PRESENTATION YES THEY DID SIR
AND AGAIN I AM THEY DID.
AND AND ACTING DIRECTOR WELL
WILL BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN IT BUT
THEY DID CHANGE THE REQUIREMENTS
ON ON CALIFORNIA'S WELL AS OF
THE STATE'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATOR
DORADO FOLLOWED BY CENTER
NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I
UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY BEHIND
IMMEDIATE.
CHANGES THAT NEED TO HAPPEN THAT
AT THE DMV AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
FOR YOUR WORK.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME -- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT.
ARE CHAIR HERE HAS SAID ABOUT
MORE OF A CS IS PARTNERS TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD. ONE OF THE REASONS
I THINK IS BECAUSE WE'VE SORT OF
TREATED DIEM V. AS HERE'S A
SERVICE TO GO GET.
YOUR CAR REGISTERED TO GET A A
DRIVER'S LICENSE IT'S NOT SEEN
AS WHAT I THINK IT SHOULD BE
WHICH IS.
THIS IS A DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY
THAT HAS TO DO WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY.
YOU KNOW DRIVERS YOU KNOW IF YOU
WANT A DRIVER'S LICENSE YOU
BETTER LEARN THE RULES OF THE
ROAD.
THAT'S PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S ABOUT
CARS GETTING THEIR SMOG CHECK SO
IT'S ABOUT CARS THAT ARE IN GOOD
SHAPE AND OUR ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING INSURANCE
IMAGINE ALL THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND BUSINESSES THAT
RELY ON ON THAT YEAH.
NOW WE RELY ON IT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IT'S A SECURITY SYSTEM I
MEAN A DRIVER'S LICENSE IS ONE
THING BUT A DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
OR ON AIDID.
ARE -- ARE WE DEPEND ON THEM TO
BUY A USE OUR CREDIT CARDS YOU
HAVE TO SHOW AN ID.
ARE YOU HAVE THERE'S SO MANY
WAYS IN WHICH WE HAVE TO SHOW A
VALID ID SO IT'S A SECURITY
DOCUMENT AS WELL.
AND EVEN MORE SO NOW WITH THE
REAL ID THAT YOU CAN EVEN TRAVEL
SO.
COMMERCE DEPENDS ON THE
FUNCTIONING OF THE DM B..
THE ABILITY TO BUY AND SELL THE
ABILITYTO TRAVEL OUR AIRLINES
WILL BE.
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED -- WITH
THESE NEW RULES SO I GUESS I'M
JUST TRYING TO HEAR.
NOT ONLY THE PARTICULARS A WE
WANT TANGIBLE PARTICULAR WAYS IN
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE AND CHANGE THE OUTCOMES
AND THE RESULTS.
ARE ALSO ONE OF A VISION ABOUT
HOW CRITICAL THIS AGENCY IS. TO
EVERY CALIFORNIANS THIS IS NOT
JUST SORT OF DID YOU GET GOOD
SERVICE YOU KNOW CUSTOMER
SERVICE WHEN YOU WENT TO GET
YOUR YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE.
THIS IS A VERY VERY BIG DEAL TO
THE WHOLE STATE SO I GUESS I
WANT. TO HEAR.
HOW THAT VISION? FOR HAVE A IN
OF DYNAMIC EFFECTIVE.
AGENCY BECAUSE OF ITS IMPACT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THROUGH
COMMERCE AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
HOW THAT BECOMES A PART OF THIS
RE INVENTING OF THE DMV NOT OKAY
HOW MANY DO WE GET THROUGH THE
DOOR TODAY?
THAT'S A REALLY DIFFERENT
ATTITUDE AND I I THINK WE NEED.
TO DO BOTH.
I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I
TOTALLY AGREE AND COULD NOT
STATED BETTER THAN YOU IN TERMS
OF ITS GLOBAL REACH.
AND ITS GLOBAL IMPACT FROM
COMMERCE AND AND AND AND IN YOUR
LISTS CENTER I WOULD ADD ALSO
THE COMMERCIAL LICENSING.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SO -- AND IT
SPINS WILL STATED ON HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT IT'S YOUR NUMBER
ONE OR NUMBER TWO ISSUE AND ALL
OF YOUR OFFICES -- YOU YOU CAN'T
MAKE IT MORE IMPORTANT THAN THAT
I MEAN WE LITERALLY COULD JUST
STOP FUNCTIONING AS A STATE IF
THE DMB IS NOT FUNCTIONING
PROPERLY.
I HOPE OUR APPROACH IS GLOBAL IN
NATURE IT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
LOOK AT BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
PROCESSES OF THE OF THE ACTUAL
FIELD OFFICE TO MODERNIZE THAT.
WERE LOOKING AS I'VE TALKED IN
MY TESTIMONY WE HAVE AN R. F..
O. OUT ON THE STREET NOW.
TO BRING IN ARCHITECTURAL FIRMS
THAT WILL LOOK AT THE FLOW AND
HOW YOU ARCHITECT AND DESIGN FOR
BETTER MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE.
AND PLACEMENT OF OF OF THE
SERVICING OF THOSE PEOPLE ALL IN
IN THE END RESULT TO BE NOT JUST
GIVING GOOD CUSTOMER SERVICE
THAT'S CRITICAL BUT MAKING SURE
THAT THE FUNCTIONING OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CAN CONTINUE BECAUSE MUCH OF OF
OF THE HEART OF IT IS INDEED THE
FUNCTION OF DAM THE ISSUE SO
WELL STATED
[inaudible]
THE THE AGENCY.
DO YOU EMPLOY WHAT ARE KIND OF
INTERNAL.
TELL THE OVERSIGHT THROUGHS SUCH.
MECHANISM IS UP BUT BUNCH MEN.
OF ADVOCATES CITIZEN ADVOCATE
SEED OF IT OR INSPECTOR GENERAL
THIS WITH ANY OF THOSE APPLY TO
THE THE DMB.
WELL SIR -- I'M THE HEAD OF THE
STRIKE TEAM AND THE DMV.
RESIDES IN THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY NOT WITHN GOV OPS SO LET
THEM ADDRESS THAT HOWEVER YES
THERE ARE NONE ON BEDS PERSONS --
CENTER ROTH IS VERY WELL AWARE
OF HOW THOSE UNCTIONS WORK AT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
AND THERE IS AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL AT CALTRANS SO I KNOW
FUNCTIONS LIKE THAT OPERATE IN
AGENCIES AND AT DEPARTMENTS IN.
IN DIFFERENT OVERSIGHT
CAPACITIES AND GIVE.
A VOICE -- TO AN INDEPENDENT
VOICE TO PEOPLE THAT USE THE
SERVICES AS ICE MENTION LIKE F.
T. B. FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS NOT THE SUBJECT TO THIS
HEARING BUT ANOTHER [inaudible]
BIG RESPONSIBILITY. FOR STOOD ON
YOU YEARS AGO WAS MOTOR VOTER.
THE EVENT PROBLEMS WITH THAT.
NOW IT.
HAS THAT NOW DIMINISHED IS A
PROBLEM FOR YET SUFFICIENTLY
THAT YOU CAN REDIRECT RESOURCES
NOW. TO THIS MORE REAL ID THING
THAT'S AT MORE CLOSELY BEFORE
OTHER AGAIN SIR I THINK THAT'S A
QUESTION BETTER ON POSED AND
ANSWERED BY ACTING DIRECTOR WEB.
DO THAT THEN WITH THEM OKAY
THANK YOU SIR AND THEN THE LAST
WAY I'D DESCRIBE TO THE TEARS.
THE SUGGESTION OF WHAT I PLAN TO
CALL OUR INTERACTIVE FOR THE
PARTICIPATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER INTERESTS.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WOULD
INCLUDE THE HIGHWAY PATROL.
TO VERY MUCH A PARTNER THANK YOU
SIR TO STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY IN
SIZE -- TO SEE YOU AND I'M ALSO --
AND AGREE WITH SENATOR NELSON
IT'S NICE TO HAVE YOU AS A PART
OF THE STRIKE TEAM AND AND I AND
I AGREE WITH ALL MY COLLEAGUES
THAT CHIU YOU'VE -- EMBRACE THE
THE LEGISLATURE HAVING A KEY
ROLE IN AND HELPING TO BASICALLY
TAKE A DEPARTMENT IN DISARRAY
AND PUT IT BACK ON TRACK TO
BEING -- PROUD DEPARTMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SAY
THAT WITH A COUNTY GOT THAT I
WOULD SAY THE 90% OF OUR
EMPLOYEES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES ARE REALLY GREAT
PEOPLE -- I GO THERE AND THEY
STRIVE TO TO REALLY HELP IN.
LEADERSHIP STARTS OF THE TOP.
AND SO WHAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING ON THIS SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE THANK YOU ANY AND YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD TO A LOT OF
INTERESTING -- COMMENTS AND ONE
OF THEM IS -- THE CREDIT CARD
ISSUE -- YOU KNOW WE'RE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE BASICALLY
THE CAPITAL OF TECHNOLOGY IN THE
WORLD SENATOR BILL KNOWS THAT IT
REPRESENTS THAT AREA -- I CAN GO
INTO A STORE THAT ACCEPT APPLE
PAY I COMPLETE MY PHONE AND
SECURELY I CAN PAY MY BILL IN
TWO SECONDS.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S MINE NOBODY
CONTRACT THAT CREDIT CARD NOBODY
CAN HACK THAT CREDIT CARD -- I
WOULD URGE YOU TO OUR RECHARGE
THE SUMMER TECHNOLOGICAL
COMPANIES THAT.
WHETHER BE APPLE OR SOMEBODY
ELSE -- AND I I'D I'D PERSON
UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED WE NEED A
PILOT EVERY EVERY STORE -- EVERY
OPERATION IT SEEMS LIKE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU WANT
TO GET THE POINTS ARE SLIDING
THEIR CREDIT CARDS -- THE ISSUE
OF OF CREDIT CARD FEES ARE GOING
TO COME UP -- IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU SEE THE STATE ABSORBING
OR YOU SEE THAT SOMETHING IS
GOING TO BE AN ADDED.
COST TO A CONSUMER WHEN THEY
COME HEY WITHIN THE BUDGET --
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE
AND THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE NOW -- IT IS
PROPOSED THAT THE CONVENIENCE
FEE WOULD BE PAID AND ABSORBED
BY THE CUSTOMER OKAY ANSWERING I
THINK IT'S IT'S USUALLY AROUND
ONE OR 2% I DON'T THINK THAT'S
DIFFERS.
IN IN THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
I THINK IT FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
IT'S TWO POINT 7%.
BUT WE HAVE A HIGHER VOLUME THE
FRESH TASTE THE HEX BOARDS SO SO.
YEARS AGO WITH THE POST OFFICE
TRIED TO DO TO LIMIT THE THE
TRAFFIC IN THE POST OFFICE IS A
LOUD OFFSITE PEOPLE TO SELL
POSTAGE STAMP FORGET ABOUT
GROCERY STORE TODAY.
SO WE HAVE A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP I GUESS YOU CAN SAY
WITH TRIPOLI THAT SENATOR MORE
LIKE REFER TO DO.
WHY DO WE GIVE THEM THE
EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS TO A
PARTNERSHIP LIKE THAT WHY WHEN
WE INCLUDE COMPANIES LIKE ALL
STATER?
OR OTHER INCH INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT DEAL WITH CAR
INSURANCE -- AUTOMATIC IF I WENT
INTO A MY INCH INSURANCE AGENCY.
I WOULD PAY THE EXTRA TEN BUCKS
IF IT MEANT I DIDN'T HAVE TO GO
TO THE DMV AND DO THAT PAPERWORK
IF THEY COULD DO IT RIGHT THERE
AND AND RECEIVE A FEE FOR A FOR
FOR DOING THAT ON OFF TRIPOLI
GETS A FEE FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- HOW THAT WORKS BUT
WHY WOULD WE DISALLOW ONE
INSURANCE COMPANY TO HAVE THAT
MONOPOLY IF YOU WILL OF
PROVIDING A STATE SERVICES YOU
GET NOWHERE ELSE EXCEPT THE DMV?
CENTER STONE I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE RESTRICTIONS THERE ARE
RESTRICTIONS WHICH I THINK
THERE'S A THE OF A BILL -- I
KNOW THERE IS AT LEAST A IDEA.
OF THE FOR A BILL PROPOSAL AND
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE SERVICES
THAT ARE BUSINESS PARTNERS --
CAN PROVIDE FOR ON THE DMV AND I
KNOW I'VE MET WITH THE AUTO
CLUB'S BOTH OF NORTH IN THE
NORTH AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY ARE REALLY EAGER TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE SERVICES
BUT I'LL LET -- THE DMB EXPLAIN
I'M I'M NOT SURE OF THE
EXCLUSIVITY OR THE LEAGUE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS PATIENTS AT ALL
FOLLOW UP WITH THEM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THEN THIS
LASTLY -- YOU KNOW THE FINALS.
WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO
MILLENNIALS ESPECIALLY WITH THE
RELY DE AND THE WAY HE REACH HIM
IS UNFORTUNATELY AFTER THESE
MACHINES RIGHT LATELY AND
GETTING ON SOCIAL MEDIA SO --
I'M GOING TO URGE THAT WE
COMMUNICATE BETTER ON SOCIAL
MEDIA I'M I'M GOING TO ASK THE
THE DIRECTOR BECAUSE I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR REAL ID EXCITER CONFLICTING.
REPORTS I HAVEN'T GOTTEN MINE
YET SO I DO WANT TO BE ONE OF
THOSE 20% TO GO TO THE DMV THEY
DO NOT.
HAVE THE RIGHT INFORMATION
YOU'RE GOING TO COME BACK AND
LASTLY I'M GONNA SAY THAT.
WHEN PEOPLE COME INTO THE DMV
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONE STATE
AGENCY THAT THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT'S REALLY THE FACE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY WE WANT PEOPLE
TO HAVE A GOOD EXPERIENCE WHEN
THEY GO TO THE DMV -- AND AND BE
ABLE TO STREAMLINE THEIR
SERVICES GET THEM AND GET THEM%
OUT GET THEM THE DOCUMENTS THAT
THEY NEED ESPECIALLY THE
COMMERCIAL WHICH WAS VERY WELL
WELL ARTICULATED.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO ACHIEVE
THESE GOALS THANK YOU SIR AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT IT
WITHIN THE PROPOSAL IS ON A AND
I ASK.
THERE IS A PROPOSAL TO ASK.
FOR MONEY.
TO DO A ENTIRELY NEW I TESTIFY
TO IT CAMPAIGN WHICH HEAVILY
WILL USE -- IF IF
IT'S APPROVED EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO COMMUNICATE BETTER
THAN WE HAVE WITH THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ON ALL MEDIUMS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING AND CHANNELS.
AND WITH REGARD TO YOUR PLAN TO
SHUT DOWN FOR A FULL DAY OF
TRAINING YES YOU KNOW THAT WAS
THE LEADING NEWS ISSUE -- THE
LEADING TRAILER FOR ALL NEWS
MEDIUM WHEN STARBUCKS WAS ON A
CALLS FOR DAY FOR THEIR TRAINING
EVERYBODY KNEW IT AND SO I HOPE
THAT AS A PART OF YOUR OUT REACH
CAMPAIGN I HAVE SAID.
EVERYONE KNOWS THE DMV IS GOING
TO BE CLOSED THIS DAY THAT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY AND I'VE
SPOKEN OR STARBUCKS ABOUT HOW
THEY WENT ABOUT THAT EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT SENATOR MORLOCK
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR ROBB
[inaudible]
SURE -- FEEDBACK I'VE GOTTEN
FROM MY CONSTITUENTS IS -- WE
ARE.
GOING TO RENT A HOTEL ROOM.
AND WE'RE GONNA DRIVE PALM
SPRINGS FROM ORANGE COUNTY TO GO
TO THE DMV BECAUSE THE OFFICES.
WE CAN GET TO IN AND OUT OF A
QUICKER SO THAT'S THE FEEDBACK
I'VE BEEN GETTING.
OUT IN PUBLIC SO I'M A LITTLE
FRUSTRATED THAT THUNDERSTONE IS
GETTING.
P. O. T. REVENUES IN.
SALES TAX REVENUES BECAUSE MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE GOING TO PALM
SPRINGS TO GO TO THEIR DIEM BE.
FOR ALL THAT JUST SOME ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION FOR YOU.
BREAK COVERED THE SERVICE FEE
YOU KNOW THE IDEA IT WOULD WE WE
FIGHTING GOVERNMENT FOR THE
LONGEST TIME HAVING TO DEAL WITH
EMERGING FAIR FEE WITH VISA AND
ALL THE REST.
SO OUR OUR OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ALSO HAVE A ALSO KNOWN NOT.
IMPLEMENTED THE ABILITY TO USE
CREDIT CARDS FOR THE SAME REASON.
THERE TEN I'M AWARE OF THAT
THERE IN OUR RESEARCH THAT THEIR
TEN DEPARTMENTS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT THAT
OFFER CREDIT CARDS AND ALL. TEN
OF THEM -- CHARGE A CONVENIENCE
FEE TO THE TO THE CUSTOMER --
PART OF THE ISSUE AT THE DMV OF
WHY THIS HAD.
NOT BEEN ACCEPTED EARLIER WAS
CONCERNED WITH THEIR IT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE CREDIT CARD PROCESSING
COMPANIES HAVE ADVANCED.
AS WE ALL WELL KNOW AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU CAN YOU CAN
BUY YOUR YOUR GIRL SCOUT COOKIES
WITH A CREDIT CARD NOW HAD THE
GIRLS GET OUT TO HIM IN TIME ME --
BUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
CONNECTIVITY WAS AN ISSUE FROM
THE FIELD OFFICES TO THE
HEADQUARTERS.
TECHNOLOGY HAS HAS OVER.
REACHED THAT AND THE YOU ASKED
IF I'D MET WITH THE CREDIT CARD
PROCESSING COMPANIES ALMOST
EVERYONE OF THEM IT SEEMS TO
TAKE SO WE WERE ABLE -- TO ALONG
WITH THE ASSESSMENT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IT DIEM BE.
ASSESSED THE CREDIT CARD
PROCESSING COMPANIES.
AND SOME OF THE I. D.
AUTHENTICATION COMPANIES AND
INDEED THEY WERE THOSE THAT
ANSWERED THE R. S. P. AND WERE
ABLE TO GO INTO THE TEST
ENVIRONMENT AT DMV AND TEST
WHETHER OR NOT -- THEY COULD
WORK WITH IN THE FRAGILE AND
UNSTABLE STRUCTURE.
AT THE DMV AND WILL BE LEARNING
THAT AND THIS WEEK I BELIEVE
BECAUSE THE TEST THE TESTING AT
THE LAB WAS DONE THE LAST TWO
WEEKS.
I THINK I'M I THINK I HAVE THAT
RIGHT.
I TO HAVE DEALT WITH THESE
MERCHANT FEES AT HAVING BEEN A
FORMER TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
WHEN.
PROPERTY OWNERS WANTED TO PAY
THEIR PROPERTY TAXES WE HAD A
CHARGE OF A 3% FEE WHICH ON
CERTAIN HOMES CAN BE QUITE A BIG.
SURCHARGE AS THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD.
THE I WANTED SERIOUS MILEAGE FOR
THEIR PLANE CREDIT CARD RESERVE
SIGN.
SO.
SO I'D LIKE TO TRY TO MEET WITH
THE INDUSTRY TO SAY WAIT A
SECOND I'M NOT A RETAIL SHOP.
THAT'S TRYING TO COMPETE WITH
OTHER RETAIL SHOPS AND THAT'S
WHY I PAY FOR THE CONVENIENCE OF
HAVING YOUR CREDIT CARD I'M A
GOVERNMENT.
I I DON'T.
NO I I IS I'M JUST WONDERING NOW
THAT WE HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO'S
GOING AFTER SAY FARM.
PHARMACY AND DRUG COSTS MAYBE WE
COULD COLLABORATE.
MAYBE THE COUNTY TREASURER'S AND
SAY HEY WAIT A SECOND WHY ARE WE
BEING CHARGED.
SUCH A HI FI LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
WHEN SHOULD GIVE US A GOVERNMENT
RATE IN.
JUSTIN IDEAS YOU RIGHT FINISH
THE STRIKE TEAM OPPORTUNITY IF
SO THE STRIKE TEAM IS IT SHORT
TERM.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN IN YOUR
POSITION?
I'M SECRETARY OF GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AND I'VE BEEN IN THAT
POITION SINCE JULY OF TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE GOVERNOR NAME ME TO
HEAD UP THE DMB STRIKE TEAM --
ALONG WITH MY DUTIES AS
SECRETARY GOV UPS.
IN JANUARY SO SINCE JANUARY AND
HE ASKED US TO DO -- OUR WORK
WITHIN SIX MONTHS SO.
ON WE HAVE SIX MONTHS TO STRIKE.
SO THEN WHAT OTHER DEPARTMENTS
RENDER YOUR SUPERVISION AND IF I
HAD ELEVEN DEPARTMENTS I HAVE
WHAT WE CALL THE THREE CONTROL
AGENCIES -- WHICH I DON'T LIKE
THAT TERM BUT DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES.
THE CALLIE T. R. AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY I HAVE
THE TWO MAJOR RAISE REVENUE
COLLECTING DEPARTMENTS FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD.
WHICH IS AN INDEPENDENT BOARD
BUT SEVERAL IS WITHIN GOV OPTION
I HAVE A CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FEE IN.
TAX ADMINISTRATION I HAVE
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS I HAVE --
VICTIMS COMPENSATION WHICH I
CHAIR.
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION IS ALSO SOMETHING I
CHAIR ON THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW IS WITHIN GOV
OPS -- FISCAL HAS ONE FOOT IN
GOV OPS UNTIL THE PROGRAM IS
COMPLETELY.
FINISHED AND THEN IT WILL COME
OVER INTO GOV OPS -- I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S ELEVEN BUT I
THINK THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD.
SO I COME FROM THE COUNTY
STRUCTURE IN SEBRING DEPARTMENT
HEADS AND I I'VE BEEN A LITTLE
FRUSTRATED AS IT IS A STATE
SENATOR THAT.
IN HOUSES PLACE RUNNING AND WHO
DO YOU CALL AND FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM THE
DMV WE GET A HEARING RIGHT AND
THAT'S ONE HEARING YEAR MAYBE
AND THEN I I GET YOUR FOR MAYBE
THIRTY MINUTES.
AND I GET LIKE TO ASK ONE OR TWO
QUESTIONS FOR FIVE MINUTES WHICH
IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT ANIMAL THAN
BEING A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
HOW HOW?
HOW DO WE?
TRY TO HELP THE STATE MANAGE
ITSELF BETTER -- YOU KNOW NOT TO
BE REAL DIRECTED YOU COULD KIND
OF TELL DEPARTMENT HEAD YOU KNOW
YOU JUST HAD AN AUDIT THAT WAS
MISERABLE.
THIS IS AWFUL.
DO YOU WANT A PICTURE DEPARTMENT
OR DO YOU WANT TO FIX YOUR
RESUME I MEAN WHAT.
WHAT WE DOING HOW DID WE GET
HERE SO WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT'S A
GOOD TIP FOR A SENATOR TO TO
SOMEHOW?
HELP YOU BUT ALSO.
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF YOU KNOW
GIVE A LITTLE ENCOURAGEMENT.
WELL DEPARTMENTS DO NOT GET INTO
CORACLE BAD SHAPE OVERNIGHT.
AND FRANKLY THEY DON'T GET OUT
OF QUOTE UNQUOTE BAD SHAPE
OVERNIGHT AND IT IS -- THE TWO
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT WORKING
TOGETHER THAT MAKE GOVERNMENT
FUNCTION -- AND WE HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH BUDGETS WE HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH POLICY ISSUES -- THERE
ARE LOTS OF STATUTES THAT GOVERN
THE WORK OF AND SEND THE WORK TO
FRANKLY THE DMV SO.
AS THE AS MADAME CHAIR SAID --
THERE ARE NEEDS TO COLLABORATE
WITH EACH OTHER THAT I THINK
WILL BE ARE THERE IS A NEED TO
COLLABORATE WITH EACH OTHER
THAT'S ALWAYS THERE AND WE CAN
ALWAYS DO BETTER WITH IT -- YOU
ALL HAVE YOUR IN THE FRONT LINES
WITH THE CONSTITUENTS WITH THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AS QUICK AS AS
EFFECTIVELY AS WE CAN AND WE CAN
DO THAT BY WORKING MORE CLOSELY
WITH YOU.
AND GAINING YOUR IDEAS AND THOSE
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS BUT DO YOU
ASK YOUR DEPARTMENT HEADS FOR AN
ANNUAL BUSINESS PLAN WHICH WOULD
ALL OF MY DOG ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS HAVE STRATEGIC PLANS --
WHICH EQUATE I THINK TO BUSINESS
PLANS -- THEY ALL ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO HAVE WORK FORCE
PLANS.
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE THIS YOU CAN
HAVE A WORKFORCE PLAN AND KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH YOUR
WORKFORCE OF YOU DON'T HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN WE HAVE TOTALLY
RE DONE AN AREA OF CALLIE CHAR.
ON TO ASSIST -- DEPARTMENTS IN
PUTTING THEIR WORK FORCE PLANSTOGETHER -- WE HAVE BLUFF DOT
AND RE.
INVIGORATED AND RE OPENED THE
TRAINING CENTER IN.
CALIFORNIA THAT CALLIE CHAR IN
ORDER TO HELP -- DEPARTMENTS TO
A MUCH BETTER JOB AT WORKFORCE
PLANNING AND STRATEGIC PLANNING.
A LITTLE OFF SUBJECT.
HAS THE DMV IS WAS NOT ONE OF
YOUR DEPARTMENT SO.
IT IS NOT SECRETARY OF THE DMV
HAS THAT PERSON BEEN ASKING FOR
STRATEGIC PLANS AND WORK FORCE
PLANS OVER THE LAST. TEN YEARS I
THINK THE YES THE AND AGAIN --
ACTING DIRECTOR WEB CAN ADDRESS
THAT BUT YES THE DMB DOES HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
SENATOR RAW THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN SECRETARY GOOD TO SEE
YOU GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR THANKS
FOR TAKING THE SON I KNOW.
YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T HAVE -- TO
AFTER READING THE REPORTS AND I
DID READ THE AUDIT REPORT.
TEN IN YOUR REPORT BOTTOM
SECRETARY ANY OTHER DOCUMENTS
THAT -- PROVIDE THE BACKGROUND
FOR THIS COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO ME THAT THE
PROBLEMS AT THE DMV -- SPANNED
SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIONS OF
VARIOUS FLAVORS.
YOU ARE NOT -- IN A PARTICULARLY
ENVIABLE POSITION HAVING TO MEET
THE DEMANDS OF THIS REAL ID MASS
AND ALL THE OTHER SERVICES THAT
THE DMV PROVIDES AT THE SAME
TIME AS YOU AND THE DEPARTMENT
REINVENT THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY IN THIS IS IN
THE NATURE OF A COMET MADAM
CHAIR THAT.
MA'AM SECTORS YOU ROOM RECALL AS
A AS A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR --
NOT TOO MANY YEARS AGO YEAR --
TO I HAD THE GREAT PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH YOU ONE OF ON
FRANKLY A MAJOR.
VERY DIFFICULT REORGANIZATION --
OF GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS IN THIS
STATE AND YOU DID SO
SUCCESSFULLY.
AND IN TERMS OF THE
COLLABORATION AND COOPERATION OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE DISCUSSED A
FROM THIS DíAS I HAVE NO DOUBT.
AND SINCE YOU DEMONSTRATED IT
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME --
THAT MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN.
IN YOUR ACTIVITIES IN THOSE
SUBSEQUENT ACTIVITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN REINVENTING THAT
DEPARTMENT AT THE SAME TIME.
AS THE DEPARTMENT MEETS THE
CHALLENGE OF ROLLING THESE REAL
ID'S OUT. TO COMPLY WITH THE THE
FEDERAL RULE SO I LOOK FORWARD
INTO PARTICIPATING THAT PROCESS
WITH YOU AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
TAKING ON THIS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TASK THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IN IN A FOLLOWING
UP ON SENATOR ROSS COMMENT -- I
GUESS THAT WASN'T NECESSARILY MY
ASSUMPTION THAT THERE WOULD BE
AN ONGOING ROLE I'VE HEARD THAT
THE STRIKE TEAM WAS -- ASKED TO
COMPLETE ITS WORK IN SIX MONTHS
WE WERE AND HE TOLD THE WILL
WILL THERE BE A HARD STOP.
IN TERMS OF AT AND WHAT AND WHAT
WILL YOUR IN PRODUCT LOOK LIKE.
MADAM CHAIR -- MY MY ASSIGNMENT
IS UNTIL JOHN JULY AND SO --
THAT'S WHAT I'M WORKINGTOWARD
AND ANSWER YOUR SECOND QUESTION
WAS WHAT IT WOULD LOOK WHAT WILL
BE THE END PRODUCT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT IS UNTIL JULY
THEY'LL BE A FINAL REPORT WILL
YOU PRIORITIZE WE TELL THE D. M.
V. THIS IS WHAT WE THINK YOU
NEED TO DO.
AND IN THIS ORDER WHAT WOULD
THAT LOOK LIKE WE ARE DOING THAT
ON A DAILY BASIS FRANKLY I THINK
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE RUN
THROUGH TODAY -- SHOWS THAT AND
AND WE I'M SURE WILL BE ASKED.
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
PERHAPS THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY TO PROVIDE SOME TYPE OF A
FINAL REPORT BUT WE HAVE BEEN
REALLY.
SEENAND DOING REAL TIME IN REAL
TIME -- LIKE THE POP UPS LIKE
THE R. F. Q. IN THE R..
AND ON THE CREDIT CARDS.
IT IS THOSE WILL BE IN THE FIELD
BEFORE.
BEFORE I AM DONE BEFORE THE
STRIKE TEAM IS DONE SO.
I NEVER ENVISIONED THIS AS A
REVIEW AND THAT INVESTIGATION
AND WHATEVER AND THEN A REPORT.
AT THE GOVERNOR REALLY WANTED
ACTION AND ALL HANDS ON DECK ALL
HANDS ON DECK YEAH I'M ASSUMING
THAT THERE WILL BE PERHAPS A
LONGER TERM STRATEGIC YES I'M
HOPING.
I'MHOPING THAT -- INFORMATION
THAT WE GATHER FROM -- THE
MCKINSEY -- REVIEW AS WELL AS
THAT WHICH WERE DOING ON THE
REDESIGN REFLOW THE
ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN OF THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WILL HAVE A MUCH
LONGER -- THREE BUSINESS
ENGINEERING IF YOU WILL OF BOTH
THE PHYSICAL AND NATURE OF DMB
AS WELL AS THE PROCESSING NATURE
OF THE DMV.
SO YES YOU SHORT TERM LONG TERM.
EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'VE.
ALL I DIDN'T SEE YOU.
SENATOR STONE STERN.
AS CHAIR -- THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY FOR TAKING ON THE HARD
ISSUES ALWAYS -- WE ALL KNOW IS
AN ACCEPTABLE SO I DON'T NEED.
TO BEAT A DEAD HORSE HERE I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD.
IT FROM MY COLLEAGUES QUITE WELL
BUT I WANT TO ASK YOU JUST A
JUST TO REFINE A LITTLE BIT OF
YOUR THINKING ABOUT -- ON THE
MILLENNIAL HERE.
RIGHT AND APPRECIATE CENTER
STONE BRINGING UP.
THIS APPLE PAY CONCEPT THAT'S
NOT IN YOUR CREDIT CARD INFO
CORRECT APPLE PAY IS NOT WITHIN
THE ORDER I'M I'M NOT SURE IF IT
WE WE IN THE RFQ.
WE DID ASK THE THE VENDORS TO
PROVIDE DIFFERENT MEANS OF OF
ACCEPTANCE AND DIFFERENT TYPES
OF CARD ACCEPTANCE I SHOULD KNOW
SPECIFICALLY AND I'LL GET BACK
TO BUT I THINK WE CAN YES -- AND
THEY'LL BE DEPENDING ON WHICH IS
THE WINNER OF THE OF THE
PROCUREMENT.
THAT IT AND AND ONE OF PLEDGES
OF A TURNAROUND TIME THERE AND
DOING SOME INNOVATION AROUND
PROCUREMENT PERIOD RIGHT THIS
GOVERNOR'S BEEN.
PULLED IN THIS IS PROBABLY RIGHT
FIRST PLACE TO START IN TERMS OF
HOW.
TO GET A CUP -- TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING CAPACITY THAT WE
STARTED DON'T ALREADY HAVE I
KNOW TRIPLE A WAS REFERRED TO IN
SOME LEGISLATION.
CAN YOU SEE ON THE TSA SIDE OR
EVEN ON ON A TRIPLE A SADDAM IS
THERE IS THERE ANY THOUGHT OF
USING OTHER CERTIFICATION
PROCESS IS SAY YOU'VE ALREADY
BEEN CLEARED BY TSA.
AND SORT OF MAKING THAT COUNT
TOWARDS THE PROCESS YOU DON'T
DID READ DOCUMENT AGAIN I KNOW
IT'S PROBABLY NOT A HUGE SLICE
THE POPULATION BUT IS THERE ANY
WAY TO SORT OF UTILIZE SAY OTHER
AGENCIES OR OTHER PROCESSES TO
DO THAT WORKS YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO THE FIELD.
OFFICE.
WELL AND I'M GONNA ASK -- A RE
DIRECT HERE QUESTION SENATOR.
TO THE ACTING DIRECTOR WEB.
HOWEVER REAL ID IS IS A MANDATE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
IS.
THE OVERSIGHT OF IT IS THE
HOMELAND SECURITY.
SO ON THERE WE ARE UNDER THE
STRICT IF YOU WILL ON RULES OF
OF OF THE HOMELAND SECURITY.
BUT DID THEY DID THEY REQUIRE.
DMV TO BE THE ENTITY DOING THE
DOCUMENT INTAKE FOR RELY
DECERTIFICATION OR IS IT IS IT A
LITTLE MORE OPEN ENDED HERE NOW
NO I BELIEVE IT'S DMB BUT AGAIN
ACTOR.
ACTING YEAH THIS WEB CAN ANSWER
THAT HAVE YOU THOUGHT THROUGH
ONE OTHER.
QUESTION TERMS OF JUST
INNOVATIONS YOU'RE YOU'RE
CONSIDERING AT THIS POINT --
UPLOADING DOCUMENTATION IS AT A
BETTER QUESTION FOR DMV'S ARE
USING A DIGITAL INTERFACE AYE
AYE AYE TESTIFIED TO IT IN MY ON
TESTIMONY THAT WE ARE -- WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE A COMPANY CALLED
ID ME.
THAT -- IT IS -- UTILIZING AND
NEST GRANT FROM THE UNIT FROM US
COMMERCE DEPARTMENT -- AND WE
ARE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
ITS IN IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL -- WHAT THEY CAN OFFER
AND WHAT THEY CAN DO SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN INDED UPLOAD THEIR
DOCUMENTATION HAVE IT
AUTHENTICATED ALONG WITH THEIR
I. D. IDENTICATOR?
THERE STILL IS A RICO REQUIRED
VISIT TO THE FIELD OFFICE BUT IF
THEY CAN UPLOAD THAT NEEDED
DOCUMENTS THEN THEY JUST GO INTO.
THE FIELD OFFICE AND THE
TECHNICIAN JUST SAYS OKAY GOD
GOT IT GOT IT DONE.
WE SO YES IT IS PART OF OUR
PROPOSAL.
GRAY AND SO THERE'S A GRANTS
THAT ENTITIES LOOKING THAT
TECHNOLOGY THEN YOU'D GO TO AN
R. F. Q. OF SOME SORT OF
EVENTUALLY ONE YES SELF LIKE HE
WAS SUFFICIENTLY TESTED IS RIGHT
RIGHT.
WELL OR EXPANDED THE THE MOVE
THEIR SERVICES WOULD BE EXPANDED
FROM A THEY'RE OFFERING NOW WITH
IN THE GRANT I DON'T APPRECIATE
OVER PREDICT THE FUTURE BUT DO
YOU THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF
PROCESS WE MIGHT SEE SOME
MOVEMENT ON THIS YEAR.
YESABSOLUTELY I MEAN AGAIN IF
IF THE BUDGETS ADOPTED ACCEPTED
ANDSO FORTH YESI WOULD I WOULD
SEE THAT AS IT'S AN EXPANDED
SERVICE THAT.
THE STRIKE TEAM HAS RECOMMENDED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THE THIRD AND FINAL
PANEL TO COME FORWARD.
DIRECTOR WEB I HOPE YOU'VE BEEN
TAKING COPIOUS NOTES ON THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE PROPERLY
DIRECTED TO YOU.
AS I LOOK AT THE PANEL -- I'M
ASSUMING.
ROBBIE CROCKETT IS BACK UP AND
SUPPORT FOR YOU BUT IT WON'T BE
A SEPARATE TESTIMONY.
CORRECT.
OKAY.
AND AMANDA MARTIN -- FROM
FINANCE -- WILL YOU AND MR
MONROE BOTH THE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY OR BACK UP JUST ONE
EXCELLENT AND THEN MISLI FROM LA --
IS HERE FOR DIVISIONAL QUESTIONS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OR WOULD
YOU BE PROVIDED TESTIMONY WE
HAVE ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT SO COLLEGE WE'RE GOING
TO BE HEARING FROM -- THREE
PEOPLE WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
DIRECTOR WAY UP AGAIN THANK YOU
I HOPE THAT LIKE THE SECRETARY
AT THE END OF YOUR PREPARED
REMARKS AT YOU WILL ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED.
BY MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THE HEARING WHETHER THEY'RE
HERE AND NOT STAFF WILL BE
TRACKING IT CAN GET THE ACCESS
TO THEM -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY APPRECIATE
YOU.
WELL THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIRWOMAN MITCHELL AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND PULL THE
MICHAEL CLOSER TO YOU.
WE WILL HAVE TO STRAIN THANK YOU
LETTER.
I AM KATHLEEN WEB ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES AND WITH ME IS
ROBBIE CROCKETT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIVISION.
THE ALLEY -- PROVIDED A GOOD
BACKGROUND REGARDING THE FEDERAL
COMPLIANT REAL ID CARD I WANT TO
PROVIDE MORE PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT
WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE THE FUTURE
IMPACTS TO DMV.
AND THE REASON FOR OUR TO JAIL
BC REQUESTS IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET REQUEST.
THE DMV ESTIMATES TWENTY EIGHT
POINT ONE MILLION CUSTOMERS WILL
CHOOSE TO GO TO A FEDERALLY
COMPLIANT REAL ID CARD.
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
WITH A POSSIBLY THIRTEEN MILLION
OF THOSE CALMER CUSTOMERS COMING
BETWEEN NOW.
AND OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY I WANT TO STRESS
WE ANTICIPATE THIRTEEN MILLION
CUSTOMERS COMING TO THE DMV IN
THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS HOWEVER.
AS SECRETARY BACHELOR REST RATE
RAISED WE KNOW THAT WE ALSO HAVE
RETURN CUSTOMERS OF ALMOST 20%.
DUE TO LACK OF CUSTOMER
INFORMATION AWARENESS WHICH
EQUATES TO THREE MILLION MORE
CUSTOMERS COMING INTO FIELD
OFFICES.
I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THAT
THESE ARE TRULY HISTORIC ON
PRESIDENT NUMBERS.
ARE BUDGET REQUEST WILL ENSURE
WE KEEP WAIT TIMES UNDER AN HOUR.
NOT GETTING THESE BUDGET REQUEST
APPROVAL RESULT IN US RETURNING
TO EXTENSIVE WAIT TIMES THAT
WERE EXPERIENCE LAST SUMMER.
OR WORSE.
BASED IN OUR ESTIMATES IF
CUSTOMERS STARTED VISITING FIELD
OFFICES EVENLY DIVIDED BETWEEN
THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
DMV IS LOOKING AT SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND PER MONTH FOR A
REAL ID WHICH CLOSELY REPRESENTS
THE POPULATION OF SAN FRANCISCO
OR GREATER FRESNO AREA EVERY
MONTH.
CURRENTLY DMV ISSUES A PROXY
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
REAL ID'S PER MONTH.
AND TO DATE HAS ISSUED OVER
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION REAL
ID'S.
THIS HISTORIC SCALE OF ALL THE
CUSTOMERS WHO HAVE YET TO COME
IS A HUGE CHALLENGE.
AND REQUIRES THE ENVY TO RESPOND
DECISIVELY.
EFFICIENTLY AND SWIFTLY ENSURING
WE HAVE THE EMPLOYEES THE PUBLIC
OUTRAGE STAFF TRAINING AND I
TEAM PERFORMANCE IN PLACE TO
FACE THE CHALLENGE AND
SUCCESSFULLY.
ENSURE WAIT TIMES REMAIN
CONSTANT.
DMV HAS THREE SEPARATE PENDING
BUDGET REQUESTS WE HAVE TO
CURRENT YEAR JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE REQUEST.
AND WORKING WITH THE STRIKE TEAM
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
HAVE CREATED A BUDGET PROPOSAL
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TERM PROVED
IN VAIN.
WE KNOW THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT
ASSN ONE TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILS
FOR YOU.
JAIL BC REQUEST OF FORTY POINT
FOUR MILLION IS NEEDED TO
REIMBURSE DMV FUNDS USED TO
DECREASE WAIT TIMES FROM AUGUST
TO FEBRUARY.
BY SIXTY FOUR MINUTES AND SINCE
LAST OCTOBER MAINTAINING IT
AVERAGE STATEWIDE WAIT TIME OF
LESS THAN ONE HOUR.
DMV HAD TO SPEND FROM FUNDS NOT
BUDGETED FOR CONTINUED SATURDAY
SERVICES.
OVERTIME HOURS AND TO PAY FOR
LOAN STAFF FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS THAT SUPPORTED DMV
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL EMERGENCY
HIRES.
THE FUNDS WE ARE REQUESTING WENT
TOWARDS OUR SUCCESSFUL EFFORT
PROVIDING EXPANDED HOURS OF
OPERATION THAT INCLUDED.
SATURDAY SERVICES AND SIXTY TWO
OFFICES EXTENDED HOURS AT
FOURTEEN OFFICES OVERTIME HOURS.
INCREASE PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
HOURS RETIRED IN NEW A TENSE AND
STAFF LOAN FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND STAFF TRAINING.
WE CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY THESE
RESOURCES HELP REDUCE WAIT TIMES
FROM AN AVERAGE HIGH I AUGUST
OF A HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
MINUTES. TO AN AVERAGE IN
FEBRUARY OF FIFTEEN MINUTES THIS
IS A REDUCTION OF SIXTY FOUR
MINUTES.
HOWEVER WITHOUT THE APPROVAL
THIS SPECIFIC FORTY POINT FOUR
MILLION REQUEST WE WOULD NEED TO
DRASTICALLY CUT FROM OUR BUDGET.
IN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS.
THIS WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES AND RESULT IN A
MEDIA ACTIONS THAT MAY INCLUDE.
AMONG OTHER THINGS ENDING THE
SATURDAY OFFICE HOURS AND ALL
EXPANDED HOURS.
STAFF REDUCTION THAT FIELD
OFFICES AND NO OVERTIME
IMPOSSIBLE DELAYS TO OTHER DMV
SERVICES TO RECOVER COSTS
ALREADY SPENT. FOR REDUCING WAIT
TIMES.
THIS WOULD RESULT A CUSTOMER
WAIT TIMES RETURNING TO THOSE
HISTORIC LEVELS THAT WE ALL
EXPERIENCED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
OR WORSE.
THE SECOND JAIL BC REQUEST FOR
SIX MILLION IS A JUMPSTART ON
SELECT REQUEST OF THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER TO PREPARE FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN SUMMERS
ORANGE.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES HIRING AND
TRAINING OF THREE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL TEMPORARY POSITIONS.
A ONE DAY TRAINING OF ALL FIELD
OFFICE IN CALL CENTER STAFF TO
ENSURE CONSISTENT AND EFFICIENT
DELIVERY SERVICE TO OUR
CUSTOMERS.
IT INITIAL MEDIA OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN ON REAL ID AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE DMV WEBSITE.
FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR THE DV
IS REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
THESE REQUESTS REPRESENTS AN 18%
TIME BOUND INCREASE IN BUDGET
AND RESOURCES. TO HANDLE THIS
UNPRECEDENTED A 100% INCREASE IN
TRANSACTIONS ASSOCIATE WITH REAL
ID IMPLEMENTATION AND INTENDED
TO MAINTAIN WAIT TIMES AND
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
THE COMPLETE BUDGET REQUEST WILL
OUT DMB TO FUND NINETEEN HUNDRED
PREDOMINATELY TEMPORARY
POSITIONS.
AT A COST OF APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO MEET A
MISSION CRITICAL OBJECTIVE.
PROVIDING THIRTEEN MILLION MORE
REAL ID'S SUCCEEDING THROUGH THE
NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS IS THE
HIGHEST SHORT TERM PRIORITY.
FUNDING WILL GO TO IMPROVE
TRAINING TO ENSURE THAT
CUSTOMERS ARE GETTING HIGH
QUALITY AND EFFICIENT SERVICE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
INCREASED REGIONAL MANAGEMENT
AND APPROVED OVERSIGHT OF FIELD
OFFICE OPERATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
TRAINING AND SERVICE IS
IMPLEMENTED CONSISTENTLY.
A LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR ON LINE
TRAINING THROUGH E. LEARNING
MODELS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET REQUEST
WILL HELP INNOVATE DMV.
FIGHTING READILY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES TO IMPROVE THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY IN
THE SHORT TERM BUT ALSO IN THE
LONG TERM.
AMONG THEM ACCEPTING CREDIT CARD
PAYMENTS AND FIELD OFFICES AND
OFFERING OTHER TECHNOLOGIES USED
BY MANY RETAILERS TODAY TO
BETTER SERVE CUSTOMERS BY
PROVIDING ON LINE CHAT.
CUSTOMER SERVICE EMAIL CHAT BOT.
A CUSTOMER RELATIONSHIP
MANAGEMENT SERVICE THAT INCLUDES
A LIVE CHAT SERVICES.
THESE TECHNOLOGY COSTA PROXY
FOURTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS WITH A FIVE POINT SEVEN
ONE TIME FUNDING -- EACH
ALTERNATIVE SERVICE CHANNEL
PROVIDES CUSTOMERS WITH THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WTH THE
IN THE IN THE MANNER THEY PREFER.
GETTING ANSWERS TO IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS AS APPROPRIATE REJECT
RE DIRECTING THEM AWAY FROM THE
FIELD OFFICE TO SERVICES
PROVIDED ONLINE.
THROUGH THE CALL CENTER OR SELF
SERVICE KIOSKS.
THE NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
REQUESTS FOR THE COMMUNICATIONS
CAMPAIGN IS A KEY COMPONENT TO
INCREASE PUBLIC AWARENESS.
IT IS VITAL TO OUR SUCCESS THIS
WOULD BE USED FOR VARIOUS MEDIA
CHANNELS AIMED AT REDUCING WAIT
TIMES BY BETTER INFORMING THE
PUBLIC.
AND INCLUDES TARGETING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
REGARDING WHICH TRANSACTIONS
REQUIRE FIELD OFFICE VISIT HOW
TO USE ALTERNATE CHANNELS SUCH
AS ALL MY CHAOS.
UP ONLY SERVICES OR CHAOS AND
WHAT DOCUMENTATION TO BRING IN
FOR REAL ID AND OTHER
TRANSACTIONS.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
CRITICAL INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING
REPLACEMENT OF OUTDATED
UNRELIABLE HARDWARE SUCH AS
TERMINALS SERVERS AND CIRCUITS.
AND EXPANDED NETWORK
REDUNDANCIES TO STABILIZE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THAT IS FRAGILE
AND AT RISK OF FAILURE.
AT A COST OF SIXTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL REDUCE
VULNERABILITY TO ALLERGIES SO
THE DMV IS NOT HINDERED BY
TECHNICAL OUTAGES AND FAULTY
EQUIPMENT.
YES WE ARE MAKING A SIGNIFICANT
REQUEST TO INCREASE DMV'S BUDGET
BY 18%.
BUT IT DOES PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES FOR DMV TO
ADDRESS THESE THE STORK IN ON
PRESIDENT LEVELS TO ACCOMPLISH
1100% MORE OF THE WORK REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN.
WAIT TIME REDUCTIONS IN PROVIDE
CUSTOMERS WITH EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE SERVICE. TO ENSURE
FULFILLMENT OF OUR GOALS AND
MEASURE OUTCOMES.
A BUSINESS WORK PLAN IS BEING
FINALIZED THAT WILL INCLUDE
PERFORMANCE METRICS.
AND TIME LINES FOR DELIVERY.
GOING BACK TO SOMETHING YOU
SHARE EARLIER BY COULD INTERRUPT
WEST SECOND AND WILL THAT PLAN
B. DEVELOP BEFORE -- THE JUNE
FIFTEENTH VOTE ON A BUDGET.
I WOULD SAY IT'S BEEN DEVELOPED
IS GOING THROUGH THE APPROVAL
PROCESS RIGHT NOW THANK YOU.
SO I WANT TO GO BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE COLDER
AREA EARLIER IS I BELIEVE IT'S
TOGETHER.
WE MUST ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE
CHALLENGES THAT WILL ALLOW THE
DMV TO CARRY ON THEIR PART IN
KEEPING OFFICES OPEN.
MANAGING WAIT TIMES AND
PROACTIVELY FACE THE CHALLENGE
OF SURVEYING AGAIN THIS IS STORK
NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS AT THIRTEEN
MILLION.
THAT WILL BE COMING INTO FIELD
OFFICES FOR REAL ID'S ALONG WITH
BEGINNING THE JOURNEY TO
MODERNIZE AND CREATE THE DMV OF
THE FUTURE. ONE THAT IS BETTER
EQUIPPED TO SERVE OUR CHILDREN.
I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING ME TODAY AND I AM
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER I'M SURE
MANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
ALREADY IS TODAY.
BEFORE I MOVE ON TO FINANCE --
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
TO ASK QUESTIONS WERE NO LONGER
HERE -- COULD YOU.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE SOME NOTES
DOWN GREAT SO -- I THINK ONE OF
THE ONES I WANT TO ADDRESS FIRST
OFF IS ON THE REAL ID
REQUIREMENTS WE DO HAVE A
CHECKLIST ON OUR WEBSITE.
THAT IDENTIFIES THE DOCUMENTS
THAT THEY NEED TO BRING IN WITH
THEM -- WE MAKE THIS CHECKLIST
AVAILABLE I THINK THE THING IS
IT'S NOT THE SAME FOR EVERY
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL -- IF YOU HAVE
A PASSPORT A PASS FOR CONSERVE
APPROPRIATELY THERE IS THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER -- WE
FIND THE PEOPLE GET CONFUSED
ABOUT THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER SOME DON'T HAVE A SOCIAL
SECURITY CARD ANYMORE.
AND NOT ALL OF YOUR WAGE
DOCUMENTS CONTAIN THE FULL
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER SO IT'S
REALLY BEING CLEAR THAT YOU LOOK
AT THE DOCUMENTS YOU'RE
PRESENTING.
AND THEN IF YOU HAD SOME NAME
CHANGES OVER THE YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO BRING IN THOSE
DOCUMENTS TO SHOW YOUR NAME
CHANGES SO WE ACTUALLY REQUIRE
EVERYBODY TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR YOU.
BASED ON YOUR LIFE AND YOUR NAME
YOUR NAME CHANGES AND THE
DOCUMENTS YOU HAVE AVAILABLE TO
BRING IN.
THE I THINK WHAT WE'RE HOPING IS
WITH THE MARKETING CAMPAIGN IS
WILL SIMPLIFY THAT IF YOU GO TO
AIRPORTS RIGHT NOW YOU'LL SEE
THERE'S SOME INITIAL.
INFORMATION AVAILABLE THAT
OUTLINES EVERYTHING THAT YOU
NEED TO BRING IN WITH YOU.
BASED ON YOUR PARTICULAR
SITUATION -- I THINK THERE WAS
ANOTHER QUESTION ON CHANGING THE
RESIDENTS INFO YEAH THE CHANGE
OF THE RESIDENCY -- SO.
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY -- D. A
DMV HAD BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SENSE YOU KNOW.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN ACTUALLY FINALIZED ITS
REGULATIONS FOR ALL OF THE
STATE'S.
WE OPTED TO PURSUE IN IN IN
RECOGNIZING WE HAD TWENTY THREE
POINT MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE
NEED REAL ID WAS THERE A
SIMPLIFIED PROCESS THAT WE COULD
EXERCISE.
WE SAW THAT THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN HAD ACTUALLY SELECTED
A SINGLE RESIDENCY DOCUMENT --
IN ADDITION TO THE ALL OF THE
OTHER DOCUMENTS WE THOUGHT THAT
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE THE SAME
PATH.
SO WE DID THAT -- AND SO WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ONLY
ASKED TO BRING IN ONE RESIDENCY
DOCUMENT WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
OUT IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
THEN HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE ACCEPTABLE THAT IT
WE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO HAVE
EVERYBODY BRING IN. TWO
RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS SO THEN WE
WENT ABOUT WITH THE RECODING AND
REPROCESSING EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEED TO DO -- THAT AS OF APRIL
TWENTY NINTH AND GOING FORWARD
WE ARE ACCEPTING TO RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTS I WILL SAY BETWEEN
JANUARY AND APRIL TWENTY NINTH
WE'VE HAD.
A NUMBER OF FOLKS ALREADY BRING
IN THEIR SECOND RESIDENCY%
DOCUMENT THERE WAS A QUESTION OF
HOW WOULD WE REACH OUT TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO I REFER TO AS OUR EARLY
ADOPTERS WHO CAME IN AHEAD OF
TIME TO GET THE REAL ID?
AND SO WE HAVE ABOUT THREE POINT
ONE THREE POINT TWO MILLION OF
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T -- PROVIDE AS
A SECOND ROSY DOCUMENT OUR GOAL
IS WE CAN ACTUALLY IDENTIFY ALL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND SENDING
MAILER OUT TO THEM.
AND THE MAILER ITSELF WILL
CONSTITUTE A STATE DOCUMENT THAT
THEY CAN THEN BASICALLY CHECK
AND SIGN OFF VERIFYING THAT THIS
IS THE INDIVIDUAL STILL THEY
HAVEN'T MOVED IF THEY'VE MOVED.
WILL HAVE TO ACTUALLY PURSUE A
DIFFERENT PATH WITH THEM BUT IF
THEY HAVE NOT MOVED THEY CAN
ACTUALLY MAIL THAT DOCUMENT BACK
TO US.
AND WE WILL CLUE POSTAGE FREE
ENVELOPES FOR THEM OR WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALSO HAVING THEM DROP
IT OFF -- AT A DMV OFFICE MY
GOAL IN THIS EXERCISE IS TO NOT
HAVING COME BACK TO A DMV OFFICE.
I DON'T NEED THAT FOOT TRAFFIC
COMING IN I WANT TO SIMPLIFY
THIS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW THAT
ONE OF THE RESIDENT ARGUMENTS
THAT QUALIFIES IS A STATE ISSUE
DOCUMENT.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT OUR DMV STATE
ISSUE DOCUMENT QUALIFIES FOR
THAT STATE ISSUE DOCUMENT.
AND IS THE SIMPLEST WAY WE CAN
HANDLE THAT.
WE ARE WORKING ALL THE THE THE
DATA PULL DOWN SO OUR GOAL IS
PROBABLY THIS SUMMER EARLY THIS
SUMMER I THINK THE GOAL IS. TO
SEND OUT OUR MAILING TO ALL
THESE INDIVIDUALS NOW THE GOOD
NEWS FOR FOLKS -- I THINK
SOMEBODY ASKED IN TWO YEARS WILL
THEY HAVE A FEDERALLY NON
COMPLIANT CARD.
THE DMV IN ITS LETTER -- TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOME -- BASICALLY
OUTLINED THE FACT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE THROUGH THE RENEWAL CYCLE
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL SO THEY MAY
HAVE FIVE PLUS YEARS FROM A
RENEWAL CYCLE DEPENDING ON IT.
TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE THEIR SECOND
RAZZIE DOCUMENT OF COURSE IF
THEY WANT TO COME IN AND HAVE
THE RENEWAL CYCLE WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE END
OF THEIR SECOND RESIDENT
DOCUMENT. ONE OF THESE WILL HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT IS WHEN WE GET TO
INDIVIDUALS RENEWAL CYCLE HOW
CAN WE MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY ARE ON NOTICE THAT WE-DON'T HAVE THEIR SECOND
RESIDENCY DOCUMENT OUR THOUGHT
IS MUCH LIKE WE DO SMALL TESTS
OR OTHER THINGS.
IS MAKE SURE WHEN THAT RENEWAL
NOTICES GOING OUT IS CLEARLY
SIGNALS THAT A SECOND ROSY
DOCUMENTS STILL REQUIRED FOR
THEM SO THAT THEY CAN STILL HAVE.
THEIR FEDERICA POINT CARD SO WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH THOSE
PROCESSES.
I SEEM TO RECALL FOLKS ASKING
MORE THAN JUST TO FOLLOW QUITE
YES DOES THE NOTE YOU HAVE MY
HOPE MEMBERS AND REMEMBER THAT
IT.
WAS ANOTHER QUESTIONS RELATED --
TO BUT IT'S BEEN PROGRAM AND SO
THE DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE A
SENIOR OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AS WELL
AND SO WE INTERACT WITH WITH THE
THE THE SENIOR COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
AND THEN THERE WAS ANOTHER
QUESTION AS RELATES TO WHAT
SPECIFIC DOCUMENTS AND AND THE
ACTING DIRECTOR HAD MENTIONED --
PRIMARILY -- FOR MAJORITY THE
CUSTOMER THE DOCUMENTS FOR REAL
ID ARE -- TO RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS
A MUSCLE SECURITY NUMBER WHETHER
EITHER BUSINESS CREDIT CARD OR
W. TO THE HAS THE FULL NUMBER ON
IT.
I'M ALONG WITH IDENTITY DOCUMENT
AND THEN THAT IF YOU HAVE A AND
A NAME CHANGE HAS MENTIONED --
JUST THE MAPPING ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT NAME CHANGE.
THING I'D I WANT TO ADD ON IS
THE ACTING DIRECTOR HAD
MENTIONED ABOUT THE SINGLE --
RESIDENTS ARE ACCURATE THAT WE
WENT FORWARD WITH THAT WASN'T
APPROVED PROCESS BY HOMELAND
SECURITY -- IT WASN'T IN REGARDS
TO WHAT'S GOING FORWARD WITH
THAT JUST BECAUSE WISCONSIN HAD
DONE IT WISCONSIN WAS BEING
COMPLY WITH REAL ID WE ENGAGED
HOMELAND SECURITY THAT WE WANTED
TO INCORPORATE THAT SAME PROCESS.
AND AND SO THEY HAD IDENTIFIED
SO THAT THAT WAS OKAY AT THAT
TIME.
SO SOMEONE DOESN'T HAVE THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY CARD BUT THEY
KNOW THEIR NUMBER IS THAT
ADEQUATE ARE YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT
PRINTED ON SOMETHING IT
PHYSICALLY HAVE TO BE ON A
DOCUMENT. FOR A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT THE FULL NUMBER NOT
JUST THE LAST FOUR DIGITS AND
THAT'S A GREAT POINT THAT WAS
ANOTHER THING THAT WE ACTUALLY
TRIED TO PUSH BACK ON EARLY ON
AS AN EARLY I'M FOR REAL ID.
IS THAT WE ACTUALLYDO
ELECTRONIC VERIFICATION OF SOUL
STURDY NUMBERS THROUGH THE
SUBSTRATE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
TRY TO BOMB.
A SEPARATE BACK BUT ENGAGE WITH
HOMELAND SECURITY AND SAY THIS
IS THE PROCESS WE DO TODAY WHY
DO WE NEED TO BRING IN A
PHYSICAL DOCUMENT.
THEY HAD SAID IT WAS A
REQUIREMENT THE REGULATIONS AND
THEY WERE NOT GOING TO CHANGE IT.
SENATOR A THING MENSURAL I
HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF THOSE WHO
HAS A REAL ID WITH.
ONE RESIDENTS VERIFICATION
DOCUMENT.
SO IT EXACTLY HOW TO Y..
WELL I KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW YET
BUT I'D I WOULD HOPE THAT I
WOULD NOT HAVE TO GO DOWN TO THE
DMV AND DROP OFF A DOCUMENT I
WOULD HOPE THAT THERE WOULD BE A
WAY TO AYE THE MAIL TO YOU.
OR UPLOAD IT SOMEHOW TO YOU.
SO YOU COULD HAVE IT IN YOUR
FILE -- AND HAVE ME AVOID THE
APPOINTMENT PROCESS NOT THAT IT
WAS PAINFUL I WENT TO MY LOCAL
OFFICE AND IT WAS JUST FINE --
BUT WHEN DO YOU THINK YOU'LL
HAVE THAT PROCESS NAIL DOWN SO I
DON'T.
FORGET AND WAIT TO MY RENEWAL --
SO AGAIN -- WE THE GOAL IS AND
SOME LETTERS OUT EARLY THIS
SUMMER TO ALL THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH.
THE REAL ID PROCESS AND HAVE A
SINGLE RESIDENCY DOCUMENT THAT
THEY PROVIDE AND AGAIN OUR
PREFERENCES THAT WE'RE GONNA
SEND A STATE ISSUED DOCUMENT
WHICH WILL SERVE AS CONFIRMATION
OF YOUR RESIDENCE CAM.
AND WITH THE POSTAGE RETURN
ENVELOPE THAT YOU CAN DROP IN
THE MAIL BACK TO US THAT WOULD
BE OUR PREFERENCE.
WELL WE ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF UPLOADING I
THINK THAT GETS TO THE HEART OF
THE WORK THAT IT CREATES BACK IN
OUR OFFICES WITH OURS THE
SCANNING AND AND TRANSACTING
THAT THROUGH OUR TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS WHICH I THINK HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT -- NEED SOME HELP --
WE HAVE AN AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
FROM A TECHNOLOGY STANDPOINT.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO IS I MORE
READILY HANDLE THE TRANSACTION
OF SCAN YOUR DOCUMENT MAKING
SURE IT'S US ASIDE WITH YOUR
DOCUMENTS YOUR PROFILE -- AND
THAT WOULD BE THE EASIEST I
THINK MOST EFFICIENT WAY FOR US
TO HANDLE IT WE THOUGHT FOR SOME
FOLKS THEY MAY WANT TO DROP IT
OFF BUT I THINK AT THE END OF
THE DAY OUR PREFERENCE ORGAN
INSTRUCT FOCUSES WE'D PREFER. TO
GO AND HAVE YOU MAIL IT BACK TO
US AND THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
RECORDED ACCORDINGLY.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING WE'RE
LOOKING AT AS CONFIRMATION WHAT
WOULD BE THAT CONFIRMATION LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE FOR SAVED IN
THE U. OF I'M I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED AGAIN.
WHEN WE WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS
WHEN I WENT THROUGH THE REAL ID
PROCESS -- I DIDN'T I DON'T
REMEMBER DO YOU SCAN THE
DOCUMENTS THAT I BROUGHT TO THE
DISTRICT OFFICE AND KEEP THEM IN
THE SYSTEM SO YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
KEEP THE THE RESIDENTS AND
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS IN YOUR
SYSTEM SOMEHOW CORRECT SO IF I
MAIL A THE PROPERTY TAX
STATEMENT THAT HAS MY AS
RESIDENTS.
ON AT MY ADDRESS AND MY NAME YOU
WOULD HAVE TO SCAN THAT INTO
YOUR SYSTEM CORRECT AND THEN
PRESUMABLY DESTROY THE ORIGINAL
SO YOU'RE NOT KEEPING OR OR SEND
IT BACK TO ME.
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
ENTIRE PROCESS CORRECT.
BECAUSE WERE GIVEN OUR DOCUMENTS
BACK WHEN WE LEAVE THE D. LOCAL
DMV OFFICE OKAY ENOUGH ON THAT
NAME CHANGES SO I JUST WENT
THROUGH THIS. FOR MY SPOUSE THIS
WEEKEND AND THE CHECKLIST WORKS
FINE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE WEBSITE AND IN A COMPUTER
AND I WENT THROUGH THE CHECKLIST.
NOW.
SHE OBVIOUSLY HAD A DIFFERENT
NAME BEFORE SHE MARRIED ME ARE
ARE YOU REQUIRED TO WASN'T CLEAR
TO ME FROM THE CHECKLIST ARE YOU
REQUIRED TO BRING.
DOCUMENTS TO THE DMV -- OFFICE
REFLECTING YOUR MAIDEN NAME.
AS WELL AS YOU WERE MARRIED NAME.
IS THAT THAT IS CORRECT OKAY.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS BECAUSE I WILL
LET HER KNOW BEFORE SHE GETS
THERE ON FRIDAY.
YES THANK YOU AND IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
IF SHE WERE NOT THE BRILLIANT
WOMAN I KNOW SHE TO BE AN LET'S
SAY SHE DIVORCED SENATOR OFTEN
AND ANOTHER GENTLEMAN.
SHE WOULD THEN BE REQUIRED TO
BRING IN PROOF OF MADE NAY.
HER MARRIAGE LICENSE SHOWING HER.
MARRIAGE THE SENATOR ROBB.
HER DIVORCE DECREE SHOW AND
SEPARATION AND THE HER MARRIAGE
LICENSE TO NEWT SET HAS BEEN.
IF THEY ALL INVOLVE NAME CHANGES
FOR HER YES.
TRAGIC DEATH SOME.
MORE LOG BOMB YOU HAD A QUESTION
I THINK THAT THE SECRETARY
SUGGESTED IT WILL BE MORE
PROPERLY DRECTED -- TO THE
ACTING DIRECTOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO POSE THAT NOW.
SURE I'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
BUSINESS PLANS STRATEGIC PLANS
WORK FLOW.
PLANS.
I KNOW YOU'RE NEW TO THE
POSITION OR I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG YOU BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT -- THE WHAT'S WHAT'S
OCCURRING.
IN THAT REGARD.
SO I HAVE BEEN THERE SINCE
FEBRUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR --
AND HAVE BEEN ON A FAST PACED
LEARNING CURVE BUT WHAT I WILL
TELL YOU.
IS THAT -- THE DMV DOES HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN IT WAS DONE BY
THE PRIOR DIRECTOR IT IS A FIVE
YEAR STRATEGIC PLAN.
AND THAT WE DO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
THIS IS PLANTS THAT ACTUALLY
FALL OUT OF THE STRATEGIC PLAN
WHICH YOU WOULD NORMALLY WOULD
HAVE BECAUSE THAT GETS INTO YOUR
TACTICAL APPLICATION OF YOUR
STRATEGIC GOALS.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
OF TASK MY ENTERPRISE GOVERNANCE
COUNCIL WHO ACTUALLY IS INVOLVED
WITH THE STRATEGIC PLANNING.
PROCESS MANAGEMENT COMPONENT IS
THAT EVERYTHING I SHARED WITH
YOU EARLIER ABOUT OUR WORK PLAN.
OUR BUSINESS PLAN WORK PLAN IS
ALL GOING TO BE INTEGRATED INTO
OUR STRATEGIC AND BUSINESS PLANS.
SO THAT WE IS A GROUP ON A
MONTHLY BASIS ARE REVIEWING OUR
PROGRESS AND ALL THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
AND CREATE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
AMONGST OURSELVES -- THAT ALSO
BECOMES A REPORT THAT I CAN
CERTAINLY SHARE WITH THE CAL
COVERING TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
AND ANY OTHER ANY OTHER PARTY
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THOSE PROGRESS REPORT SO.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO US WORKFORCE
PLANNING IS ALSO ANOTHER
IMPORTANT AREA I JUST.
RECENTLY SIGNED OFF ON DMV'S
WORKFORCE PLAN IT'S A VERY HIGH
LEVEL DOCUMENT.
I NEED TO GET INTO FURTHER
DETAILS ONE OF THE TASKS THAT I
AM WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
IS OUR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
DEVON DIVISION I AM ACTUALLY
BRINGING IN SOMEBODY TO DO A
WORK FORCE ASSESSMENT OF THAT
TEAM BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE HIRING.
THE RIGHT SKILL SETS AND
CAPABILITIES INTO THAT OPERATION
SO THAT WE CAN BECOME THAT
MODERN TECHNOLOGY ARM FOR THE
DMV.
SO THAT SOMETHING WERE ENGAGE
WITH BECAUSE I REALLY NEED MAKE
SURE AS WE'RE GOING OUT TO
RECRUIT AND HIRE IT IS THE RIGHT
SKILLS THAT WERE BRINGING INTO
THE ORGANIZATION.
AND MAYBE FOR MISTER CROCKETT
SINCE I'M ASSUMING YOU'VE BEEN
WITH THE DMB FOR AT LEAST TEN
YEARS -- THE LEGISLATURE SEEMS
TO BE ADDING [inaudible]
WORKLOAD.
ON ITS OWN MOTOR VOTER.
DECALS FOR CARS IN THE CARPOOL
LANE CONSIDERED CENTER -- HAVE
YOU BEEN ACCOMMODATING THAT IN
HIS -- POINT WHERE YOU SAY WAIT
A SECOND WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO
SOMEHOW MAKE THIS FIT IN OUR
BUSINESS PLAN.
THIS WHOLE MOTOR VOTER
IMPLEMENTATION YOU KNOW EVERYONE
WAS WARNED THAT WASN'T GOING TO
WORK.
IN APRIL AND AND AND A WIN
ANYWAY.
SO HOT HOW DO YOU.
PROVIDE SOME COUNSELING PUSH
BACK TO MAKE SURE THINGS ARE
BEING DONE AT THE RIGHT TIME
WITH THE RIGHT SOFTWARE AND
RIGHT [inaudible]
STEPHANIE.
CORRECT IN ITS IN ITS A
CHALLENGE AT THE END OF THE
BALANCING ACT OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
THE LEGISLATION THAT'S BEFORE IT
IS IS REALLY GOOD -- LEGISLATION
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND ALL YOUR ANSWERS
CONSTITUENTS I THINK THE THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE DO END UP --
ENCOUNTERING SOMETIMES IS A LOT
OF LEGISLATION REQUIRES SOME
CODING.
AND SO WHEN YOU START TO HAVE I
HAVE ALL THE DIFFERENT CODING
THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO DO IT
BECOMES A DOMINO EFFECT IN
REGARDS TO HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE
THE CODING.
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT WE RUN
INTO IS A LOT OF TIMES --
BECAUSE OF THE THE BENEFICIAL
NATURE OF THE LEGISLATION.
THAT HS -- IMPLEMENTATION DATES
THAT ARE EITHER COMING UP YOU
KNOW SIX MONTHS FROM THE FROM
PASSAGE OR A LOT OF TIMES ARE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE TRIES TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH.
THE INDIVIDUAL OFFICES FOR
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATES I
THINK THE BIGGEST THING OF
BENEFIT FOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD BE.
IN REGARD TO THAT IS GOING BACK
TO THE COMMUNICATION IT'S MORE
THAN JUST COMMUNICATION EVEN ON
THIS STUFF IT'S COMMUNICATION ON
ON BILLS THAT THAT ARE IMPORTANT --
TO YOU GUYS AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AS IT RELATES TO
LET'S MAKING SURE THAT I'M THAT
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT.
I THINK IT DOES A MANAGER THANK
YOU THANK YOU FACT FOLLOW UP ON
THAT HOW ARE YOU BALANCING THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF REALIZE DE.
WHICH WEEK WE CAN SEE THAT
HEADLIGHT COMING RIGHT AT US
WHAT THE THE KINDS OF LONG TERM
MANAGEMENT REFORMS THAT ARE
NEEDED THAT WE HEARD VERY
CLEARLY ARTICULATED AS A RESULT
OF THE AUDIT.
YOU KNOW COURT CUSTOMER SERVICE
FUNCTION FUNCTIONS LIKE TRAINING
SO HOW ARE YOU [inaudible]
BALANCING.
SO GREAT QUESTION -- AND ANYONE
INNINGS I WOULD SAY THAT I HAVE --
LEARNED AND BEING THERE I'M IN
AND I AGREE WITH THE FINDINGS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SAY.
IS SOME SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE CHALLENGE WITH A RELEASE OF
SAY WITH THIS SYSTEMIC ISSUES AT
THE DMV AS YOU'VE POINTED OUT.
HOWEVER -- WE ALSO KNOW WE HAVE
AN IMMEDIATE NEED WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS WITH RELATING.
SO I WOULD SAY ONE WE'RE ASKING
YOU TO SUPPORT -- BRINGING IN
PEOPLE BUT BRINGING IN PEOPLE IS
NEVER A LONG TERM ANSWER.
BRINGING IN PEOPLE'S ADDRESSING
A SHORT TERM DEMAND THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE FACING OVER AT LEAST
THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
I ANTICIPATE THAT NOT ONLY DO WE
HAVE THE OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TIME FRAME WILL PROBABLY
ACTUALLY HAVE A TAIL AFTER THAT.
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT WAKE UP ONE MORNING
AND SAY.
YOU KNOW MAYBE I NEED TO GET
THAT REAL ID I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE MY PASSPORT WITH ME ALL THE
TIME.
SO I WOULD SAY GOING TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
ACTIVITY -- BUT I WHERE I'M
FOCUSED AND I'VE ALWAYS KIND OF
TAKEN THIS APPROACH EVEN SERVING
IN THE GULF OFFICE AGENCIES THE
DIRECTOR PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
ORGANIZATION AS TO WHAT I CALL
THE THREE LEAVES THE STORE.
THE WORK FORCE IN THE WORK FORCE
HAS TO GO THROUGH TREES REMOTE
TRANSFORMATION BUSINESS
PROCESSES WE HAVE MANY BUSINESS
LINES IN FACT I WOULD SAY OF ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS I'VE HAD TO WORK
WITH THE DMV IS.
YOU KNOW MOST LIKE A RETAIL
OUTLET IN THAT IT SO HOUSE MANY
PRODUCT LINES THAT IT SERVES.
AND WE HAVE TO DO A BUSINESS
PROCESS ASSESSMENT REALLY AROUND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
PRODUCT LINES WHETHER IT'S MOTOR
CARRIER PERMITS DRIVER'S LICENSE.
MOTOR VEHICLE REGISTRATIONS
TILING ALL OF THEM WE NEED A
DIVE INTO A LOOK AT THOSE
BUSINESS PROCESSES AND THEN
THERE'S TECHNOLOGY
TRANSFORMATION -- I THINK WHAT I
LOOK WHEN I SEE DMV I SEE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WE HAVE DONE --
DEFERRED MODERNIZATION OF DMV
FOR MANY YEARS I MEAN WHEN I SEE
THAT WE ARE RUNNING A SIMILAR
CODE WHICH IS SO OUTDATED IT'S
EVEN BEFORE COLD ALL CODE AND WE
HAVE CALL BOB CODE -- AND I LOOK
AT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE NOT
NIMBLE WE ARE NOT AND CHILD.
AND WE AND WE DO A CODE CHANGE
IT TAKES SOMETIMES MONTHS TO DO
GO THROUGH THE TESTING
ENVIRONMENT BUT WE'RE OFTENTIMES
GIVEN A VERY SHORT DURATION TO
BRING SOMETHING UP WHICH MEANS
WE WILL HAVE PROBLEMS THERE WILL
BE SOME.
GLITCHES IN THE SYSTEM -- BUT I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU BECAUSE THIS
CAME UP.
EARLIER TO QUESTIONS HOW DO WE
COMPARE WITH ALL THE OTHER
STATES IN THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
HANDLING THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE. ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS I BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH AND THEY ARE A GREAT
RESOURCE TO US INTO ALL OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES.
IS THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
MOTOR VEHICLE DMINISTRATORS.
IT IS ACTUALLY A GROUP OF FOLKS
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT DO MOTOR
VEHICLE OR DRIVER'S LICENSE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHAT I FIND FASCINATING IS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THEY ISSUED A
LARGE BUSINESS PLAN AROUND
TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION FOR ALL
DMV'S.
IF YOU ACTUALLY DO ANY KIND OF
GOOGLE SEARCH YOU'LL FIND A
NUMBER OF OUR STATES THAT ARE
EMBARKING UPON TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FOR THEIR DIEM --
I WOULD ALSO TELL YOU THERE IS
THE ISSUE AROUND.
THE REPUTATION OF MOTOR VEHICLE
ORGANIZATIONS THEY'VE JUST
ISSUED ANOTHER PAPER GUIDING
MOTOR VEHICLE ORGANIZATIONS ON
HOW TO BUILD REPUTATIONS.
IN THEIR STATES -- ANOTHER
REALLY INTERESTING -- ONE IS
WITH THE CARDS TO JUST I I THINK
RE IMAGINING THE DMV FOR EVERY
STATE.
I THINK WE REALLY HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT UP IN I ALMOST A
BORDERLINE NINETEENTH CENTURY
MODEL OF DOING BUSINESS.
MY MANTRA WITH STAFF IS THAT
THIS JOURNEY IS ABOUT US MOVING
FROM OUR GRANDPARENTS DMV TO OUR
CHILDREN'S DMV.
AND I THINK SOMEBODY ALLUDE TO
THE FACT THE DMV IS REALLY
BLESSED WITH A LOT OF VERY
CARING AND PASSIONATE EMPLOYEES.
IN MY JOB AND MY ACTING ROLE
HERE IS TO MAKE SURE I GIVE THEM
THE TOOLS.
AND THE TRAINING TO BE AS
SUCCESSFUL AS THEY CAN BE IN
THIS MODERN AGE OF DELIVERING ON
OUR MISSION.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT I
FIND INTERESTING IS IF YOU
GOOGLE EVERY STATE IN THE NATION
IS FACING ISSUES AROUND REAL
IDEA PROCESSING TIME I SAW AN
ARTICLE.
RECENTLY IN TEXAS THE WHERE THEY
WERE ENCOUNTERING FOR A FIVE
HOUR WAITS -- I KNOW THAT THE
STATE OF KENTUCKY RECENTLY IS
DELAYING THEIR ACTIVITY BECAUSE
OF SOME SYSTEM ISSUES -- SO IT
GOES ON AND ON EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS.
THIS CHALLENGE BUT I WILL TELL
YOU IT'S A GREAT ENVIRONMENT FOR
BEST PRACTICES SHARING A
SECRETARY BACHELOR REYES INDEED
ANNA'S DOING SOME REALLY
INTERESTING WORK -- NEW YORK HAS
DONE SOME INTERESTING WORK --
AND SO WE TRY TO LEARN FROM
OTHER STATES AND SAY WHAT WOULD
BE APPLICABLE AT THE SCALE WE
NEED TO DO IT HERE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
IT'S A GREAT RESOURCE FOR US AND
CERTAINLY FOR YOUR STAFF --
ENCOURAGED HIM TO LOOK AT THE
WEBSITE BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
GREAT INFORMATION OUT THERE AS
WELL.
I THANK YOU I'M GOING TO ASK --
I KNOW CENTER LEYVA WHO'S NOT
HERE ASK A QUESTION I'M JUST
GOING TO ASK STAFF IF YOU FOLLOW
IT WITH WITH WITH HER OFFICE
WITH REGARD -- TO THE FIRST
SLIDER TO IN THE ALLEY -- WAS
PRESENTATION IT TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THE TEMPORARY STAFF HE
WOULD YOU KNOW YOU KNOW HOW LONG
HOW YOU WERE DEFINING TEMPERS OF
WE CAN CIRCLE BACK WITH HER --
IT'S CLEAR -- YOU'VE BEEN CLEAR
AS HAVE OTHERS ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES ALL.
WITH THAT OUR LACK OF ACTION ON
THE APRIL LETTERS IN THE GLBT
REQUEST WOULD HAVE I APPRECIATE
HEARING.
THAT THEY PLAN IS PUT IN PLACE
THAT WILL INCLUDE METRICS
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WILL BE
MOST HELPFUL FOR US IS
UNDERSTANDING THE AFFIRMATIVE
OUTCOMES OF THE INVESTMENT.
AND SO I'M CERTAINLY HOPING THAT
THAT DATA WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
US PRIOR TO AN ULTIMATE BUDGET
VOTE -- BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WILL HELP INFORM AND GIVE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES A SENSE OF EASE.
MORE OF A SENSE OF EIGHTIES --
AS WE EMBARK ON TRULY STEPPING
UP TO THE PLATE -- AND
ACKNOWLEDGING -- WE HAVE COME TO
THIS POINT IN TIME INDIAN THESE
HISTORY AS A RESULT OF A LONG
TERM LACK OF INVESTMENT OR
PERHAPS APPROPRIATE INVESTMENT.
AND SO HOPEFULLY -- THOSE
METRICS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO US --
TO HELP US MAKE THAT DECISION --
WE'LL MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS AMANDA
MARTIN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
THE INTERESTS OF KEEPING THE
TRAIN MOVING I WILL BE VERY
BRIEF AND BUDGET FOCUSED IN MY
COMMENTS -- BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
PAGE SIX OF YOUR AGENDA DOES LAY
OUT THE FUNDING HISTORY OF
REQUESTS FOR APPROPRIATIONS THE
FIRST FOUR ROWS ON THAT PAGE
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PROPOSAL WAS
ORIGINALLY A FIVE YEAR PROPOSAL
BUT GIVEN THAT REAL ID WAS JUST
STARTING THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE FIRST TWO YEARS
WITH THE ANTICIPATION OF COURSE
THAT WE WILL BE BACK IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH IS WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW -- THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION SUBMITTED AN
ADDITIONAL REQUESTS ON JANUARY
THIRD BASED ON DISCUSSIONS WITH
PLEDGE STAFF DEPARTMENTS
COMMITTED TO EXTEND THE JAIL B.
C. REVIEW PERIOD -- AND TO NOT
APPROVE THE AUGMENTATION UNTIL
THE LEGISLATURE COULD HOLD A
HEARING ON THE MORE PRIDE ISSUES
AGAIN MY WERE HERE TODAY.
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM --
SAYING THE STRIKE TEAM AN ACTING
DIRECTOR WEB IS GIVING YOU A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR SPRING
FINANCE LETTER -- BUT IS THIS
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
MAKE ONE CLARIFICATION ON THE
NUMBERS.
ON THE AGENDA NOTES THE PROPOSAL
AT FOUR HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO MILLION -- ACTING
DIRECTOR CITED TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX MILLION BOTH ARE
CORRECT.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE TWO
NUMBERS IS -- THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION OF NON MBA FUNDS TO
REFLECT THE PASSING THROUGH A
CREDIT CARD CHARGES SO THAT IS
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE TWO
NUMBERS.
I ALSO NOTE THAT THE BUDGET
AFTER TWENTY EIGHTEEN REQUIRES
THE DMV TO SUBMIT MONTHLY WAIT
TIME REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
AND HE USED TO MAKE THEM THROUGH
AT LEAST DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS AFTER
THE OCTOBER ONE TWENTY POINT.
EIGHT FUND THESE REPORTS INCLUDE
NOT ONLY ARE WAIT TIMES BUT ALSO
THEIR PROGRESS ON HIRING OF
POSITIONS AND SO THOSE ARE
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE
MONTHLY AS ONE OF OUR
COMMUNICATION TOOLS -- BUT WE
HAD WELL AS THE INCREASING
PERCENTAGE OF REALIZED THE
TRANSACTION SO WE WILL CONTINUE
TO KEEP THE LEGISLATURE INFORMED
THROUGH THIS MECHANISM AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ON A
CRAFT [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
THE BILL.
OF THIS.
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNTY -- WHEN I
LOOKED AT THE REPORTER THINK
IT'S SO?
PAGE ZERO WORLD PAGE SEVEN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A FULL FINANCE
LETTER.
IS A MOBILE YOU'RE -- REQUESTS
CORRECT -- TOOLS SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
OF ACCORDING TO MY CALCULATIONS --
I THINK.
WHAT THE QUESTION WOULD BE IS --
THE MOTOR VEHICLE CAL IS
STRUCTURALLY UNBALANCED.
COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR PROBLEM OR ISSUE OR
WHAT WAS THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT
GONNA LOOK LIKE.
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS WITH
THIS EXTRA.
MONEY THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN
OUT OF THAT ACCOUNT.
IS IT GOING TO REQUIRE -- FEE
INCREASES AND OTHER KINDS OF
REVENUE THAT -- WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT SO CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE.
CERTAINLY SAYS AS PART IN THE
PETITION -- ACTUALLY WITH OUR
SPRING FINANCE LETTER WE
PROVIDED WHICH WE DON'T NORMALLY
DO BUT WE DID PROVIDE AN UPDATED --
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT FUND
CONDITION STATEMENT THAT
REFLECTS THE INCREASED
EXPENDITURES -- IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT WE WILL BE UPDATING THE
REVENUES THAT'S PART OF THE MAY
REVISION BUT JUST LOOKING AT IT
RIGHT NOW.
THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT DOES
DIPPED TO A LOW OF ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION IN RESERVE
AND I BELIEVE IT'S BUT YEAR PLUS.
TWO BUT WE HAVE ADJUSTED I
WITHIN THIS BY PASSING THROUGH.
A TRANSFER OF ALMOST NINETY
MILLION A YEAR THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND
NINE TEN TO THE GENERAL FUND WE
SUSPENDED THAT TRANSFER SO ABOUT
MONEY REMAINS IN THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT -- VAT TRANSFER IS
NOT WHAT WE CALL NON ARTICLE
NINETEENTH NOT.
COMING FROM -- CAR JUST RATIONS
IT'S IT IS A THAT'S WHY I HAVE
BEEN IN PAST PASSED THROUGH.
TO THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT'S
BEING SUSPENDED WE HAVE ALSO
DELAYED SOME CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECT AND PROPOSED SWITCHING
SOME OF THOSE PROJECTS FROM --
CASH FUNDED MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT -- TO PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUND TO CONTINUE
THOSE PROJECT PROJECTS THAT FOR
WHICH ARE ARE FAR DOWN THE ROAD
AND SO WE HAVE TAKEN SEVERAL.
EFFORTS TO ALLOW THE MEDICAL
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNTY REMAIN
SOLVENT AND FROM THIS PROPOSAL.
GO ON WITHOUT A FEE INCREASE
THANK YOU SO THE THESE -- THE
MOTOR VEHICLE CAO FUNDS THE
HIGHER CONTROL CORRECT.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST SO
WHAT WOULD THE THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT BY HAVING MORE
REQUIREMENTS ON IT.
FROM -- DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES -- I WAS SO IT HAS LESS.
FUNDS THAT WILL BE FLEXIBLE.
THERE -- FOR IF THE LEGISLATURE
WANTED.
TO FUND -- HIGHER PATROL
INCREASES OR BASED ON THE
POPULATION.
YOU KNOW INCREASES IN CALIFORNIA --
YOU KNOW THE YOU KNOW AND SO
FORTH BECAUSE THAT'S NORMALLY
WHAT YOU WANT TO LOOK AT HIGHER
CONTROL AS SOON.
IT'S LIKE YOU WANT TO INCREASE
IT BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
DRIVERS YOU HAVE OUT THERE THE
NUMBER OF OF THE POPULATION OF
THE STATE -- THINGS LIKE YOUR
ACCIDENT RATES.
TRYING TO REDUCE SAFETY.
SO SO I'M KIND OF WONDERING HOW
IT IS -- SPENDING IN THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNTY -- AFFECT THE
HIGHWAY PATROL.
BUDGET OVER THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
SO WE LOOK AT ALL DEPARTMENTS
BUDGETS EACH YEAR -- AS I SAID
DURING ON YOUR CURRENT FORECASTS
[inaudible]
THE NBA WOULD DROP TO A LOW OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION SO IF
YOU WANTED TO FOR INCREASED.
EXPENDITURES BEYOND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED.
THUS FAR FOR THE HIGHWAY PATROL --
YOU WOULD EITHER BE DIPPING INTO
THAT RESERVE OR YOU WOULD HAVE
TO ADJUST OTHER EXPENDITURES OR
REVENUE SOURCES FOR THE ONE
FIFTY FIVE RESERVE.
IS OVER A LIKE -- FOUR AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLAR FUND.
THAT'S ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION.
OF RESERVES ON A FOR HALF
BILLION DOLLARS MOTOR VEHICLE
FUND RIGHT.
PRACTICE LESS IT IS.
LESS A SADDLE VERY SMALL RESERVE
YES.
WE LIKE 55% RESERVE WHICH WOULD
BE CLOSER TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
HOWEVER THE CHP AND DMV
HISTORICALLY HAVE MANAGED.
ON AS LOW AS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR RESERVE WE WOULD PREFER
OBVIOUSLY HIGHER RESERVE BUT IN
ORDER TO FIND ALL OF THE THE
NEEDS WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR SPEECH BE
SOME -- ONE TIME FUNDING WITH
GENERAL FUND GIVEN THE
CRITICALITY OF C. H. P.'S --
NEEDS AS WELL AS THE CONDITION
OF THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT.
OKAY DID YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION
ABOUT THE FEE INCREASES OVER THE
FIVE YEARS.
OUR CURRENT PROPOSAL DOES NOT
REQUIRE A FEE INCREASE OVER THE
LISTING OF FEEDING CREWS ARE NOT.
NOT THE SURE IN THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD.
BASED ON OUR CURRENT ASSUMPTIONS
THAT WOULD NOT BE NEEDED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL LET'S MOVE ON TO HEAR FROM
THE SENATE BILL SO I'M SORRY.
IF I MAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
DISTURBING.
TO SEE THE DEFERRAL OF THESE
MONIES THAT HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED AWAY.
AND NOW WHAT YOU'RE ASKING THE
ADDITIONAL NOT COULD NOT BE JUST.
TO APPROPRIATIONS OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND.
THE MONEY'S THERE DEFERRED AWAY
MEAN THE MONIES FOR THE WE'RE
NOT WE'RE GONNA NOT.
GONNA.
PAY WITH A FIVE YEAR KIND OF HEY
HIATUSES.
WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING?
FROM THE FROM THE REPAYMENT OF
THE YES FOR FUNDS OKAY IT'S A
GOOD NEWS THAT.
WERE TRAINED PAYING ATTENTION TO
BRING IT BACK BUT IT'S VERY BAD
NEWS IT WAS EVER DONE BUT THAT
SAID [inaudible]
THEN.
ARE YOU CONTEMPLATING ADDITIONAL
REVENUES THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED GOING FORWARD.
WE'RE GOING TO DERIVE THAT FROM
THE GENERAL FUND.
IN THE C. P. OR HOW DO YOU
INTEND TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
SO OUR CURRENT PLAN -- DOES NOT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL -- GENERAL
FUND TRANSFERS.
INTO THE NBA IT DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE A FEE INCREASE IT
DOES NOT AT THE MOMENT
ANTICIPATE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOM A
GENERAL FUND BEYOND WHAT IS.
IS CURRENTLY PROPOSED OBVIOUSLY
IT WILL BE A YEAR BY YEAR
ASSESSMENT OF HAVE NEEDS GOING
FORWARD THIS IS A FINE FAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATUREMONITOR VERY CLOSELY
EVERY YEAR -- BUT AT THIS POINT
WE HAVE A SOLVENT MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT -- GOING.
FOR IT AND WHAT IS THE ARE
ARGUMENT FOR UTILIZING REVENUE
BONDS FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY.
BY THE PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUND.
HAS BEEN USED TO FUNDS --
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS FOR MANY
DIFFERENT ENTITIES IN THE STATE
THAT THIS PART OF ITS PURPOSE
THE THE ARGUMENT.
THAT -- SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE ALREADY HAD -- THROUGH.
THERE ARE WORKING DRAWINGS AND
THEY'RE READY TO GO TO
CONSTRUCTION -- FUNDING THEM
WITH THE BILLING CONSTRUCTIN
FUND WILL NOT ONLY ALLOW THEM TO
GO FORWARD.
BUT WELL THERE WILL BE SOME COST
INCREASES THEY ARE OFFSET BY THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY DOING
THEM NOW BECAUSE THERE'S OF
COURSE THE GROWTH.
ON WHEN YOU DELAY A PROJECT
CONSTRUCTION COSTS GET GREATER
AND SO -- OVER SEVERAL YEARS IT
WOULD IT WOULD NOT OUT WHILE
STILL ALLOWING THESE PROJECTS GO
FORWARD.
BUT IT IS IN A REVENUE BOND AND
THAT COULD BE A GREATER EXPENSE
THE STATE WOULD NOT.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT WE FOR
THAT THE CONSTRUCTION PROCEEDS
NOW THERE IS IN THE INCREASED
COST OF DEBT SERVICE.
BUT BACK.
ABSOLUTELY 20% BUT IF YOU DELAY
THAT SAME PROJECT BY FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS BECAUSE YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIND IT ON A CASH
BASIS -- THAT AMOUNT GETS EATEN
UP BY INFLATED CONSTRUCTION
COSTS.
OKAY
.
THANK YOU I WAS GONNA IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION
EARLIER SENATOR MORLOCK ABOUT
HOW AS A SITTING MEMBER YOU CAN
FEEL CONNECTED -- WE WANT -- THE
ACTING DIRECTOR TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE TIME TO GIVE HER FULL
ATTENTION -- TO STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS THE REPORT THAT
HE'S DEVELOPING THE METRICS --
AND SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT ALL
OF US CALL AND SCHEDULE A MEET
GREET WITH HER.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
CITY MEMBER THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THAT IS OUR OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW
IN BETWEEN -- OFFICIAL HEARINGS
LIKE THAT LIKE THIS THAT WHEN
THERE ARE DEPARTMENTS THAT WE
HAVE A PARTICULAR INTEREST IN BE
IT BASED ON A COMMITTEES SERVE
ON OR WHAT HAVE YOU OR CALLS WE
GET FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS IT
THAT.
WE DO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE REACH OUT TO
THE DEPARTMENTS AND IF IT'S NOT
THE ACTING DIRECTOR THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON SHE
DESIGNATES IN A DEPARTMENT. TO
COME IN ONE ON ONE AND GIVE US
THE INFORMATION WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S THE OPTION AVAILABLE TO
US ALL.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE CITY
MEMBERS AND WITH THE ACTING
DIRECTING NOT IN -- I'M GLAD TO
KNOW THAT SHE AGREES.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS SENATOR
NIELSEN.
WITH THE REAL ID AN
IMPLEMENTATION.
COULDN'T SOME OF THIS.
DEFERRAL OF THE PAYMENT BACK.
SHOULDN'T SOME OF THAT BE FAST
FORWARDED AND USED.
FOR THE REAL ID WHAT IS IT THEY
HAVE TO BE STE.
THIS.
IT'S NOT FORGIVEN BUT SET ASIDE
FOR SO LONG BUT IT'S NOT A
DEFERRAL IF I'M AND THE SNOW
THAT IF THE WELL IT FORMALLY.
IT WAS.
IT WAS A IT WAS BORROWED CORRECT.
WHO IS THE STREET HELLO?
OKAY I'M SO I WAS A TRANSFER.
THERE'S AN ANNUAL THERE HAS BEEN
SINCE NINE TEN THERE'S BEEN AN
ANNUAL TRANSFERRED IN THE BUDGET
ACT IT'S BASED ON THE PRIOR YOUR
ACTUAL AMOUNTS THAT WERE
COLLECTED BY DMV.
AND WE ARE PROPOSING TO SUSPEND
THAT SO IT WOULDN'T COME.
AFTER THE FIVE YEARS WELL TAKE A
LOOK AT IT BUT AT THIS POINT
IT'S NOT A LOAN A REPAIRMAN IT'S
A WE ARE NOT GOING TO TRANSFER
THOSE MONIES OUT OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT INTO.
THE GENERAL FUND. FOR FIVE YEARS.
BUT THAT SPARES.
ANY DRAW ON THE GENERAL FUND
CORRECT [inaudible]
BUT THAT GENERAL FUND MONEY IS
NOT GOING TO BE JUST.
IT'S GOING TO BE SPENT SOMEWHERE
ELSE CORRECT.
SO IN TERMS OF OVERALL BUDGET
IMPACT.
IT'S NOT BEEN ANY RELIEF FOR
BENEFIT.
SO WHAT IS THE RATIONALE. FOR
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
HOW ARE YOU MAKING IT MORE
EFFICIENT MORE EFFECTIVE LESS
COSTLY? SEVEN IN ESSENCE A
DEFINED SHIFT RATHER EVENT LIKE
TO POINT YOU'RE SAYING IF WE DID
NOT SUSPEND THE TRANSFER WE
COULD FIND AT THIS PROPOSAL WITH
GENERAL FUND ALTERNATIVELY WE
SUSPEND THE TRANSFER.
AND WE FIND IT WITHIN VA.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE SLEEP FROM LA I'LL -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS A REFERENCE TO
HER EARLIER -- WE HAVE PREPARED
SOME ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION IF YOU TRY TO THE
HANDOUT THAT WE DISTRIBUTED
EARLIER WE'RE GONNA START ON
PAGE SIX OF YOUR HAND OUT.
IN TOTAL WE HAVE SEVEN ISSUES
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN REALLY
OUR PERSPECTIVE IN IDENTIFYING
THESE IS TO HOLD THE LEGISLATURE
THING THROUGH.
THE THE PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE
THEM AS WELL THINKING ABOUT ON
AN ONGOING BASIS WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING LEVELS
SHOULD BE.
THE FIRST ONE I'LL JUST GO OVER
REALLY BRIEFLY BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT IT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLEAR OUT COMING PERFORMANCE
MEASURES.
BEING A TOOL FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ENSURING THAT LEGISLATIVE
EXPECTATIONS ARE MET.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT THIS
REQUEST IS BASED ON A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS -- FERRIS OPTIONS ON
HOW INDIVIDUALS REACT TO THINGS
LIKE THE REAL ID -- DEADLINE AS
WELL AS THE VARIOUS ACTIVITIES
AT THE DMV SEE IN SEEKING TO
IMPLEMENT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
INDIVIDUALS REACT IN THAT COULD
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT SO FOR
EXAMPLE. ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT
WAS MENTIONED IS SOFTWARE TO
VALIDATE SOME OF THIS
DOCUMENTATION THAT WE WOULD BE
PROVIDED FOR INDIVIDUALS GO IN.
THAT ACTUALLY WRITTEN THAT IS A
GREAT TOOL IF IT WORKS
EFFECTIVELY AND AS INTENDED
HOWEVER IT DOES ALSO REYES KIND
OF PRIVACY CONCERNS IT'S UNCLEAR
THE EXTENT TO WHICH INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE COMFORTABLE.
WITH SHARING THINGS LIKE THEIR
AND NAME ORSOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER DATE OF BIRTH
ELECTRONICALLY.
OUR THIRD ISSUE FOR
CONSIDERATION THE BOTTOM OF THIS
PAGE IS THAT THE NET IMPACT OF
ALL OF THE VARIOUS PROPOSED
ACTIVITIES IS REALLY UNCLEAR.
SO A NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES ARE
DESIGNED TO SHIFT INDIVIDUALS
OUT OF THE FIELD OFFICE AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT SHIFT IS
APPROPRIATE. FOR A IS
SUCCESSFULLY ACCOMPLISH I SHOULD
SAY HE WILL THEN HAVE EMPLOYEES
WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY HANDLING
THAT WORKLOAD THAT COULD BE
REDIRECTED TO HANDLE REAL ID
WORKLOAD.
INTO THE NET IMPACT IS REALLY
KIND OF UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE.
SEVEN OUR FOURTH ISSUE IS --
THIS IS THIS ISSUE ABOUT SHORT
TERM VERSUS LONG TERM ACTIVITIES
AND SO YOU HAVE THAT OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE AND SO.
IN THINKING ABOUT THE CAPACITY
OF THE DMV AND THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO FOCUS
ON THAT -- WE'VE HEARD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A WORK PLAN FOR
THE LONG TERM THAT'S ACTUALLY A
REALLY GOOD THING. TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE IS KIND OF MOVING
FORWARD IN A DELIBERATE EVAN
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER RATHER THAN
DOING IT PIECEMEAL MANNER
BECAUSE IF YOU MOVE FORWARD IN A
PIECEMEAL MANNER YOU MIGHT END
UP -- USING RESOURCES IN IT AND
EFFECTIVE MANNER IN THE LONG RUN.
THE FIFTH ISSUE THAT WE WANT TO
RAISE YOUR ATTENTION IS THAT ALL
OF THE VARIOUS PENDING
EVALUATIONS -- THE PROTOTYPING
AND THE PILOTS COULD REALLY VAN
IMPACT THE MIX OVERALL LEVEL OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED SO AN
EASY EXAMPLE FOR THAT IS IF THE
FIELD OFFICE EXPERIENCE OR JUST
HOW THE FIELD OFFICES ARE
CONSTRUCTED REALLY CHANGES.
pLEVEL OF RESOURCES AND IT'S
UNCLEAR AT THIS TIME WHETHER
WE'D BE REDIRECTING RESOURCES OR
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WOULD
BE REQUESTED THROUGH THE
PROVISIONAL PROCESS.
THE SIXTH ISSUE TOWARDS THE
BOTTOM IS THAT.
THE EXISTING CHALLENGES WITH --
THE MOVE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND JUST SIMPLY
CAPACITY ISSUES YOU HAVE SO MANY
FIELD OFFICES COULD REALLY
IMPACT HOW EFFECTIVELY THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES ARE USED.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HEARD
THE AUDIT RAISES THIS ISSUE
ABOUT INEFFECTIVE -- ALLOCATION
OF RESOURCES THERE'S A REQUEST
FOR A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND SO IT TO THE EXTENT
WE DON'T KIND OF ADDRESS THAT IT
MAY MEAN THAT WERE NOT USING THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE MANNER.
TURNING TO THE FINAL PAGE WE
CANNOT PAGE EIGHT THE LAST ISSUE
FOR CONSIDERATION IS REALLY
CONSIDERING THE ONGOING LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT THAT'S APPROPRIATE
REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH FUNDING
IS PROVIDED. TO YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THE UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS
OF ASSUMPTIONS EVALUATIONS
ETCETERA.
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING LIMITED TERM
FUNDING THIS WOULD REQUIRE DMV
TO COME BACK AND JUSTIFY HOW THE
VIEWS THE REQUESTED RESOURCES
THAT WERE PROVIDED.
REASSESS THEIR PROCESS SEE IN
THE MEANTIME AND THEN JUSTIFY
ANY FUTURE REQUESTS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE CONDITION OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT WHICH WE TALKED
ABOUT -- BRIEFLY JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
A SECOND ISSUE HERE IS.
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE DOES
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES.
IT WITH ONE OF THE SECTION
LETTERS BY THE TIME THE
DEPARTMENT HAD SUBMITTED THE
REQUEST AND THEY HAVE ACTUALLY
ALREADY SPENT HALF OF ALMOST
HALF OF THE FUNDING.
AND IF YOU DO THAT THAT REALLY
LIMITS JUST LEADERS ABILITY TO
KIND OF EVALUATE THE CAUSES
BEHIND THAT AND TAKE ALTERNATIVE
ACTION IF NECESSARY AND SO ONE
THING LEGISLATURE CONSIDER IS.
REQUIRING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
SEEK LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL BEFORE
INCURRING ANY ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES.
AND THEN OUR FINAL COMMENT HERE
IS JUST THINKING ABOUT WHAT THE
REPORTING WOULD BE HELPFUL IT
COULD BE THE WAIT TIME REPORT
THAT WAS NOT WITH MENTION A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BUT IT CAN ALSO INCLUDE OTHER
METRICS AND THAT IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT GIVEN THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE OTHER
CHANGES -- IN TERMS OF SHIFTING
WORKLOAD OWL BUT ALSO GOVERNANCE
CHANGES REDESIGNING FIELD
OFFICES EXCITER AND SO. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP UP UPDATED
AND ESSENTIALLY -- TO CONDUCT A
REGULAR OVERSIGHT SUCH
INFORMATION COULD BE REALLY
REALLY HELPFUL.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IF YOU HAVE THEM.
THANK YOU I I APPRECIATE THAT
PROPOSALS AND I THINK -- GIVEN
MY COMMENTS EARLIER ALL ASWE
TALK ABOUT A CULTURE SHIFT THAT
THAT THAT WHILE THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF ACTIONS THAT ARE AT OUR
DISPOSAL THAT THE LEGISATURE
UTILIZING THE PASSWORDS MORE OF
A CARROT STICK APPROACH.
I THINK WE I WANT US TO THINK
CREATIVELY.
ON TO GO BE ON THIS LIST
COLLEAGUES IN TERMS OF WAYS IN
WHICH THAT WE REALLY CAN'T PRO
ACTIVELY ENGAGE -- SO IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF WE HOLD THE PURSE
STRINGS YOU KNOW ON A KIND OF
STEP BY STEP BASIS AS WE GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS -- UNLESS WE
FEEL -- AS A LET'S THAT BODY
THAT'S THAT'S OUR ONLY OPTION
AVAILABLE TO US BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ENGAGED IN TERMS OF
REALLY COMING UP WITH
PERSPECTIVE SOLUTIONS --
QUESTION SENATOR ROBB THE
MANAGER I ASSUME IN RESPONSE TO
THE CHEERS EARLIER QUESTION IN
THE INDICATION THAT WE WOULD SEE
THE BUSINESS PLAN THE ACTION
PLAN AND AND THE PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
USED TO ASSESS SUCCESS OR
FAILURE HERE THAT.
THAT THAT PLAN AND THOSE
PERFORMANCE METRICS WILL ROUTE
REFLECT THE THE REPORTS THAT THE
LA -- WAS.
AS ADDRESSING HERE IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S IMPORTANT WHETHER IT'S
WAIT TIMES WHETHER IT'S
ABSENTEEISM ALL THE OTHER --
ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PERFORMANCE ON IT.
I ASSUME WE WILL SEE THOSE AND
AND WHAT'S FOURTH COMING FROM
YOU MA'AM.
YEAH AND THE TIMING OF WHEN YOU
RECEIVE IT I'M LIKE I CAN'T
COMMIT TO BUT I WILL -- ASSURE
YOU THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE THAT BEFORE
YOU FINALIZE.
YOUR DECISION SO I THINK EVERY
EFFORT IS BEING MADE TO GET IT
TO YOU AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
I THINK YOUR POINT ON THE
MEASURES AND AND I AGREE WITH
THE LA -- ON ON THEIR GUIDELINES.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE A MENU
OF OPTIONS AVAILABLE WHEN YOU
SEE THE PLAN AND I THINK THE KEY
THING IS WHAT ARE THE KEY
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES.
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO YOU
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY SHARE A
WORK TOGETHER AND WE CAN PROVIDE
REPORTS BACK TO YOU WANNA.
I THINK IS INDICATOR EARLIER WE
ALREADY ARE DOING A MONTHLY
REPORT -- ON THE THROUGH THE
JAIL BC PROCESS.
ON THE WAIT TIMES BUT I THINK --
MAYBE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RE EXAMINE ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
STILL WANT TO REPORT ON ARE
THERE SOME NEW THINGS WE NEED TO
REPORT ON AND WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE SILICON INFORM YOU --
MICHAEL IF I'M I'M ABLE TO GO
HEAD CONTINUE IN THESE EFFORTS
ULTIMATELY IS YOU WOULD FIND A
DASHBOARD ON THE DMV WEBSITE.
THAT'S IDENTIFYING OUR
PERFORMANCE MEASURES -- THAT
WOULD BE MY GOAL IN BRINGING IN
A CONSULTANT TO WORK WITH ME TO
ESTABLISH BOTH GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
AS WELL AS A PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT CULTURE -- AND THEN
WE WILL BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT HOW
WE'RE ACTUALLY PERFORMING AS
ORGANIZATION FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
IN YOUR CONSTITUENCY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR MOORE Là.
THANK YOU -- POLICIES THAT I DID
NOT HEAR ALL THE TESTIMONY BUT
HI.
I AM -- JUMPING TO AN ASSUMPTION
THAT THERE MAY HAVE BEEN SOME
QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT WHETHER
JUST ADDING MORE PEOPLE.
IS GOING TO REALLY ADDRESS YES
ISSUES AND WHAT I KNOW IS THAT
UNLESS THE DATA I HAVE THIS
WRONG WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DMV OFFICES IN CALIFORNIA
IS THAT CORRECT.
BUILD OFFICES A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO ACTUAL FIELD OFFICES
OKAY SO AND THE NUMBER OF TOTAL
PEOPLE.
BEING INCLUDED A BEING INCREASES
IN ORDER OF ITS IN NINETEEN
HUNDRED WORDS CLOSE TO TWO
THOUSAND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY PROVED WHAT WERE
HE AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
ACROSS THAT NUMBER OF OFFICES
THAT.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND FIVE YEAH BUT IT AGAIN IT
MAY SEEM.
BOTH COULD BE CONSIDERED SMALL
NUMBER PEOPLE OF PEOPLE IS
REALLY ISSUE OR A LARGE NUMBER
PEOPLE GET DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
ISSUE IS.
AND IF THEIR TEMPORARY AND NOT
FULLY TRAINED BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE PART OF THE PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS THIS IS A NEW PROCESS
AND SO YOU KNOW WILL THEY BE
ADEQUATELY TRAINED AND IF WE ARE.
GOING TO BE MOVING TO SOME
CHANGES IN SOFTWARE. FOR CHANGES
IN -- GETTING.
TRYING HOPE TO GET MATERIALS
ELECTRONICALLY AGAIN IT'S LIKE.
IS THIS ARE THESE PEOPLE WILL BE
THE WILL THEY BE TRAINED OR WELL
OUR EXISTING PERMANENT STAFF SO.
IT'S I HAVE NOT READ THE DEAL
LAUGHS PERFORMANCE AUDIT YET I
KNOW THE THAT DMV'S NOW ENGAGED
VACANCY.
BUT IT'S JUST SEEMS LIKE BEFORE.
I MEAN I HAVE NO PROBLEM
ASSISTING THE DMV AND I WANT TO
IMPROVE THE CUSTOMER WITH THEIR
MONEY SPENT WELL YES PEOPLE
DYING AND CLARITY AROUND HOW
MANY PEOPLE AND OUR THEY'RE
GOING EXACTLY SO.
YES.
OFFER -- KIND OF A WHAT I CALL
AN ENTERPRISE VIEW AND THEN I'M
GETTING INTO SOME OF THE PEOPLE
NUMBERS ROBBIE I KNOW IS CAPABLE
ADDRESSING THOSE IN DETAIL.
I AGREE THAT JUST THREE PEOPLE
AT A PROBLEM IS NOT A IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE BEST THING TO DO BUT
I WILL TELL YOU IN THE LIGHT OF
THE REAL ID SITUATION THAT DOES
REQUIRE FACE TO FACE.
INTERACTIONS REQUIRES US TO HAVE
PEOPLE IT COUNTERS WORKING ON
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS THIS DOES
REQUIRE A PEOPLE -- ENGAGEMENT --
WITH THE GUARDS -- TO THE STAFF
THAT WE ARE BRINGING ON BAR
REMEMBER THAT MOST OF THOSE ARE
TEMPORARY POSITIONS THAT WE'RE
BRINGING ON BOARD.
BUT I FIND INTERESTING THE
CONVERSATION THE LA BROUGHT UP
AND IT'S VERY TRUE IN ANY GOOD
WORK FORCE PLAN YOU ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR SUCCESSION
PLANNING.
AND DMV DOES HAVE SUCCESSION
PLANNING -- AREAS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING OUT.
I SEE THIS OPPORTUNITY ALSO IS
AS FOLKS MAY RETIRE OUT A DMV IT
KIND OF GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING IN PEOPLE TO SEE IF
THEY WOULD BE ACTUALLY A GOOD
PERMANENT EMPLOYEE COMING ONTO.
THE DMV BUT TO YOUR POINT AS WE
LOOK AT CHANGING OUR BUSINESS
MODEL TO ACCOUNT FOR A WALK IN.
CALL IN AND CLICK AND THOSE ARE
REALLY THE THREE MODES AND ONE
IS OUR MIND YOU IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'LL BE PLENTY OF
PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE TO DO
BUSINESS WITH US THROUGH THEIR
PHONE.
AND THEIR COMPUTER BUT I WILL
ALSO TELL YOU OPEN OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE ARE PEOPLE
WOULD PREFER TO WALK IN AND DO
BUSINESS WITH US AT OUR OFFICE.
SO WE NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR
ALL THREE MODES OF OPERATION TO
SERVE HIM BUT YOUR POINT WE WANT
TO MEASURE THE TRAFFIC.
YEAH MEASURE THE APPROPRIATE
STAFFING LEVELS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO ADDRESS THAT COMMUNITIES
NEEDS AND HOW BEST TO SERVICE
THEM SO -- YES THIS IS PERMANENT
HELP OR BRING IN TO ADDRESS AN
IMMEDIATE NEED FOR REAL ID WE DO
HAVE A TRAINING PLAN -- I THINK
THE STAFF WE'VE BROUGHT ON BOARD%
OR ALREADY TREATING -- WE HAVE
THE THREE HUNDRED STAFF AND
WE'VE ARE CREATED TO TRAINING
MODULE FOR THE THREE HUNDRED
STAFFER ASKING.
FOR AND THEN THE OTHER THING I
WOULD HAVE THAT'S MUCH MORE
MODERN AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO OFFICES --
YOU ABSOLUTELY NEED IT IS
BRINGING ON E. LEARNING.
AND LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
GIVES US THAT FLEXIBILITY TO
PROVIDE CONSISTENT STATEWIDE
TRAINING THAT PEOPLE CAN DO IT A
DESKTOP AND WE CAN PROVIDE THAT
FROM AN ONBOARDING STANDPOINT.
IF THERE'S EVER A REFRESHER
COURSE BASED ON THE EMPLOYEES
SEATS AS WELL.
AND IN SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED
HER WAYS BY OTHER MEMBERS --
ALSO SEND TO SCAN I WANT YOU TO
BE CAUGHT FOR THAT AS WELL AS
THE THE DATA POINT THE CAME UP
AS A RESULT.
OF THE AUDIT WHICH TALKED ABOUT
THE ABSENTEEISM RATE THAT THE
OBSERVER IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF
WINDOWS THAT WERE.
EMPTY NOT STAFFED AND THAT WAS
DISCUSSED AS WELL AS I ASK%
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO QUEUE
UP WITH THE STANDING MIKE TO GET
READY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD
JUST.
SAY TO ACTING DIRECTOR WEB I
THINK ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE LA L.
THAT SECOND BULLET THAT REALLY
TALKED ABOUT.
ALL THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE THAT THE DM B. C.
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL BEFORE
INCURRING ADDITIONAL SPENDING IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH YOU WANT SPECIFICALLY.
I'M SORRY SENATOR MORLOCK.
JUST BECAUSE I'M SITTING WAY OUT
HERE.
JUST MAYBE TO SUMMARIZE -- I
LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THE TERM IN A ROW PRICE
VIEW THAT YOU JUST USED BUT YOU
ALREADY HAVE EXISTING RESOURCES
YOU ARE A MAJOR REVENUE SOURCE
FOR THE STATE WITH THE VEHICLE
LICENSE FEES AND NOW THAT'S
EXPANDED WITH THE GAS TAX --
THAT'S JUST BEEN APPROVED DO YOU
CHARGE OTHER FEES ARE THOSE
RETAINED IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
[inaudible]
YEP.
THE DEPARTMENT COLLECTS ABOUT
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF
THAT.
ABOUT. TWO AND A HALF TO THREE
BILLION IS MOTOR VEHICLE COME
MONIES FOR THE MOTOR VEHICLE
MONEY IS THE MONEY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT UTILIZES ALL THE
OTHER REMAINING COLLECTIONS THAT
WE DO GOOD OTHER FUNDS.
THAT WE DO NOT USE THAT ARE YOU
BUT LIKE AN ENTERPRISE FUND YOU
FIND YOURSELF.
CORRECT WE LIVE MOTOR VEHICLE
OUT WE ALSO GET AN APPROPRIATION
FROM THE STATE HIGHWAY COUNT
ASSOCIATE WITH THE WAY THINGS
THAT WE COLLECT.
AND THEN ALSO FOR THE MOTOR
VEHICLE LICENSE FEE SO THAT'S
FOR THE VLF.
COM AND SO THOSE ARE THE THREE
MAIN FUNDS THAT WE GET FROM A
PREPARATION IT'S A MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT AS THE MAIN ONE WHICH IS
THE THING FUND AS MUCH EARLIER
THAN THAT TAMBIéN SEATS BE IT'S
ONE OF FOUR AND THEN -- STATE
HIGHWAY COUNTY LATE FEES AND THE
MOTOR VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
ACCOUNT WHICH IS FOR THE VLF.
SO YOU'VE BEEN FINDING YOURSELF
NOW WE'RE GIVING YOU MORE MONEY.
WE'RE NOT RAISING FEES.
AND WE DEPLETED A MOTOR VOTER
VEHICLE ACCOUNT OR WE'VE BEEN
PULLING AT LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION OUT OF THAT
ACCOUNT. TO THE GENERAL FUND FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS SO THAT'S A
REVENUE SOURCE TO THE STATE AS
OPPOSED TO YOUR DEPARTMENT IS --
IS THAT A TRANSFER IS THAT ALONE
IS THAT A AT THE MOMENT OF MY
COMMUNITY.
PARTNERSHIP FINANCE THAT'S
THAT'S JUST AN ANNUAL BUDGETARY
TRANSFER.
SO IT'S LIKE REVENUE TO THE
GENERAL FUND IN ITS.
THANK YOU DMV AND THAT'S IT.
THE NUMBER WE'RE HAPPY TO SEND
THAT BACK NOW.
DURING THIS [inaudible]
PEAK PERIOD.
THE CORRECT WE I MEAN THE THE
REVENUES -- HOWEVER I CAN SPEAK
TO THE THE DETAILS OF THAT THE
THE REVENUES ARE PRIMARILY FROM
THAT THE SALE OF INFORMATION THE
DMV HAS TO INSURANCE COMPANIES.
RIGHT SO IN MINUTES AT THE TO
GET INTO PRICING A WE WERE
PROVIDING THE INFORMATION BUT
WE'RE ALSO CHARGING THE
COMPANIES FOR IT.
AND SO -- AS SUCH IT DOESN'T
HAVE ARTICLE NINETEEN
LIMITATIONS TO IT AND SO IT'S
BEEN LONG TERM CONSIDER GENERAL
FUND REVENUE.
THAT THE DMV COLLECTS BUT IN
THIS CASE WERE PROPOSING A FIVE
YEAR SUSPENSION OF THE THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH FANFARE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THE GENERAL
PUBLIC WE HAVE.
TO PROMISED HER ACTING CHAIRMAN
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
I JUST WANTED -- TO I'M FROM.
CAN DRIVING RECORDS ARE BASED IN
RANCHO CORDOVA.
SO I KNOW THE GOVERNOR SAID YOU
WANT TO BRING SILICON VALLEY TO
THE DMV WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A
RANCHO CORDOVA IS AN AND SILICON
VALLEY BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
GREAT CALIFORNIA OMPANIES THAT
ALREADY.
DO BUSINESS WITH THE DMV AND I
HAVE BEEN DOING BUSINESS WITH
THE DMV SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX MORE THAN HALF MY LIFETIME
NOW.
AND I WANT TO JUST SAY THAT THIS
IS A NEW ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
OVER THERE.
I THINK IS DOING A PHENOMENAL
JOB I THINK.
ARE THE DEPARTMENT HAS ABOUT
TWELVE DEPUTY DIRECTORS I THINK.
I THINK I KNOW ALMOST ALL OF
THEM THEY ARE EXTREMELY.
TALENTED TALENTED PEOPLE WITH
LOTS OF GOOD IDEAS AND I AND I
FEEL LIKE.
THIS GROUP THAT IS IN THERE NOW
AND THE STRIKE TEAM ARE REALLY
LISTENING TO THEM MORE THAN
ANYBODY ELSE HAS THEY I DO
BUSINESS WITH FIFTY STATES AND
I'M NOT JUST SAYING THIS BECAUSE
I'M IN CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK
YOU HAVE.
SOME OF THE MORE STE TALENTED
PEOPLE THE MOST EDUCATED PEOPLE
AND THE MOST EDUCATED PEOPLE IN
THAT DEPARTMENT VERSUS.
ANY OTHER DMV I'VE BEEN TO OUR
WORKED WITH AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF I WANT TO GIVE
YOU A POSITIVE STORY I GUESS.
AND I DID WANT TO ANSWER FOR
SENATOR STONE'S QUESTION ABOUT
THE TRIPLE A THEY DO NOT HAVE AN
AXE THEY DO NOT OF EXCLUSIVITY.
THERE'S FOR OTHER COMPANIES
INCLUDING OUR COMPANY THAT ARE
CALLED BUSINESS PARTNER
AUTOMATION.
OP PARTNERS AND SO WE SUPPORT A
LOT OF THE MOM AND POP
REGISTRATION PEOPLE YOU SEE IF
YOU GO DOWN THE STREET AND SAY
WE CAN GET YOU STICKERS.
WE SUPPORT THEM SO WE ARE THE
INTERMEDIARY BETWEEN THEM BUT I
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME
GLIMMERS OF GOOD NEWS YOU DO
HAVE GREAT PEOPLE OVER THERE.
HAVE DEDICATED PEOPLE THERE AND
I THINK YOU KNOW HAVE LEADERSHIP
THAT IS LISTENING TO THE DEPUTY
DIRECTORS WHO HAVE A LOT OF
GREAT IDEAS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR I'M SURE THOSE
FOLKS APPRECIATE SOME FAVORABLE
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
GOOD MORNING -- TUNE GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT GREG HAYES ON
BEHALF OF INTELLECTUAL
TECHNOLOGY INK -- MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE I. T.
I. IT MAKES THE DMV KIOSKS THE
SELF SERVICE TERMINALS -- THAT --
THEY'RE SEEKING TO EXPAND THIS
YEAR FIRST OF ALL WE WANT TO
COMMEND SECRETARY BADGER THE
STRIKE TEAM.
AND ACTING DIRECTOR WEB ON THE
WORK THEY'RE DOING THEY
INHERITED.
SIGNIFICAN NUMBER OF LEGACY
PROBLEMS THAN THEIR ACTING VERY
QUICKLY TO PUT -- SOLUTIONS IN
PLACE THE JUST AS A REMINDER
THIS COMMITTEE THE WAY THE SELF
SERVICE TERMINALS ARE OUT
FUNDING ALLOCATION WORKS IS -- I
TI PAYS FOR THE KIOSKS AND THEN
THE ALLOCATION WORKS ON A PER
TRANSACTION BASIS.
SO -- WE'RE VERY INVESTED IN THE
LOCATIONS OF THESE TERMINALS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET TO THE
PLACES WHERE CONSUMERS AGAIN USE
THE MOST AND I ALSO WANT TO
UNDERSCORE VIEW IT ESPECIALLY
FOR THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THESE TERMINALS HAVE LIMITED USE
AT THE MOMENT BECAUSE OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE HISTORICAL --
COMPUTER SYSTEMS AT THE ENVY THE
MAINFRAMES AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
TO WORK WITH THE DMV TO EXPAND
THE USE OF THOSE SO WE CAN
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE TRAIN --
TRAFFIC INTO THE DMV FIELD
OFFICES AND LOOK TO EXPAND THE
USE OF THOSE FOR CONSUMERS AND
GET THE MINUTE PLACES WHERE THEY
CAN USE THE MOST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT THIS
KIOSK THING IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT DO YOU VIEW THIS IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM GOING
TO TAKE A LOT OF TIME TO SOLVE
AND AND MAIL THAT WITH THE
EXISTING SYSTEM TO DMV HE WAS A
PRIVATE [inaudible]
CONTRACTOR.
YEAH -- SO FIRST OF ALL OUR
COMPANY'S LOCATED DOWN IN -- THE
SAN DIEGO AREA NORTH SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND YES WE DO WORK
REGULARLY WITH THE DMV TO TRY TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM DO YOU VIEW
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
HANDLED IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME IS IS GOING TO BE A
LINGERING.
PROBLEM WE'RE GONNA TAKE SERVICE WORK --
ASPECT OF THE KIOSKS WILL TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME BUT GETTING
THE MORE KIOSKS INTO PLACES THE
BUDGET ALLOCATION PROPOSES WILL
BE HAPPENING THIS YEAR'S A
CONSUMERS CAN ACCESS THOSE
QUICKLY.
IN LOCATIONS THAT THEY FREQUENT
YOU KNOW A DRUGSTORE GROCERY
STORE THAT ALSO HAVE -- LONGER
HOURS THAN THE DMV FIELD OFFICE.
THANK YOU VETERAN WOULD YOU
COMMENT ON THIS SITUATION -- WE
DO HAVE A PLAN AND IT WILL BE
PART OF OUR WORK PLAN GOING
FORWARD TO EXPAND KIOSKS -- AND
I AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS AND
AND YOUR OBSERVATION CENTER
NIELSEN IS THAT IT'S ONE THING
TO HAVE THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
TERRY BUT I WANT MORE SERVICES
AVAILABLE ON THE KIOSK.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM WE HAVE
A PLAN ACTUALLY OF CERTAIN SORT
OF TRANSACTIONS THAT WILL BE
ACTUALLY.
BRINGING INTO THE KIOSK
ENVIRONMENT -- BUT I WANT THEM
ONLINE AS WELL AS THE CHAOS SO
YOU'LL FIND THEM IN BOTH PLACES
SO WHERE IS THE PLAN THIS YEAR --
TO GO HEAD EXPAND THOSE SERVICES
AND ALSO PROVIDED IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES WE ALSO THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I BRING IT UP BECAUSE SO MANY
AGENCIES HAVE HAD SO MUCH
TROUBLE WITH THE I. T. AND THEN
THE IF YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE
THAT COULD BE.
NOT BODE WELL FOR THE FUTURE
THAT'S ALL [inaudible]
HI.
WE THANK YOU.
BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE A HEARING
I'M SURE WE'LL BE DOING MORE
WITH YOU AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY.
THANK YOU ROGER